and make the affirmation today
those members have already been
contacted by my office
there will be further opportunities for
all honourable members to take the oath
or make the affirmation following her
late majesty's funeral there is no
procedural requirement to do so
once we have concluded our tributes to
approximately 10 pm a humble address to
his manchester will be moved formally in
the term set out on the order paper
i will now take the oath of allegiance
before inviting other honourable members
to do so
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and virtual allegiance to his
majesty king charles as hers and
successors according to the law shall be
god
okay
can i
now begin to start with father of the
house so peter bottomly
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successes according to law
i'm just there
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm
that i will be faithful and bear true
allegiance to his majesty king charles
his heirs and successors according to
laws
[Music]
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful
and bear true allegiance to his majesty
king charles his heirs and successes
according to law so help me god
thank you affirmation
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare an affair that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors
according
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successes according to law so help me
god
do swear that i will be faithful and be
of true allegiance to his majesty kenny
charles his hairs and successors
according to life
i solemnly sincerely and truly declare
in the firm that i was faithful and bear
true allegiance to his majesty from
charles his heirs and successors
according to law
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord
so help meet
allegiance to god majesty king charles
his heirs and successors according to
law so help me god
[Applause]
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law
so help me god
almighty god that i will be faithful and
bear true allegiance to his masterpiece
his heirs and successors according to
laws so help me god
and within that scan
i cut them
in all of them
i swear by almighty god i will be
faithful and bear through allegiance to
his mostly king charles his heirs and
successors according to law to help your
god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful in their true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and fair true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help with
god
who needs to stop and do this if
affirmation is doing its own thing
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successes according to law
so help in god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and defer
that i will be faithful and bear true
allegiance to his majesty king charles
his heirs and successors according to
lord
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law
so help me god
bible please
thank you
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful in their true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to law so help me
god
i swear i almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord so help me
god
i swear by almighty god
that i will be faithful and bear true
allegiance to his majesty king charles
his heirs and successors according to
lord
so help me god
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs
and successors according to lord
so help me god
[Applause]
i swear by almighty god that i will be
thankful for their true
his majesty can he charge his heirs and
successes according to law so help me
god
i do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that i will be
faithful and fair true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors according to lord
i swear by almighty god that i will be
faithful and bear true allegiance to his
majesty king charles his heirs and
successors
according to law so help me
god so we can breathe
[Applause]
uh
order i shall now invite the house to
resume its tributes to a late majesty
i expect to conclude tributes
up till 10 o'clock and at that time i
should invite the minister to move the
motion from a humble address to his
majesty
182 members contributed yesterday i know
many want to do so today i hope
therefore the members will keep to the
informal time limit of no more than
three minutes
i now invite
the deputy prime minister
dr therese coffey
well first of all mr speaker i'd like to
thank you for allowing government
ministers to be able to participate in
this debate today i really do appreciate
it and i know that my constituents from
suffolk coastal will do so too
the constancy that her late majesty the
queen gave us through decades whether as
a child it was uh personally with the
silver jubilee indeed all the
celebrations that we had for golden uh
the diamond and in particular most
recently the platinum as well as all the
commemorations of e day and moments when
the queen brought this nation together
both recognizing sad times as well as
those points at the cenotaph but also
the celebration of what makes our
country great
just thinking about my mother very first
time she watched television
was when uh the coronation happened and
somebody in her town of wrexham nearby
bought a tv and people piled in from
around the surrounding streets in order
to watch the princess of course the
queen by then be crowned
but that impact goes right around the
world and i saw that when i was an
environmental minister
and indeed whether it was in kenya
uganda wherever i went
certainly the queen was held in the
highest regards and there were always
representations made for her
but that sort of impact actually
happened during world war ii as well you
know if i think about the broadcast that
happened by the princesses i remember a
long time ago in 1995 when i went to uh
on as a representative of the united
kingdom as a youth we went to the anne
frank house
and there there were pictures of the
princesses and indeed in the anne frank
diary of the 21st of april 1944
anne frank referred to the 18th birthday
of the then princess
her royal house princess elizabeth of
york
but along the lines of not only wishing
her birthday but also wondering which
prince they'll marry this beauty off to
but that sort of constancy and impact
around the world is something that i am
confident that our new sovereign king
will have as well not only for his work
on the environment but also continuing
the sincere traditions of his mother
turning to suffolk coastal and the
impact there well i will always pay
tribute uh to the savvy parish council
it's renders from parish council who
always put their parish fate on the same
day as the trooping the color because we
get the lineup of all the fly past
coming through constituency
whereas many other places pay for it
but there seemed to be a particular
affection to benjamin britton and oprah
music and
in terms of the
the queen opened snake maltings on the
20th festival in 1967
and when it burned down just a couple
years he ate later
she came back in effect to reopen it as
well
and that affection carried on and i
think it was that love of music that we
may not have always seen so so
self-evident but indeed people will know
in this chamber and elsewhere the
special arrangement of the national
anthem uh that benjamin britton wrote
and that was then further attested
testified by the fact that the queen
authorized the name of only one other
person on the coinage of the realm that
was benjamin britain
in terms of mr speaker i want to say on
behalf of people suffolk coastal how
much they will miss
queen elizabeth ii but also pledge their
loyalty and support to king charles iii
thank you
event cooper
thank you
thank you mr speaker this morning the
accession council met to proclaim the
new sovereign his majesty king charles
iii and it was an immense honor to bear
witness to that historic proclamation
for the privy council but also for my
constituents in normanton pontefract
castleford and nottingly and for us in
pontefract it's particularly important
to mark the arrival of the new king who
as prince has been a huge supporter of
the prince of wales hospice in
pontefract
and an association we have considerably
more positive than our last constituency
connection with the accession of a
monarch with the which involved
pontefract castle richard ii and a
rather unfortunate end
mr speaker it's an honor today to speak
in the second day of tributes to her
majesty to a truly remarkable queen
and everyone has their memories for one
of my constituents it was
parcels from the young princess
elizabeth sent in 1947 sharing the
country across the country wedding gifts
she said i've always remembered it there
was a pineapple in it and we didn't know
what it was
and for those of us children in the
1970s it was the silver jubilee
the queen meant street parties for us
and everyone made such a big fuss of it
being 25 years we frankly thought she'd
already been queen forever
and that's what she was for us and
subsequent generations our forever queen
who constant who would serve our country
for another 45 years
and right honourable members for peckham
for doncaster north for chingford have
all described how when they became privy
councillors and when they left
their office she invited them to tea
once they'd left their job and the
remarkable thing is she did it for
dozens of us
every departing cabinet minister or
party leader and i was invited after the
2010 election we drank t she asked me
how we had managed with these kids as
being cabinet ministers and i said
chaotically and we talked about housing
as well
and others have described the kindness
that she showed in those meetings but i
think it was much more than that
she didn't invite us when we were on the
way up she didn't invite us when we were
playing a constitutional role she only
invited us when it was all over and when
the cameras had gone home
and most of us don't like to talk about
our downfall and so most people never
knew she even held those teas
and i said then it was very kind of you
to do this she said it was to recognize
and to say thank you for public service
and that said much more about her than
it did for the service that any of her
cabinet ministers had shown because it
showed how privately
even more than publicly she believed in
selfless duty and valuing public service
to our country and yes she showed that
sense of mischief and i think no one has
told the story that so many of us must
have heard john prescott the lord
prescott tell of his first privy council
meeting
with claire short who was international
development secretary at the time and
according to john had arrived late with
a large handbag and a pile of papers and
as they stood to hear the privy council
business read out suddenly claire's
phone began to ring
and claire romichfast was unable to find
it in her handbag before the noise
eventually subsided the call went
unanswered and the queen simply said oh
dear i do hope that wasn't anyone
important
[Laughter]
rightly many members paid tribute
yesterday to the address that the queen
gave
just two weeks into the first lockdown
thousands of people had already died
thousands more were being rushed to
hospital unable to breathe schools were
closed families were split up churches
mosques synagogues all shut
parliament had closed and the prime
minister was very ill
and all of the institutions we relied on
and took for granted
were either closed or under strain
except for the queen
and only the queen our forever queen who
had been a constant through ups and
downs could give us that message but it
wasn't just her authority in invoking
those wartime sacrifices she captured
the yearning of a country to come
together just as we needed to stay apart
and she invoked those british values
that i want to finish with mr speaker
the attributes of self-discipline of
quiet good human resolve and of fellow
feeling still characterize this country
the words she used to describe us
but the words so many of us have used to
describe her
and that's why she was so important to
us
because she embodied the values that we
want to see still as british the
resilience the strength the kindness the
fairness
the common decency the determined
optimism that things will get better
because we will make them so and that
selfless duty to commitment to public
service she held up a mirror to our
nation of what we want to be
she may not be the forever queen that i
still believed in at that silver jubilee
but those values that she stood up for
were forever values and those are her
legacy now
amanda milley
thank you mr speaker
my thoughts and prayers and those of my
kind of chase constituents
are with his majesty the king
and all the royal family
who have lost a much-loved mother
grandmother and great grandmother
for us
we've lost a queen who dutifully served
our country
through every high and low that we have
faced from war to the pandemic her late
majesty has remained the constant
providing quiet but steadfast leadership
and showing that whatever we face
our great country can come together
i like many members of this house had
the real privilege
to meet the queen
the first time i met the queen
was when i was appointed deputy chief
whip
we've heard from several former whips
during these tributes
about the various duties that are
undertaken
my first meeting with the queen was for
one one swapping
the exchange of the ones of office
between the outgoing and the incoming
deputy
mr speaker now members who know me well
in this house will know that i'm not
known for being very quiet
but i was so so nervous i was really
worried i was going to mess up all the
protocols
so ahead of going in i just went totally
silent
and there were colleagues and friends
there
including the my right friend the member
for pudsey
he was a bit baffled
and turned around went gosh
where's amanda got
as many members have remarked on
she had an amazing ability
to put you at ease
including that smile
the length and breadth of our country
the queen was loved and admired
including in canada chase
but this love and admiration
stretched across the world
something that i personally saw on
overseas visits
and of course mr speaker this is true
for our overseas territories
a number of which i've visited in the
past year
whether mr speaker in a snowstorm
at goose green in forklifts
where we both were
or in the heat of anguilla
you could not help be moved
every time the national anthem was
played
you could see
and feel the admiration felt by the
people of the overseas territories
for those of us in this place we chose
to go into public life
because we want to make our great
country better for those that we serve
and in her late majesty we could not
have had a better example to follow
her unparalleled record of public
service
stand stood as an inspiration
we have been lucky to have her wise
counsel
and calm leadership over the past 70
years
for the country and around the world
her late majesty was a figurehead for
all that the united kingdom
represents
i offer his majesty the king
and his family
my heartfelt condolences and the
condolences
of my catholic chase constituents
as we all mourn the loss of queen
elizabeth ii
we know that his majesty the king
had an excellent mentor
and he will continue her great legacy
god save the king
sir george howarth
thank you mr speaker
her majesty the queen embodied a shining
example of duty
a sympathy and understanding of the
people of our country and the
commonwealth and beyond
an exceptional good
judgment
now mr speaker i have to confess
that i've not always felt supportive of
the principle of the monarchy
as a young local councillor i once
attended a function
at which the loyal toast to the queen
was proposed
foolishly
i declined to take part remaining firmly
in my seat
my non-participation
led to comment in our local paper
and a strong backlash from the people i
represented
i learned two lessons from that episode
the first was the unnecessary
courting of controversy
was not a good thing to do
and secondly
that the people held our constitutional
monarchy and the queen in particular
in enormous respect and affection
one question i was asked at the time was
so what is your alternative
and i have to confess i struggled to
find an answer
by the time i was
elected to this house more than a decade
later
i'd come to the
view
that her majesty and the monarchy were a
much valued part of our national life
the dedication and sense of duty
in the in the ensuing years has served
to strongly confirm me in that view
yeah yeah
round chaps
mr speaker like many in this house i had
the opportunity to both meet and speak
to the queen on numerous different
occasions but
unfortunately the relationship didn't
start particularly auspiciously i was
invited to buckingham palace for what
other members will know is an ancient
and complex process of becoming a
private councillor so complicated that i
was called to a side room with five
colleagues to have the process explained
it seemed that we would enter into a
large hall in buckingham palace a
majesty would stand at one end and we
were told we would kneel on red cushions
going back some distance on our right
knees holding a bible in our right hands
then we would switch that to our left
hand then take the sovereign's hand with
our right hand and brush her hand and
then stand and say your majesty
brush her hand
was that an instruction to brush her
hand
with my hand or my sleeve or a
handkerchief and as about i was to ask
we were called in to the actual
performance of the uh great ceremony
itself
no matter i thought i was fifth in the
line to become a privy counsellor i
would watch my colleagues each of whom
were swearing on the new testament i'm
jewish i was swearing on the old
testament i was at the back of this line
i would watch what was happening
unfortunately as we went into this very
large hallway it was so long that i
couldn't see what was happening the
ceremony at the front and as i got
closer the field of view
narrowed and the girth of my colleague
in front of me widened
and i still couldn't see
what brushing the hand actually entailed
and now with
palpitations and nervously i knelt in
front of her majesty the queen on the
red cushion right before her
i switched the bible the pentatosh from
the right to the left hand stretched out
my right hand she stretched out her bare
ungloved right hand and to my surprise
moved it towards my face
it moved towards my lips
i pursed my lips it stuck
and then in what felt like an age she
was trying to pull it away and then
suddenly
[Laughter]
a hand pulled away
i wanted the ground beneath me in
buckingham palace
to swallow me whole
but i remembered to stand up
your majesty
i quavered she looked me right in the
eyes with those wonderful sparkling eyes
and as if both to acknowledge what had
happened
and also to forgive me in one turn
she said
yes
[Laughter]
mr speaker we never spoke of it again
god saved the king
i'm sorry mr speaker i never expected to
be called so early and i was so enjoying
everybody's contribution
[Applause]
uh i i rise to pay my respects on behalf
of my constituents in mitchum and morden
who like the rest of our country and
commonwealth are united in mourning
so much has been said in this house and
indeed from pubs to podiums around the
world and yet such is the magnitude of
the moment that it still feels like
there is so much left to say
queen elizabeth was the historic
figurehead of modern times a leader a
female leader may i say
so incomparably devoted to her service
and her people
as the longest reigning monarch she has
been ever present a constant figure of
reassurance throughout all our lives
perhaps that is why the grief feels so
personal for so many
her majesty's leadership transcended
generations she navigated a century of
societal changes from her coronation in
postwar or britain
to every move of her reign teleflies
globally and across social media
it was this insight that best shared her
wonderful sense of humor with treasured
memories of olympic ceremony skydives
and more recently of afternoon tea and
teacup drumming with paddington bear
she truly was a leader for all ages
respected and admired by young and old
ever other members have spoken at length
of her dedication and duty it was this
work ethic that i admired most with her
service quit continuing quite literally
until the end as she welcomed her 15th
and final prime minister
just days before her death
what a remarkable drive she had
i suspect there must have been many
times through seven decades of service
when a stiff upper lip was required but
even in the darkest hours she
steadfastly believed that you just have
to keep going equality of true
leadership her majesty had an unrivaled
ability to unite even at times of
deepest division
perhaps that's why we trusted her she
was our great nation's guide through
good times and bad as a country we look
to her for reassurance and most recently
in the coronavirus lockdowns and when
she said that we would meet again we
trusted the century of experience that
she was drawing upon her platinum
jubilee showed the love that our country
had for her and sparked a togetherness
community and patriotism that she
consistently inspired she was so proud
of her country and commonwealth and we
were so proud of her
so we say thank you for 70 years of
service stewardship and extraordinary
stoicism
may she rest in peace
so john robert
mr speaker we meet together
in mourning
and once again
our late queen has united the nation
but this time unfortunately she has
united us in grief
at our common sense of loss
we here in parliament suspend our
differences
our party and our political views
because something so large has happened
that constant in our national life who
has always been our queen
is no more
and all those of us here who are all
privileged to have supporting roles in
public life
have learned a great deal from observing
just how well
the queen carried out all her public
service over the years
everyone here has met her invitation of
buckingham palace or at a national event
in london or maybe hosted her in their
constituency some of us had the honor on
many occasions to be with her and see
her
and i think what always came across to
all of us is just how much she respected
every person and every institution that
she visited
and she showed that respect
by impeccable manners and great courtesy
always on time
always properly briefed always
appropriately dressed for the occasion
but as so many have said from their
personal experiences there was something
so much more than this she was not just
the consumer professional at those
public events
but there was the wants spirit the
personality and above all that
understanding that everyone else at that
event was terrified that something was
going to go wrong or that they hadn't
understood the protocol or that there
was some magic way of doing it as my
right honourable friend was explaining
that they had to get right but in the
public events
the queen always relaxed people and
showed them there was no right way
because she was there for the people she
was there for the institution she was
there for the event and that is what we
can learn from now of course she was
also our majesty she was the embodiment
of the sovereignty of people and
parliament she represented us so well
abroad and she represented us at home
knowing that as a constitutional monarch
she represented us when we were united
she spoke for those times when we were
gloriously happy and celebrating or she
spoke for those times when there was
misery and gloom and she had to deal
with our grief and point to the better
tomorrow that was why she held that
sovereignty so well and for so long a
constitutional monarch who did not
exercise the power but captured the
public mood who managed to deal with
factious and difficult parliaments of
different political leaders but who was
above the politics and meant that our
constitution was safe in her hands i
wish her son and the new king every
success in following that great lead as
he has told us he will do
and can with others say today
god save the king
joanna jury
thank you mr speaker it's very humbling
to follow so many
uh great speeches
on my own behalf and on behalf of my
edinburgh southwest constituents i too
am rising to honor the memory of our
late queen
much has been said of her dedication and
her service but i want to concentrate on
her love of scotland and the love of
many scots for her
because the queen died at balmoral and
is to be taken first to the palace of
hollywood house and then to st giles
cathedral in edinburgh scotland will be
the center of the world's attention over
the next few days this is breaking with
tradition but these were the queen's
wishes and scotland is honored by them
the last monarch to die in scotland was
james v who died at falkland in 1542
he was of course the father of mary
queen of scots and it was her son james
vi who presided over the union of the
crowns
mary queen of scots is the ancestor of
all the stewards and indeed all the
hanoverians who followed
elizabeth stewart the daughter of james
vi
married one of the german electors and
with the demise of the last europe
monarch in 1714
elizabeth's grandson succeeded to the
british throne that's the hanoverian
line and it can be traced directly back
to scotland's stewards
our late queen was keenly aware of this
perhaps that's why she chose stewart
names for her first two children
charles and ann
and of course her mother was a scot
in 1953 after her coronation the first
place our late queen visited was
edinburgh and throughout her reign she
returned to scotland for important
events and indeed she chose my country
to be center stage during state visits
in 1962 she chose scotland for the state
visit of the king of norway and in 2010
very memorably for many people of my
faith she chose hollywood for the state
visit of pope benedict xvi
and of course she officially opened
scotland's parliament when it was
reconvened in 1999.
our late queen i believe embodied the
union of the english and the scottish
crowns which of course is quite
different from the union of the
parliaments and predates it by over a
hundred years
at a time of change there are many in my
country particularly younger people who
might prefer a republic to a
constitutional monarchy but that did not
in any way prevent the affection our
late queen held for scotland from being
returned in equal measure
sadly i never had the privilege of
meeting her majesty queen elizabeth the
queen of scots but earlier this year i
did have the privilege of meeting our
new king
we spoke of scotland and i was left in
no doubt that he shared his mother's
abiding love with my country
so before i resume my seat in honor of
his late mother i want to recite just a
few words of burns poetry which i
believe may be a favorite of the king
farewell to the mountains high covered
with snow
farewell to the straths and green
valleys below farewell to the forests
and wild hanging woods
farewell to the torrents and loud
pouring floods
my heart's in the highlands my heart is
not here
my hearts and the highlands are chasing
the deer
chasing the wild deer and following the
role my hearts and the highlands
wherever i go may she rest in peace
andrew mitchell
for all the pomp and tradition
her late majesty's true magic was in her
humility
she did not need a gilded throne or
royal regalia to touch people
it was in her smile
her poise
her natural charm
understated yet reassuring the best of
britain
thank you mr speaker for allowing me to
make this brief tribute on behalf of the
royal town of sutton coalfield a royal
town now for 494 years who at this sad
time unite with the rest of the country
in shared sorrow
the queen's visit to the ninth world
scout jamboree held in sutton park in
1957 is still remembered by my older
constituents as she came to join in the
celebrations for the 50th anniversary of
scouting and had lunch
in our magnificent town hall
and mr speaker i have never visited a
primary school where one of the first
questions hasn't been have you met the
queen
i had the privilege and good fortune to
meet the queen when i was her
international development secretary
like millions around the world
i will never forget every second of
those meetings
she was intensely interested in the less
developed members of the commonwealth
she was the reason the commonwealth not
only survived it flourished and grew
reaching out to unexpected parts of the
world with rwanda
enthusiastically joining
and at the commonwealth heads of
government meeting held in june this
year in rwanda
i watched the binding power of the
monarchy as the king as he now is
spoke on behalf of her late majesty of
the ideals and values she inspired and
to which so many nations now aspar
in kigali the capital of one of the
commonwealth's youngest countries the
national flag and the flag of the east
african community are today flying at
half-mast and will continue to do so
until the queen's funeral
i also remember traveling for many hours
in uganda to the hospital in masaka
run by an 80 year old sister of the
medical missionaries of mary
who had recently received the obe from
the queen for her 50 years of service
and in the hospital entrance hung a huge
picture of the president of uganda mr
museveni alongside an equally huge one
of her majesty the head of the
commonwealth
tomorrow mr speaker in the royal town of
sutton coalfield we will hold a service
of remembrance
in our town church holy trinity
followed by a reading of today's
proclamation
and we will mourn the loss of our great
queen who meant so much to us all um
thank you mr speaker and like other
members my main
memories of her late majesty the queen
are a visit to my constituency
in 1987
i was chair of newham council's planning
committee and i negotiated with mullens
the terms of its planning permission for
london city airport i attended the
opening by her majesty in november 1987.
it was pointed out that the terminal at
the airport was on the site from which
her grandfather had opened the king
george the fifth dock in 1921 66 years
before
the airport was controversial locally
it turned out that most local residents
still smarting from the economic damage
of the closure of the docks
10 years earlier welcomed the jobs it
was bringing but some were very unhappy
understandably about living with the
noise of the planes
on the day of the airport opening there
was a small demonstration
the airport management rightly wanting
to avoid unnecessary ill feeling invited
half a dozen demonstrators inside and
gave them the chance to meet the queen
and to set out their case
when it came to their turn the residents
explained their fears about aircraft
noise
the queen listened very carefully to
what they had to say and then she
replied
i know exactly what you mean you should
hear the noise that wins the castle of
the jets coming in to land at heathrow
the prime minister said yesterday that
her late majesty had a
unique ability to transcend difference
and heal division well that's what she
did on that occasion her off-the-cuff
response transformed the situation
arriving a as disgruntled outsiders the
residents by the time they had left were
insiders who'd shared a moment of
recognition and warmth with their head
of state
the rancor between the objectives and
the airport was i think permanently
eased
the day after the opening ceremony for
london 2012 which was a saturday when
you might have thought that after the
night before the then 86 year old
monarch would have been entitled to a
day off the queen returned to london
city airport to mark its 25th
anniversary
other memorable visits included in her
golden jubilee tour a visit to green
street
the most successful asian shopping
street in the country we claim where she
was greeted by enthusiastic women in
colorful sarri's waving union jacks
creating wonderful photographs in the
daily mail the next day
and we always remember her opening what
we now call newham university hospital
in december 1983.
her reign mr speaker was seven decades
those treasured memories will last for
many decades still
debut green
like many others i suspect my initial
reaction on hearing of the queen's death
was not just sadness and regret but a
peculiar sense of uncertainty how how
could the world continue without this
magnificent woman playing
a central role in the background of all
our lives but also like many others i
was lucky and privileged enough to meet
the queen uh a number of times and can
add to the testimonies and many other
members about her warmth kindness vast
depth of knowledge absolutely
razor-sharp mind and fabulously dry
sense of humor and my best evidence of
the latter
was another uh privy council meeting not
i'm happy to report to my on right home
offender from welling hatfield his
but um as he said a council takes place
whenever a new member is appointed
and this involves as we've heard
a lot of kneeling moving
kneeling again holding a bible kissing
and talking now politicians are good at
words but many of them are not very good
at choreography and i vividly remember
one meeting where somebody got it wrong
badly wrong there was chaos my right
honourable friend was nothing on that
as you can imagine this provoked silent
but extreme hilarity and glee among the
close friends of this poor wretch who
was getting it very very badly wrong
and i looked across
and the queen's face was completely
impassive
but the look in her eyes told me that
the person biting their tongue hardest
in that room was her majesty
one of her greatest personal attributes
was that despite being royal all her
life and the monarch for 70 years she
didn't have a trace of self-regarding
pomposity
but her many personal attributes were
not enough to make her a great leader
she had so much more than that to give
particularly she had a genius for
necessary reform for taking an ancient
institution of huge importance and
changing it little by little so that it
stayed relevant in fast-moving times she
enabled the monarchy to remain ancient
and modern it's an extraordinary
historic achievement and even in the
last 48 hours we've seen that the new
king is proceeding on the same path the
television of the
accession council the unexpected
walkabout at buckingham palace yesterday
these tell us that king charles will
both preserve the traditions of the
monarchy while keeping it fit for the
21st century and beyond so we can be
assured that we will continue to have a
people's monarchy there can be no
greater tribute to the late queen and no
better platform for the new king that we
can say with great confidence god save
the king
thank you mr speaker so many of us are
trying to find the words to describe the
reign of her majesty queen elizabeth
many of us have eloquently
philosophically emotionally and even
poetically alluded to her legacy and her
reign but despite all the great words we
have had to say or will say we all fall
short not because of lack of words or
helpful
heartfelt emotions to speak on this
momentous occasion but because even our
greatest words fall short in doing
justice to the life legacy and the reign
of this extraordinary monarch
we look around the world and we realize
that these are not just somber moments
for the people of britain or the
commonwealth but for the entire world
indeed the words of president macron of
france which eloquently stated to you
she was your queen
to us she was the queen
highlights how she was a worldly figure
that existed beyond the nations and
realms in the hearts of all people from
across the world
she was a unified monarch who brought
together people in a way that was unique
only to her
this is why when we look across our
nation of the sadness and the grief
people and communities are feeling we
see that people of all races of all
religions and all communities are united
in the devotion and heartfelt emotion
they are showing at the passing of their
queen
this unified attachment to her majesty
did not just appear out of nowhere but
was directly a symbol she expressed
throughout her reign in 1952 in her
first christmas broadcast at a time when
inclusion diversity were very much
unseen in society she addressed the
nations and asked that people whatever
their religion may be to pray for her
and her reign the same message of
inclusivity and diversity we heard
yesterday from our new king king charles
iii
in the same way despite her majesty
keeping her views close to her heart it
was obvious to see her deep-felt
connection to the commonwealth and to
justice by the summer of 1986 it was
widely known about the queen's apparent
objection to the event prime minister
margaret thatcher for britain's refusal
to place sanctions on apartheid south
africa it is no wonder that her favorite
african leader was nelson mandela who
she held a deep friendship with until he
sadly passed
on a more local front the queen took
several visits and was welcomed by the
people of bradford throughout her 70
year reign
18 months after her coronation on the
nation on her nationwide tour she
visited bradford marking the city's
first royal visit since 1942.
the queen visited bradford park avenue
during this trip and was sanctuary by 30
000 school children on behalf of all my
constituents i hope i can today express
their thoughts healings and condolences
to the royal family at this difficult
time
as one era comes to an end we pray for
the next as a woman of faith i admired
her majesty as she was a person of deep
faith and belief and i end the words of
the great muslim poet rumi he says you
are not a drop in the ocean you are an
entire ocean in a drop her majesty was
an ocean in her kindness selflessness
and humor and she made herself a drop
through her humbleness sense of duty and
service to her people god save our king
greg clark thank you very much indeed mr
speaker my constituents in the town of
royal cambridge wells and the wider
borough of tumbridge wells loved her
late majesty and on behalf of us all i
express our gratitude for her life of
service
in world time bridge worlds we have a
very special connection
through mr harry collins who for 22
years has been the personal jeweler
to her late majesty responsible for the
care of her jewels and for designing and
making some of the new pieces that have
been so admired around the world during
that time
i had coffee with mr collins this
morning and his devotion to her late
majesty is absolute
and he is much too discreet to break any
confidences
but i did read however
that his appointment survived having
fallen flat on top of one of the queen's
corgis
when attempting to follow protocol by
walking backwards during one of his
early consultations
now one of the high points
of my life
was as many members many right
honourable members have expressed was
meeting her majesty to be sworn in to
the privy council for the first time as
i was in 2010 we've heard
already this morning and yesterday some
of the hazards of that
and it is so overwhelming is that moment
that i understand that men
have suddenly been moved to curtsy
and otherwise capable people have swayed
on the footstool while trying trying to
kneel on one knee holding up a bible in
one hand and to recite the oath at the
same time and of course the one person
who didn't mind as has been said was her
majesty herself who put everyone at
their ease
so one of the reasons that i will always
be grateful to my right honourable
friend the member for oxbridge is in
reappointing me to the cabinet again
this summer i was able to swear the oath
of office
to her majesty
in person herself on the 8th of july at
windsor castle
when i shook her majesty's hand
i was greeted with the most dazzling
thousand-watt smile
sparkling eyes that suggested that she
was absolutely thrilled to see me
now i strongly suspect mr speaker that
her majesty's demeanor did not they
reflect the fulfillment of a three-year
hope that the prime minister would
restore me to office
instead it showed
that at the age of 96
on a hot summer's afternoon
her majesty still recognized that for
everyone she met it was a moment that
they would treasure forever
and in a second it revealed her personal
kindness and adherence to the highest of
standards right to the last
across the world over 70 years hundreds
of thousands of people
have been treated with such kindness and
thoughtfulness by her majesty the queen
her life was one of constant
devoted and selfless service
we are blessed that she reigned over us
may she rest in peace and god save the
king
come on germs
mr speaker i had like many the great
privilege of meeting the queen as a
member of the privy council uh defence
minister and a member of this house i
remember the first time uh i met her uh
not long after being first lectured to
this house in 2001 remembers were
invited
to meet
her majesty and you can imagine we were
all very nervous and apprehensive
about
the visit
but as many have
said in these tributes that once we met
her she made us feel at ease
she asked questions about our
backgrounds and
was interested in our constituencies the
other thing that struck me uh mr speaker
was a i think an encyclopedic knowledge
of different parts of the united
kingdom
mentions already being made in these
tributes to a dedication to our armed
forces
and it wasn't simply because she was
head of the armed forces is because she
was a real devotion an understanding of
their role i think that came from
somebody who'd served herself
but i've got the same speaker it went
beyond that and i think the best example
i can give when i was veterans minister
was a decision
to award the elizabeth cross in 2009
to the next of kin of those who'd lost
loved ones in the service of the country
and can i just attest this was not a
popular decision among certain parts of
the establishment but for me what it
showed about her was she recognized the
important role
of families playing continue to play
in supporting those who we asked to
serve in the members of our armed forces
for many of us including many of my
north durham constituents
the queen has been that constant
presence
in our lives
in what we all know has been and
continues to be
an increasingly uh changing world
but she had those two things that i
think are important
dedication to service
with the central tenants of her reign
and some in this cynical age may dismiss
them as being old-fashioned and part of
the bygone age but i would disagree with
that because the cynicism of those that
aim to divide us uh i think need
reminding what she
used and
led by example
in saying that we are individuals we
have differences
but it if we work together
despite those differences it makes us
all stronger
yesterday we sat
in this chamber and listened
to our new king's address to the nation
what is clear despite his grief and the
huge responsibility which now rests on
his shoulders
that that dedication and duty to service
will
continue
which was so
excellently exemplified by
the late queen
god save the king
so generally right thank you very much
mr speaker it is an honor to have this
opportunity to offer my condolences
those of my family and of my
constituents to his majesty the king and
to the royal family and to pay tribute
to her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
as with many others i was privileged to
meet her a number of times and it was
easy to be intimidated by what she was
but never by who she was with the
authority there was always great warmth
mr speaker we've heard many eloquent
tributes in the last 48 hours but
perhaps none have been quite so eloquent
as the faces of the people we have all
seen on the streets
those faces show the struggle of her
subjects to reconcile the feelings of
grief gratitude and pride we all share
for the life and work of our late queen
grief because of the scale of our
national loss
but also more personally because we
relied on her constancy to anchor our
own lives to an extent that many of us
are only now beginning to realize
grief two because we no longer have the
remarkable individual fulfilling this
uniquely challenging role
the task of modern monarchy looks
impossible
to encapsulate all that is good about a
nation a family of nations and to
celebrate its diversity while drawing it
together
to be looked to to set the tone at every
moment of collective joy and disaster
and also to share the best and worst
moments of your own life with the
country and with the world
and in meeting that challenge queen
elizabeth ii was a breathtaking example
of servant leadership for 70 years
making the impossible look effortless
and maintaining an irrepressible sense
of humor throughout and it is for that
leadership that we feel such gratitude
among our sadness
delivered by this most exemplary of
british monarchs in the most british of
styles
with resilience and dignity
and without drama or fuss
with service to others as a primary and
persistent vocation however hard the
task or the events of her own life
perhaps mr speaker not always happy but
always glorious
and mr speaker this was majesty indeed
and so we are also proud
proud that we were privileged to live in
this second elizabethan age
proud that for so much of our recent
history
our nation was personified by the
monarch we mourn today
her loss is great
but her legacy is greater
a country a people and a commonwealth
immeasurably better for her long and
faithful service to us all
yeah
wendy
thank you mr speaker it is an honor to
be paying tribute to our late majesty
queen elizabeth on behalf of my
constituents in northeast fife in this
place and as a relatively new mp it is
easy to feel overwhelmed by the history
of this place and the events that it has
seen and never more so than today when
considering the queen's life of her
dedication and of her work
i feel as i know many do unanchored we
were all elizabethans for the majority
of us without realization or
acknowledgement and no matter our views
on the monarchy the queen was there our
constant through ever-changing times
we have seen both a jolting and an
imperceptible change in the filter of
our lives
qc to casey
future king speeches that will take
place in the speech
the singing of god save the king
given the current line of succession it
is unlikely that any one of us here will
see a reigning queen again in our
lifetimes
now like other members i want to pay
tribute to the queen's service her
dedication to the nations of the uk and
the commonwealth and to their citizens
and her commitment to her people because
for us in scotland she was our queen of
scots the scots as a people and we know
her love of scotland as a place of
beauty escape and of peace and i trust
that she found some of that beauty and
peace on her visits to northeast fife
fife is known as the kingdom of fife
recognising its religious and royal
heritage including that of saint andrews
named for our nation's patron saint and
of falkland whose palace is closely
associated with that of another queen of
scots mary
her first and last visits were both to
lukers military base where in 2018 as
their colonel in chief she presented the
scots dragoon guards with a new standard
visits in between took in the broad
spectrum of meeting with the communities
of the snuke the former royal bar of
cooper and beyond and to visiting the
ancient university of saint andrews a
place of recent family significance and
i wish the queen's granddaughter lady
louise well as she commences her studies
there and i hope that she finds comfort
in our town
the breadth of her's engagements within
northeast fife reflect her life from
leading her armed services to hearing
from the smallest of children
now as a primary child of the 80s the
queen meant brownie promises and royal
weddings with the queen off centre as a
happy and proud parent
i never had the privilege of meeting the
queen my only connection is i was one of
the last babies christened by the
reverend keith angus before he went to
crafty kirk to become
the queen's chaplain in scotland it's
been wonderful to hear from those
members who have met her the twinkle in
the eye has come through strongly
although i've always wondered if like
paddington she could subject ministers
to a very hard stare
i saw her once in person at the last
queen's speech she attended in this
place which took place during covet she
processed past me down the royal gallery
supported by her son our now king and i
conclude by saying that he and the rest
of the royal family are in the thoughts
and prayers of my constituents and i god
save the king
sir charles walker
mr speaker broxborne mourns the death
of her majesty the queen but it
celebrates her life of selfless service
mr speaker quite simply i join my
constituents now in saying god save the
king right that was bar too quick clive
effort
thank you mr speaker on behalf of my
constituents of elton and myself i would
like to send my deepest sympathies to
his royal highness king charles iii and
his family on the passing of his mother
queen elizabeth ii i think over the last
few days we've identified a new syndrome
and i think it will be studied for years
i think it's the queen elizabeth ii
syndrome because because i felt
um i would be sorry for the nation at
losing its head of state i thought i'd
be very sympathetic and sorry for the
family losing a mother a grandmother
and a great-grandmother but i did not
expect
i must admit to feel such a deep
personal sense of loss and i know others
have expressed a same feeling and if we
reflect on the images that are that
mould us that make us uh
british if you like
you know and conjure those images to
mind it's the queen's image that stands
out most prominent and if you think of
those
uh those characteristics that we would
associate with britishness strength
fairness dignity dedication
determination duty tradition charity
um those are all attributes that you
would associate with the queen in the
way that she performed her task as as
our monarch characteristics she applied
uh both home and abroad she was the
embodiment embodiment of how we would
want to be seen in the world
her longevity in her role gave her a
deep knowledge and understanding of
global politics and its personalities
which no other country benefited from
she saw politicians come and go
she reigned over 15
prime ministers which is over a quarter
of the prime ministers we've ever had
similarly with presidents so 13
presidents and six popes she was
determined to lead
by example each and every time she
stepped out in public
the generation that she comes from the
war generation is a tough generation her
experience
of that gave her the insight to know
exactly what message we needed during
the covid pandemic
she knew through her collective for our
collective endeavor that we would get
through
and that that beacon that she said at
the end of the road which i think will
be etched forever in the rock of our
nation
we will meet again
her generation knew loss in the darkest
of hours and her dedication to duty told
her that at her darkest of times
she must lead by example and she sat
alone
wearing a mask obeying the rules
at her husband's funeral i don't think i
admired him all at any other time
she didn't waver in her duty and it's
not fair to say to those that will
follow that we won't see her like again
our king has a hard act to follow so i
say
god help the king
hurry up
yeah
it is with great humility and sadness
that i rise to pay tribute to her late
majesty the queen on behalf of my
constituents in west worcestershire when
we think of the sadness that we are
feeling we can only imagine how much
grief her family members must be feeling
and we send them our heartfelt concern
condolences i think so many of us had
hoped
that her late majesty would live
to reach her 100th birthday like her
mother did and that she would have to
make the decision as to whether or not
she sent herself a telegram
but during her reign her late majesty
made four official visits to
worcestershire most recently during her
diamond jubilee tour when she opened her
faithful city of worcester's new library
the hive and it was an honor to meet her
on that
occasion on her first visit to
worcestershire in 1957 as the reigning
queen she came to melvin to see the
royal radar establishment and wolverine
college because radar was invented in
morphin and had played such an important
role in us winning the second world war
and as many colleagues have said
she took a particular interest in our
working here in parliament invited all
new mps
to meet her after the election in 2010
and it was at that occasion that i
learned of her fondness for more than
water and since then i think many of us
have always thought that perhaps it was
more than water that had given her
majesty her wonderful complexion and
also helped her enjoy such a long life
many tributes have made clear how close
her relationship has been with this
parliament
but as chair of the british group in the
inter-parliamentary union i wish to
highlight her role supporting
international parliamentary democracy
human rights and the rule of law around
the world
the inter-parliamentary union brings
together almost the whole of the world's
parliamentarians and as our head of
state she opened three of the
organization's conferences in london
in 1957
in 1975 and notably the centenary
conference of the ipu in 1989
and as she addressed those hundreds of
parliamentarians from around the world
she underlined the core values of
multilateralism
the importance of bringing
parliamentarians together to find
peaceful methods of solving disputes and
to understand each other
so let this time of grieving
reinforce the wisdom that lasting peace
must come through words
our late queen is now at peace
and in the world words of our daily
prayer in this chamber
may she attain everlasting joy and
felicity
god save the king
garrett
thank you uh mr speaker it's a privilege
uh to have the opportunity to to rise in
this debate to pay tribute to her
majesty the queen on my own behalf but
also
particularly importantly on behalf of my
constituents in harrow west
the queen was a remarkable monarch
loved and admired as many in this house
have already underlined across our great
country and indeed across the world
as a result i have not been surprised by
the depth the warmth and the sheer
volume of heartfelt messages that my
constituents have shared about the
queen's life and their sense of loss at
her passing
harrow indeed was the first borough
created by the queen after her
coronation in 1953
and that is probably the most important
of the many reasons why we have always
been the most important part of london
ever since
[Laughter]
she visited
albara many times many school bits
school visits in particular and to
celebrate uh the borough's golden joke
jubilee in 2004
and was always enormously well received
i had the privilege too of meeting her
as others have done uh on a couple of
occasions once as a new member of
parliament at a reception in buckingham
uh palace for young achievers which is
probably the nearest i've ever come to
being a rising star
and i met her too as a minister in the
foreign office
and what was obvious
on that occasion and indeed in the many
conversations that i had with ministers
across the commonwealth and the globe
was the enormous respect in which she
was held and her quiet work receiving
and meeting diplomats and the leaders of
the countries with whom our country
needed to engage with was always was
always enormously well received and
hugely important
indeed many of my constituents who have
links to india and to pakistan or
across east africa in particular
tanzania kenya and uganda or those with
links to west africa such as those with
background in ghana and of course those
with a background in the caribbean as
talk of the immense respect they have at
a personal level but also of the immense
respect that their families and uh and
relations back home in their countries
also uh also have too
hers was a remarkable life mr speaker 70
years of phenomenal public service is
our monarch her skills her constancy and
her considerable diplomatic efforts
helped underline and enhance the
greatness of our country
and the warmth of the tributes from
leaders across the globe from across the
commonwealth and across europe and
indeed from the president of the united
states have only underlined her
importance to our country too god save
the queen let god save the queen and god
save the king
jeffrey clifton
[Music]
mr speaker it is an honour to be able to
give a tribute on behalf of the people
of the cotswolds with their many
connections with the royal family
ever since her majesty the queen made
that public broadcast when she was only
just 21 pledging a whole life of service
to the nation she has honored that to
the full yeah she ruled unstintingly for
over seven decades bolstered by her
sense of duty christian faith and as
others said her sense of humor
the rock
the constant for the nation
always wise and comforting council
the first british monarch to visit
northern ireland for a hundred years to
visit our the republic of ireland for
100 years and west germany in 1965
she was indeed a world-class diplomat
she was an important leader of the
commonwealth as my honorable friends has
said and during her reign the
commonwealth has increased from seven
members to 56 countries a legacy which
we should strive to build on
a true country woman
she like nothing better than to ride on
her horse in her earlier days or walk
her dogs
she took a keen interest in nature and
understood agriculture
she loved horse racing
the queen visited san ancestor in 1963
to view the revamp of the marketplace
she then visited the royal international
attitude at fairford to celebrate the
raf's 90th anniversary in 2008.
she was one of the most influential and
important figures in the 20th and the
21st century a truly great cream who
united all in every part of this nation
the commonwealth and beyond
our sympathies go out to all members of
the royal family
she's now at peace with her beloved
husband prince philip god save the king
barbara keeley
thank you mr speaker
i want to speak on behalf of my
constituents in wesley nickel south to
say first that we are deeply saddened by
the death of her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
she has been the monarch throughout my
lifetime
this loss feels like losing a member of
my own family
she was devoted to the service of the
nation for 70 years and she served our
country and the commonwealth with great
commitment deep devotion and dignity
my constituency of wesleyan eccles south
lies within the city of salford one of
our most famous artists ls lowry was one
of the official artists of the
coronation of queen elizabeth ii in
1953.
his classic work from this momentous day
is called the procession passing the
queen victoria memorial
in october 2000 the late queen
officially opened the lowry theatre and
art gallery in salford
during her visit the queen greeted staff
and volunteers from the lowry and spoke
to local school children who had created
an exhibition of photographs about life
in salford
his royal highness prince philip was the
first chancellor of the university of
salford and the queen supported him in
his role as a dedicated and active
chancellor during his 24-year tenure at
the university
in 2012 during her diamond jubilee tour
the late queen opened media city the
home of the bbc and itv granada in the
north as well as other media service
companies and the media base of the
university of salford and it was an
honor for me to meet the queen on that
occasion
the late queen's visit last visit to
salford was in july last year she may
act as members of the production staff
at the croatian street set in media city
in celebration of the show's 60th
anniversary
now as the shadow minister for civil
society i know that many charities hold
the late queen elizabeth ii in very high
esteem
she was the patron of over 600 charities
military associations professional
bodies and public service organizations
and tributes have been pouring in for
many of these over the last couple of
days
the late queen's patronages cover every
area of the charity and voluntary sector
from charities for young people to the
preservation of wildlife and the
environment
the values she possessed of selfless
public service compassion and leadership
encompassed the spirit of our civil
society
in her christmas message of 2016 her
late majesty talks of drawing strength
from ordinary people doing extraordinary
things
volunteers
carers community organizers
and she said
on our own we cannot end wars or wipe
out injustice but the cumulative impact
of thousands of small acts of goodness
can be bigger than we imagine
her own thousands of acts of goodness
will be remembered for generations
i know her legacy will continue to live
on in the thousands of charities and the
volunteers dedicated to supporting
communities across the uk and around the
world
and that king charles iii will continue
the traditions of selfless public
service
compassion and leadership
god save the king
dr julian
thank you so much mr speaker towards the
end of yesterday's proceedings
participants were encouraged to avoid
repeating the points of their
predecessors
this is no easy task when such unanimity
prevails
now some members of this house clearly
had
far more contact with her majesty than
others yet it's natural that so many of
us wish to record our tributes to the
outstanding monarch of the modern age
not simply for ourselves but on behalf
of tens of thousands of constituents who
also adored her
one reason for that adoration was the
queen's accessibility
the lemington times has helpfully listed
four notable visits she paid to our part
of hampshire including in
1979 to mark the 900th anniversary of
the new forest and
2012 as part of her diamond jubilee tour
multiply those visits by well over 600
constituencies and the scale of her
efforts on visits alone is seen to be
colossal
new forest east was formed before the
1997 general election and as its first
mp i described to the house
how even so beautiful an area had been
touched and toughened by the impact of
war
princess elizabeth's formative years
were similarly shaped and strengthened
by that ordeal
her family's involvement with the
services already so strong could only
increase
whilst others directed the operations of
the military the allegiance of those
forces was to her and her alone
this is more than symbolic it's an
essential guarantee of the
constitutional independence of the
military
i'm very fortunate to represent so many
people
with past present or potential service
in the armed forces of the crown
one such constituent my partner's father
received his distinguished flying cross
from the hands of the queen as long ago
as 1955
during the malayan emergency
he was struck by the depth of her
knowledge even then
it went far beyond the formalities of an
investiture
we can truly be thankful
that at the top of society she chose to
be its servant she adapted to change yet
always seemed the same
she did her duty unfailingly and was in
short an inspiration to the nation
west street
thank you uh mr speaker it's a privilege
to follow so many others in rising to
pay tribute to her late majesty the
queen on behalf of the people of ilford
north on the london borough of redbridge
the depth of our sorrow reflects in part
the length of her reign her lifetime of
service and duty and the devotion she
gave to her family our country and our
commonwealth but it also reflects how
special the woman beneath the crown was
at once the head of our royal family and
yet able to touch the hearts of every
family in the land
east london holds a special place for
the royal family in our hearts
during the second world walking george
vi and his family stayed in london
during the blitz and visited families
whose lives and livelihoods had been
devastated by the nazi onslaught the
then princess elizabeth visited ilford
to see those affected by the bombing on
the day after ve day in 1945
and returned again in 1949
to see the 1000th council home that had
been built by atleast government she is
said to have remarked and i quote of all
the houses and estates i have visited
ilfords are the best
she also visited a care home
where one elderly resident was so
thrilled to meet the princess that they
immediately burst into tears of
happiness
i saw a similar outpouring of emotion
when the queen visited ilford again for
her diamond jubilee in 2012 where she
unveiled a plaque to the dry garden
created in her honor in valentine's park
which spoke to the great challenge of
climate change a court calls close to
the heart of our dear king one residence
hold the ilford recorder we have always
read about queens and princesses in the
storybooks to have the queen in our
neighborhood it's like a dream come true
a dream come true
it's a sentiment i can't imagine being
elicited by a mere president
and one that was certainly uh elicited
with no effort from her majesty the
queen and it hardly seems real that that
dream has ended
we are privileged to have lived in the
second elizabethan age her late majesty
the queen oversaw our country's
transition from empire to commonwealth
to a modern democracy where witnessing
huge social changes throughout her
lifetime so many of my constituents are
proud of those changes and of course
retain strong familial familial bonds
right across the commonwealth she showed
by example that tradition and modernity
are not adversaries but well-suited
companions from her majesty's first
televised address to her very last zoom
call and from the beginning of her reign
amidst rationing and post-war
reconstruction to her address to the
nation at the height of the covet
pandemic she reminded us that whatever
the triumphs and disasters of our
history our country's best days now lie
ahead history like life moves on
his majesty the king has told us that
the grief of the nation indeed the grief
of the world has provided comfort to his
family for their irreparable loss i hope
he knows that his presence in our lives
in recent days has been comforting and
reassuring too and if i may say mr
speaker but when the queen welcomed the
then duchess of cornwall into her family
the nation took her into her
hearts and it is a privilege and
pleasure to see her take the place as
queen consort we are blessed to have
known the reign of elizabeth the first
our greatest queen may god rest her soul
and may god save the king
before i leave the chair can i remind
members and staff
there is a service tomorrow at 6 p.m in
saint margaret's church for
parliamentary community
to remember her late majesty the queen
those wishing to attend please contact
my office will quince
thank you mr speaker it is with great
sadness that on behalf of the people of
colchester i rise to pay tribute to her
late majesty queen elizabeth ii
her majesty dedicated her reign to
serving our country and the commonwealth
in her lifetime she witnessed our nation
and the world transformed immeasurably
yet for so many of us
she was the constant throughout our
lifetimes
her warmth and her smile providing
stability and reassurance during the
very toughest of times
her service to the british people and
her presence in our lives
will be forever held in our hearts and
in the hearts of people across the world
on behalf of the people of colchester to
his majesty king charles iii and the
royal family i send our sincere
condolences
and to her late majesty queen elizabeth
ii
we send our thanks
our admiration
and our love
may you rest in peace mom god save the
king
madam deputy speaker
i mourn her majesty queen elizabeth ii's
passing
on behalf of my constituents in blaine
gwent i offer my heartfelt condolences
to the royal family
when i heard the sad news my first
thought was that we the british people
have lost our preeminent public servant
as her late majesty once said
i do not give you laws or administer
justice
but i can do something else
i can give my heart
and devotion to these old islands and to
all the peoples of our brotherhood
of nations
queen elizabeth dedicated her life to
the greater good
and wove together the ties that bind us
in 2012 the late queen visited evervale
it was one of those days in our valleys
when the skies
emptied gallows
but still she saw through the program
her late majesty knew that meeting our
community
hearing our choirs collecting flowers
from children
being with us
mattered
she showered goodwill on the people of
blind i grant
as the heavens reigned down on all of us
in the days following the queen also
visited
she was due to open a new school in the
village struck by grief just 46 years
earlier
on reflection
i now realize she was the constant
was there when tragedy struck
standing alongside us when our nation
was moaned but also she was there to
usher in the new beginnings
as i look to the future i think of his
majesty king charles iii
now when prince of wales i recall his
visit to hezbotti and iriben the
hospital named after one of my
predecessors who established our
national health service
whilst very carefully done
there was a nod to the political genius
who established yet another great
institution of our country
i also remember the king wore a blue
cornflower in his buttonhole
it was a classy look
he clearly knew of our great valleys and
their history
i have no doubt he will continue the
legacy of his beloved mother the late
queen
finally
i would like to warmly welcome
the naming of the new prince and
princess of wales
[Music]
madam deputy speaker though i mourn
our longest reigning monarch
i know save
god save the king
thank you madam deputy speaker
in 2015 i was a appointed depth chair of
the party and
attending cabinet and
no one had informed me that i would be
made a privy counsellor
my constituency office
got a call saying i needed to attend the
palace
and i said i reply to my caseworker
there's just a nutter on the phone just
ignore it
this happened on two or three telephone
calls
and it was only on the day itself when i
was told a ministerial car would be
picking me up to take me to buckingham
palace that i realized and sadly i i
would have bought a nicer suit had i had
i know
but it was the greatest the greatest
honor of my my life and of course i
sadly was not able to kneel because of
my legs
but the queen
her majesty did not bat an eyelid and i
thought there am i the son of an
immigrant to this country
getting becoming a member of the privy
council and i thought to myself what a
what's an honor and what a meritocratic
country that we have become
now the queen um
i'm very proud to be here representing
my constituents of harlow of hastingwood
matching maison royden and shearing and
the queen
visited harlow in 1957 and harlow is a
new town
and it was built after the war to
provide people from homes many of whom
came from the east end of of london and
she attended and had a wonderful visit
in the market square and the bbc
featured that in one of their
documentaries over the past couple
of days and what it symbolized was
although that the
a queen came from the old world she was
bringing in the new world
and she was showing that actually this
is what the new britain would be about
post-war beautiful new towns uh bringing
hope aspiration achievement opportunity
and community
and dignity
to our country and these were all the
values of course that her majesty
represented
just finally
madam deputy speaker i am a jewish mp
and i was brought up in the
united synagogue which is traditional
judaism
every single part of the service is in
hebrew
and not being um
the best of
learners i mostly don't understand a lot
of what is going on
but
the one part the one part of the service
is that is in english
is the prayer for
uh the queen
and if i could just read that it says
may the supreme king of kings in his
mercy preserve the queen in life guard
her and deliver her for more trouble and
sorrow the one part of the service every
week that is said in synagogues in the
land
is a prayer for the queen it made me
very proud whenever i attended synagogue
that i i was able to say
to say that prayer and the queen
embodied
everybody not just her christianity a
deep christianity but everybody of all
faiths jewish people muslims and
hindus and many other faiths
this week the synagogues will be saying
not a prayer for the queen sadly but a
prayer for
king charles and the rest of the prayer
says
may he put a spirit of wisdom and the
understanding into her heart into his
heart and into the hearts of all her
counselors that they may uphold the
peace of the realm advance the welfare
of the nation and deal kindly and justly
with all the house of israel
on behalf of the jewish people
in our country those of the jewish faith
but also my constituents of harlow
hastings match amazing loyden and
sharing god save the king
dr philippa whitford
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i rise on behalf of my constituents of
central airshow to express our
sympathies to the royal family and to
pay respect to her majesty for her long
service of three score years and ten
literally a biblical lifetime
being from northern ireland for me
her greatest contribution was to peace
and reconciliation on the island of
ireland
both by bravely welcoming martin
mcginnis here in london but also her
state visit in 2011 which brought so
much healing
madam deputy speaker this debate has
already woven the most important part of
any funeral the eulogy
and reminds me of the traditional wakes
i grew up with
with the coffin lying in state in the
living room surrounded by family friends
and neighbors
what struck me then as a little girl
was how the sadness gave way
once the funny story started once the
embarrassment
the talk of someone being on a chair in
blackpool singing at the top of their
voice
these embarrassing stories
changed the whole mood in the room that
i observed as a five six and seven year
old
the somber tones were replaced by
laughter
but strangely the coffin often also
turned into a coffee table
covered in glasses
now i don't think her majesty is likely
to face that indignity
but i remember my uncle saying that he
aspired to being buried in a coffin with
ring marks because it would be a symbol
of a really good wake
one that accepts that death is part of
life
and one that celebrates not a life ended
but a life completed
in the same way this chamber
has been lifted by so many funny stories
that demonstrate her majesty's great
sense of fun
both in public
such as the stunt at the olympics or
with paddington bear
or in private many that we've heard from
honourable and right honourable members
today
but the most illuminating
are those which show how she used humor
to put people at ease
out of kindness
i think she's probably delighted at the
sheer amount of laughter that has been
in this chamber over the last two days
and having walked the last journey with
many of my patients
over a lot of years
i know that virtually all of us would
choose to die peacefully at home
and that's exactly what the queen did
so we should take comfort from the fact
that she ended her life
peacefully and quietly at home in her
favorite place balmoral
surrounded by her family and loved ones
it doesn't get better than that
so while we offer our sympathy and
condolences to her family in their
sorrow at her loss
for her we should be glad
she goes to her rest
welcomed once again into the arms of her
beloved philip
and no doubt already sharing a wry joke
and probably at our
expense so for her majesty i simply pray
may she rest in peace
[Music]
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
rise on behalf of my constituents of
rochester and strewed i want to extend
my deepest condolences to the royal
family her majesty's death is a terrible
loss for us all and has touched every
corner of the world
her majesty was a constant reassurance
present and the world is unrecognizable
from the start of our reign despite
these changes she was a steadying figure
who led this country from the aftermath
of the second world war to the country
we are today
like many people in this house i have
only lived under her reign and as a
female born in 1978
i was lucky to be born into a unique era
for this country
growing up when for the first time in
our history
we had both a female head of state and a
female prime minister
these powerful female figures at the top
of our country so for me it was
absolutely normal to see women leading
the queen was a remarkable figure an
inspiration to many whose influence has
shaped generations as the values that
she has embodied the sense of duty
public service quiet dignity
epitomise her reign
she was a continuous figure both in this
country and around the world who managed
to exercise a calm and steadying
influence over our country even in its
toughest times
rochester and strude has been blessed by
many visits from her majesty over the
years i'm immensely proud of our raw
history and the links we have with our
queen with our late queen
she was that she made her first visit to
rochester in 1938
with king georgia 6 when she visited
shorts aircraft works and which was also
followed in 1942 to the royal chatham
dockyard
i hope that i am writing saying that she
liked what she saw in those only early
visits before her session which inspired
many trips in the following years
in her capacity as colonel in chief of
the corpse she expected the royal
engineers at brompton barracks in 1968
one of her many visits to the barracks
she also opened the royal engineers
museum in 1987 and made her final visit
there in 2016 to celebrate the 300th
anniversary of the corpse of the royal
engineers and it was the greatest honor
of my life to have meets her on that
occasion
i felt nervous
shared by everyone else who had met the
queen for the first time and after
overcoming the first hurdle of getting
my curtsy right i moved on to the next
step of meeting her majesty the
handshake there i was just over a year
into being an mp standing in front of
her majesty who had just turned 90
worrying about the damage that i could
cause her hand should i grip it too hard
i could not have been more wrong as i
failed to appreciate
um
i felt appreciates how years of
experience had left her majesty skilled
at administering a handshake as she took
my hand firmly and released it before i
could even take a moment
but also coupled with her great smile
and the twinkle in her eye that so many
have spoken of
the barracks was not only the place that
the queen had visited on her a visit to
rochester she had been to rochester
cathedral and even took a trip to our
great isle of grain oral refinery in
1955.
following her 1942 visit to the royal
chatham dockyard she returned to the
site in 1984 where she was able to see
the redevelopment proposals for the
closed chatham dockyards of mary's
island
these are a few examples highlighted how
committed and dedicated the queen was to
her people she was totally devoted to
the british people throughout her reign
and hundreds of thousands of people who
met her felt at ease her
absence will be felt around the world my
thoughts and prayers are with her family
and i know that king charles iii has the
support of rochester and all the good
people to lead this country into a new
era
god save the king
ellie reeves
thank you madame deputy speaker this
isn't just a time of national mourning
our grief is shared the world over
a testament to the service and impact
our queen had
for seven decades she selflessly
dedicated her life to service
she was an icon that meant so much to
all of us and so at times we felt we
would never lose
because so long was her service her
presence was sewn into the very fabric
of our society
guiding our country above the fray of
politics
her unrivaled commitment and experience
helping to lead our nation keeping it
steady no matter the political
turbulence
in her quiet way symbolizing the
commitment self selflessness and
humility we expect from our leaders
the progress we saw globally during her
reign in technology culture and politics
is unparalleled in history
but as an ever-present matriarch
throughout she assured us as the world
changed exponentially
it is truly sad that we have now lost
her
and whilst my words today cannot do a
life of such dedication justice the
outpouring of tributes the world's over
is a testament to her place in our lives
now our thoughts are with her family as
they mourn
we all send them our condolences
and in my constituency of lewisham west
and penge we mourn her too
in june we came together across the
constituency to hold platinum jubilee
parties
neighbours coming together for the first
time since the pandemic children playing
in the street people making new friends
all in her name i was proud to help
organize my jubilee street party my
seven-year-old son declared it the best
day ever
and we raised over 800 pounds for our
local food bank
and one of my earliest childhood
memories was seeing the queen as she
visited the pioneering saint
christopher's hospice in my constituency
her support and that of the royal family
made such a huge difference to their
work
i know that i speak on behalf of
everyone in my constituency
when i say thank you your majesty for
everything the service selflessness and
humility
queen elizabeth ii went above the call
of duty and for that we will always be
grateful
john whittingdale
thank you madam deputy speaker it is a
privilege to join honourable members in
paying tribute to her late majesty not
just on my own behalf but on behalf of
all the people of the malden
constituency many fine treatments have
been given both yesterday and today and
so many honourable members have spoken
of her late majesty's dedication her
commitment her remarkable sense of duty
and her lifetime of service which was
always performed with dignity compassion
and kindness i echo all of those
sentiments it has been an extraordinary
week starting with the appointment of a
new prime minister and ending with the
accession of a new sovereign i
congratulate my right friend the prime
minister i'm sure she will be grateful
that her first audience with the monarch
was with her late majesty queen
elizabeth i'm sure that his majesty king
charles will continue to provide advice
and counsel but my right word friend
must be sad but she will not benefit
from the extraordinary wisdom and
experience that her late majesty had in
advising 15 successive prime ministers
before entering the house i worked for
one of those prime ministers margaret
thatcher
she
used to
fix inheritary the only immutable
engagement in 11 years the weekly
audience with her majesty
i suspect there were occasionally some
quite robust discussions she never spoke
of what was said
but i do know that she immensely valued
the experience of her late majesty and
was hugely honoured when she attended
margaret thatcher her own 70th birthday
party
a number of members have spoken about
how they're asked in primary schools
where they've met the queen and and i've
had exactly that same experience but
i've also been struck on international
physics when so many parliamentarians
from across the world have spoken of
that admiration of the queen
and envied
the fact that we have benefited from
having her as our sovereign and we have
seen that in the global tributes with
union jackson the red white and blue
across america brazil the extraordinary
display on sydney opera house
yesterday and of course the words of the
president of france the country that has
not always had great relations with the
british monarch but who said
you uh
you have your queen we have the queen
madam deputy speaker
i like many honourable members or right
honourable members benefited from
meeting mcqueen as a member of british
council and i had the good fortune to
accompany her on one occasion to the
cenotaph uh which is one of the roles of
the secretary of state for culture meter
and sport but it was her two visits to
malden which my constituents will always
value the first in 1971 to mark the
800th anniversary of the award the
charter to malden by henry ii
and the second in 2010 which i was
privileged to be able to take part in
when she visited malden salt before
walking down the high street to have
lunch in the town hall
on that day it seemed that the whole
town
turned out to celebrate her visit
today the whole town and in the whole of
my constituency are once again united in
mourning the passage of her late majesty
and in pledging allegiance to king
charles iii yeah
great davis
deputy speaker there is nothing more
important to a child than their mother
she provides the comfort the security
the stability
amidst the worries of the world a person
assumed by all of us to go on forever
and so it was
with queen elizabeth the mother of our
country our queen of hearts
the people across the four nations of
the united kingdom owe so much to her
majesty the queen provide for providing
steady continuity of a war and peace
time through the peaks and troughs of
change so we feel a sense of deep grief
across our united kingdom
the loss of our eternal mother for me
personally i feel a special affection as
my own mother was of the same generation
and met my father during the war when he
served in the royal navy
elizabeth of course bore the weight of
the united kingdom on her young
shoulders from the age of 25 when
winston churchill was the prime minister
over 70 years of global change
she's been an anchor for britain in a
sea of change through 15 prime ministers
14 u.s presidents and seven popes
supporting the world with a long-term
interest of her communities and nations
in mind not the short-term expedience of
others as a mother a grandmother a great
grandmother she had to lead a family
often in personal turbulence in the
public view with a steady hand carefully
balancing the interests of the country
with those of her own family
i the privilege of meeting her briefly
on behalf of swansea west on a few
occasions uh since 2010 and in those
fleeting moments could appreciate her
wisdom the quiet gravity amidst a sunny
demeanor where whatever the weather she
will remain loved by so many millions
for so many things her continuity has
helped anchor our fundamental values
of fairness and democracy amidst the
undulating changes of political
leadership and the storms and
sunshine of global events
we shall never forget her and the people
of wales and swansea west will always
hold her in our hearts for the service
and devotion to our country our thoughts
of course with the queen's family
wishing the strength this most difficult
time in the comfort of remembering with
love and affection happy times shared
together as a family with elizabeth who
will continue to live in our hearts and
finally
for swansea west i recall how on the
14th of may
1946
elizabeth at the tender age of 20
attended a recital of poetry wigmore
hall with a mother queen elizabeth and
sister princess margaret there dylan
thomas a wales's greatest poet born of
course in uplands in my constituency of
swansea hill i read out fern hell the
last uh
verse which reads
nothing i cared in the lamb white days
that time would take me up to the
swallow thronged loft by the shadow of
my hand
in the moon that is always rising
nor that riding to sleep i should hear
him fly with the high fields and wake to
the farm forever fled from the childless
land oh as i was young and easy in the
mercy of his means
time held me green and dying though i
sang in my chains like the sea
deochambar elizabeth rest in peace god
save the king and the prince and
princess of wales
just a quick reminder to colleagues that
um mr speaker has um asked if
remarks could be confined to three
minutes so that we can get as many
people in as possible in stuart
thank you madam deputy speaker for this
opportunity to pay tribute to her late
majesty
in an interview yesterday the mayor of
milton keynes amanda marlowe was asked
what
her late majesty meant to the people of
milton keynes
and she replied simply she was
everything
and that is partly due to the fact that
milton keynes as we know it today
was founded built and flourished as a
new city during her reign from becoming
a collection of north buckinghamshire
towns and villages to the thriving city
we know today
milton keynes developed under
her late majesty and she visited many
times uh both to celebrate our history
uh whether that was to visit uh the
railway uh works at overton uh which has
been home to uh the royal train for for
many years
or to bletchley park in my constituency
where she visited
about 10 years ago
to unveil a memorial to the code
breakers there
and
members who've had a royal visit will
know that these are often
planned to
the last minute if not second such was
our interest and that of the late duke
of edinburgh that the timetable went
completely out the window
she was so engrossed
in celebrating the achievements of the
code breakers but as well as our history
she was there to celebrate our
development whether that was the opening
of the open university
our new city center
or the football stadium every part of
milton keynes
development she has been there for but
the greatest honor came
just a few months ago
and the platinum jubilee and she had the
grace to bestow on us city status
and at the heart of our bid
was the fact that milton keynes is made
up of many different communities
from the vast majority if not all
of the countries in the commonwealth and
that of course is something that she
enormously uh cherished
finally madam deputy speaker i
noticed yesterday that in his fine
speech the the leader of the opposition
uh quoted
some lines from philip larkin one of her
laureates
and i would just like to conclude by
quoting a very short poem from another
of her poet laureates sir john bechman
it's called the last laugh
and it reads i made hay while the sun
shone
my work sold
now if the harvest is over and the world
cult
give me the bonus of laughter as i lose
hold
and i very much hope that her late
majesty did keep her much
well-known sense of humor to the end
and that once the period of grief and
mourning at her loss has passed
that we may all as individuals and as a
nation
smile and remember with joy
what she meant to us
and did for us
thank you mom god save the king
cat smith
thank you
speaker when i rise
on my uh on behalf of myself but also of
my constituents in lancaster and
fleetwood to pay tribute to our
longest-serving
monarch
underpinned by her christian faith she
gave a life of service and built on that
firm foundation and for that we give
thanks and celebrate in the words of the
king a life well-lived
uh the queen owns the duchy of lancaster
and so she's always had a strong tie to
my constituency
and to us in lancaster she's known as
the duke of lancaster which can catch
visitors out and so if anyone is ever
invited by speaker to sing our national
anthem in lancaster the words are
slightly different as we sing god save
the duke instead of the more traditional
words which can catch as i said visitors
out
and and because of this strong tie the
queen visited many times and she visited
lancaster priory in 1999 to mark the
600th anniversary of this important link
between the crown and the duchy of
lancaster
and she also personally approved the
grant of a charter which constituted
the university of lancaster back in
1964.
and she made many visits to lancaster
castle in fact she visited lancaster
castle three times in 1969 before i was
born in 1977 before i was born and in
may 2015 literally days after i was
elected as the member of parliament so
when the declaration was made and you
are handed an envelope as a newly
elected member um i got an additional
envelope which says in a few days time
you'll be meeting the queen do you have
a hat and i don't think they meant the
uh barrow afc bobble hat
um
utterly uh terrified before i made my
maiden speech i found myself stood just
by platform three at lancaster station
as the royal train rolled in and rather
unusually in lancaster which is normally
gloriously sunny all the time the
heavens opened and it poured with rain
and at that point i realized that
hundreds and hundreds of my constituents
were stood out in this pouring rain
lining the streets to welcome her
majesty in the hope of perhaps and
catching a glimpse and that to me really
brought home the uh power that the queen
had to bring people together from all
walks of life and all generations and to
be honest as a newly elected mp that was
an important lesson for me to realize
too and but she also visited other parts
of my constituency madame deaf speaker
from the rural farms to the renowned
russell school in fleetwood in 1994 to
mark its 150th anniversary and from the
correspondence that i've received in the
past 48 hours it's clear that my
constituents who had the good fortune of
meeting her now have memories that will
last a lifetime so
as the sun sets on this second
elizabethan age we give thanks that our
nation has had the good fortune
to have the queen servers for 70 years
may she rest in peace and rise in glory
god save the king
john glenn
well thank you madam deputy speaker and
i rise to speak today on behalf of my
salisbury constituents
and i would like to start by
acknowledging the unique contribution
that her majesty has made to our nation
the commonwealth and the world
we will never see
a monarch reign through so many decades
and the overwhelming grief sadness
and disorientation that our nation is
now experiencing
is in proportion to and a direct
consequence of
the enormous role that her majesty
played in our lives
and as king charles said in his moving
address last evening
thank you
queen elizabeth thank you for your
gracious presence in our lives
now many of her subjects will never have
met the queen
but everyone felt that they knew her
and that she cared for them
and i have sat in this chamber these
last two days and heard so many
wonderful speeches from colleagues
across both sides of the house
and i was moved by the sheer breadth and
depth
of the impact that her majesty has had
in every corner of her united kingdom
and beyond
much has been said about her devotion to
her family
her love of the countryside horses her
beloved corgis her humor
her kindness
and the enduring impact
of that remarkable smile
that warmed the hearts and left an
indelible impression
seared into the soul
of anyone she encountered
i cannot off of offer anecdotes from
time spent at belmoral sandringham or
encounters at the palace
but i feel no less privilege for that
nonetheless i did meet her majesty when
she visited salisbury in 2012 in her
diamond jubilee year
she visited the rifles regimental museum
in the salisbury cathedral close our
cathedral
and an exhibition of our country's
history and communities on the cathedral
lawn
the abiding memory i will have is one of
a
sublime peacefulness
an aura of sincerity as she engaged so
generously in so many conversations with
my constituents
and each morning when in my constituency
home overlooking so fortunate the great
cathedral and as i reflect on the day
ahead looking out my window i have two
pictures on the window ledge
one of my beloved parents
and one of me
shaking the hand of her majesty a few
meters away
i met her at once
but i think she will always be with me
in my service in salisbury
her majesty
led a life that was animated and fueled
by a deep christian faith
that sustained her through life's highs
and lows
i think this will be the strongest
legacy that she will leave me with
her life
was driven by duty
but sustained in
full submission to the gospel of christ
and his teachings
and i thank god
for what he showed us
about his character
through her majesty's wonderful life
god save the king
chris madison thank you madam deputy
speaker and i rise on behalf of my
constituents in the city of chester and
what is so telling to me as i listen to
honourable and right honourable members
across the house
is that amongst the grief and amongst
the sadness there's laughter and the
smiles
the queen had that ability to make us
smile
and to make us laugh
and it's something that is so important
to remember today
for me two factors stand out for me on
the death of her late majesty the first
is the fidelity she gave to that pledge
she made in cape town on her 21st
birthday to dedicate her life to service
never in history can a promise have been
kept so faithfully for so long
she embodied dignity
service and dedication
secondly i must think of the royal
family and the personal loss that they
have felt
the fortitude they are showing
especially our king
at a time of bleak bereavement
is a clear sign of the fine man he is
and the fine king he will be
and i noticed how quickly he connected
with people yesterday when he returned
to buckingham palace
may he and his family take comfort
from the shared grief that the whole
nation and the commonwealth is feeling
her majesty as many have said was the
rock of certainty and reliability around
which the maelstrom of an ever-changing
world would circle like a hurricane
a beacon of hope a fulcrum of
dependability
from the post-war austerity through the
swinging sixties the permissive society
the space age globalization the age of
the internet and the world wide web and
the coronavirus pandemic she saw it all
she moved with the times but she also
acted as an anchor of stability and
security in the storm of the changes in
the world of the
the world saw
she came to chester in june 2018 to open
story house our new theater and art
center
the whole city was bouncing and buzzing
she the lord mayor and a couple of
others crammed into a small lift to go
up to the upper floors
of our new theater
doors are closing
said the automatic voice of the lift
yes so their majesty i think we can all
see that
and again it's one of those examples of
her using a little humor to put everyone
at ease particularly in that tight space
of the lift
and i'm so grateful that in chester and
across the realm
we were able to celebrate the platinum
jubilee earlier this year
so that she could see the love and the
and the gratitude for of all of us for
that life of service
may she rest in peace
god save the queen and god save the king
heather wheeler
thank you very much for calling me madam
deputy speaker
i along with most people in south
derbyshire i'm so sad that her majesty
queen elizabeth has left us
i on behalf of the constituents of south
derbyshire send our heartfelt
condolences to the royal family we have
been so lucky in most of our lifetime to
have had a queen who has been totally
dedicated to public service and duty
queen elizabeth showed us public
servants how it should be done and she
remains an inspiration to me as she has
been for so many other people
i was lucky enough to have the honour of
meeting her twice once in derby and once
in buckingham palace
both moments i would cherish for the
rest of my days
at buckingham palace i was with my dear
departed husband
and spent a wonderful evening chatting
with queen elizabeth and prince philip
all around us were buckets catching
raindrops from a dodgy roof which gave
me the opportunity to share our mutual
grief over leaking rooms and different
ways of trying to fix them probably not
a conversation many others have had with
the queen
she was amazingly knowledgeable on this
subject as on so much else
to close madame deputy speaker our
constitutional monarchy and its ability
to adapt and change with the times
is the envy of the world
none of us politicians
are more important than our monarch
ministers come and go
whilst the continuity of our monarchy
provides us with an important balance of
power of which i am proud
may our beloved queen elizabeth ii rest
in peace and long live king charles iii
here
sarah green
thank you madam deputy speaker it's an
honor to rise today to pay tribute to
her late majesty on behalf of my
constituents in cheshire and amisham as
we know the late queen came to the
throne having seen the torments and
consequences of war at a time when she
was still grieving for a much-loved
father and consoling her own mother
we are honoring someone who epitomized
service and fulfilled a promise made
over seven decades ago
i know i'm not the only one humbled by
her continued adherence to that promise
throughout her extraordinary life
here was a woman who had a talent for
connecting with people
even if they'd never met her
one constituent told me how he can
remember waving flags as a young child
at her coronation in 1953 and this year
we came together once again to celebrate
her platinum jubilee indeed the person
who lit the beacon in chelsea peter was
chosen from the select group of people
who had lived in the village
consistently since the queen came to the
throne in 1952
attending those jubilee events it was
absolutely clear
just how well-loved her late majesty was
throughout cheshire and amisham i was
told of her visit to us in 1985 as the
patron of the epilepsy society greeted
by a group of 1200 school children
another constituent got in touch this
morning to share his memory of
witnessing the queen going to thank lord
salisbury for organizing the flotilla on
the thames he said i saw a rough tough
forester with tears streaming down his
cheeks
mothers and children hugging after
exchanging a few words with her majesty
and she bestowed a cheeky grim with a
shrug of her shoulders on me just before
climbing into the helicopter
it is these fond and often deeply
personal memories that so many people
have to share that is so striking
whilst we remember her late majesty i am
mindful of the fact that his majesty
king charles has come to the throne
whilst grieving for his mother
i hope the knowledge that his majesty's
loss is shared by so many brings some
comfort to him and the royal family may
she rest in peace and god save the king
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
rise to express my deep condolences to
the royal family and those members of
the royal household on the death of her
majesty the queen
on and on behalf of my mid sussex
constituents we are all deeply thankful
for her life of remarkable service
her encouragement her grace her
fortitude and her warmth simply cannot
be matched and a true inspiration both
here and across the globe as we've heard
and the fact that she reached across the
generations uh supporting people young
and slightly older capturing the mood
and always studying as a presence in
those good times and sadly in the more
bad times and we don't have enough words
of thanks that can cover that deep
affection and devotion that we have for
her for her faithful and impeccable
public service and the commitment that
she embodied and that we try to reflect
in some small way and it was again on
display uh earlier this year as we all
came together across mid-sussex for
street parties for concerts church
services to celebrate her platinum
jubilee and as reflected on earlier in
the contributions growing up and onwards
to serve as one of her ministers her
constancy constancy and support of the
queen was always there and growing up as
a child in the 80s in fact a a speaker
in the chair who was a female and lady
thatcher it seemed perfectly normal to
have female leaders around us i didn't
actually notice there was lots of other
men but there we go there's another
story um our queen was absolutely there
and we're by our side and always with us
and came to our county most recently in
november
2017 but it was in mid-sussex back in
march 1999 when she formally opened
the triangle ledger center in burgess
hill with the um duke of edinburgh and
visited the town council and the help
point now many constituents have special
memories of meeting the queen receiving
a card or a letter or perhaps an honor
for their contribution to the nation and
our local community and i unlike other
people have only caught a glimpse for
her as a reporter i reported on her
coming to neighbouring or other
constituencies but i caught a glimpse of
her back in 1984 in my
neighboring area
where the south of england show is held
but also we do remember that she's
across the land on parks in every single
constituency where people she met and
gave comfort to or supported and very
often i remember conversations with my
grandmother about her and the
conversation was what would a handbag
look like and what color would she be
wearing would it be teal or green or
cornflower she seemed to dress for the
occasion a fashion icon as well
as i conclude my thoughts the constancy
and dedication that has been shown is
reflected in her son our new king his
work with charities will continue in his
son our new prince of wales and at this
time of deep personal sorrow we wish him
well and our new prince and princess of
wales he's had a long apprenticeship and
we look forward to seeing him shine god
save the king
florence
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
pay tribute to her late majesty the
queen
like many other people i had the
opportunity to meet the queen as a
counsellor i attended the annual garden
party at buckingham palace in 2010 with
my late mother
my mother like most british nigerians
who speak yoruba remarks that she's
going to meet ya charlie which
translates to charles's mother
and she proceeded to phone all her
family members across london and the and
nigeria to tell them the good news she's
going to the palace
i remember seeing some of the other
guests at the palace and seeing how good
it was to see so many members from the
commonwealth represented or dressed in
their national dress in uniform now
madame deputy speaker the one thing that
the british nigerian director in the uk
enjoy in addition to our culture and
hard work and education is a good party
and i remember my mother's face when she
was presented with sandwiches and cakes
at the garden party because according to
nigerians an event cannot be called a
party without jollof rice
when i saw the queen coming towards my
mother and my mom said she was going to
ask her about the food options and the
horror in my face because i thought i
could see the headlines in the daily
mail already
counsellor from brixton kicks off at the
garden party i pleaded with my mother
not to ask her about the catering
options and i said we would stop for kfc
on the way home
my constituency of vauxhall is home to
so many people from around the
commonwealth who are in britain for a
variety of reasons but the one thing
that stands in unique of their vision of
this country is the presence of the late
queen elizabeth the queen has fondly
remembered a cross boxing
long before air travel was common
king george vi and the royal family
including the young elizabeth would
often depart for their visits from
waterloo station and my constituency
including aurora visit to canada in 1939
and the royal visit to south africa in
1947.
in march 1967 the late queen opened the
queen elizabeth hall at the south bank
center and in 1977 she unveiled a plaque
to celebrate the new gardens created for
her silver jubilee
jubilee gardens
the queen returned to vauxhall to
officially open the transformed gardens
on the 25th of october 2012 during her
german jubilee year
and the gardens which sit as a backdrop
to the london eye continues to be
london's one of london's most much loved
and much-loved public spaces
the queen was a representative for our
country like no other and she
represented our country like no one else
the queen had a one raven commitment to
public service for over 70 years
and despite the level of scrutiny she
was under for long of her reign
her peerless dignity and leadership
meant that she always acted as a source
of prize
it was a pride felt by so many people
who were always out when they traveled
aboard about the queen
a pride felt but by those who become
british citizens while taking the oath
of allegiance
now we must welcome king charles iii to
the throne
and i know from his visit to vauxhall
and his personability and dignity he
will follow that long tradition
psalm 62 verse 5 to 6 reads
for god alone my soul waits in silence
for my hope is in him he alone is my
rock and my salvation my fortress i
shall not be shaken the queen was not
shaken
eternal restaurant to her oh lord and
let perpetual light shine upon her may
she rest in peace
victoria atkins thank you madam deputy
speaker
thursday the 8th of september 2022 was
the day we all knew must come but hoped
fervently
somehow would not
the waves of sadness that we all feel as
well as the individual acts of
remembrance and contemplation reflect
the respect and love we feel for her and
acknowledges how she shaped our modern
elizabethan age
her late majesty was our constant
from wise words and a wry smile in her
christmas addresses
to sucker in times of distress such as
the pandemic
and in our day-to-day lives her image on
our banknotes our coins and our stamps
her late majesty
was not just the keystone of our
constitution
she was also stitched into the rich
tapestries of our own lives i remember
madame deputy speaker the news at 10
with my watching the news at 10 with my
grandmothers who were of her generation
and there would be commentary fierce
commentary on the clothing worn by her
majesty on a particular visit but
everybody would agree that she always
looked wonderful in bright colors
as my honourable friend has referred to
earlier
we have a proud heritage of royalty in
my constituency of louth and horncastle
since 1066 the king's champion has held
the feudal manner of scribblesby the
role of the king's champion is to gallop
into westminster hall on horseback in
full armor to throw down the gauntlet
that is where the phrase comes from to
challenge any newcomers to the incoming
monarch
i am very much hoping that king charles
iii is going to reinstate this
tradition
we also are the birthplace of king henry
iv in 1367 at bowling brook castle and
in 1643 there was a very important
battle the battle of windspeed
where the parliamentarians beat the
royalists but perhaps will gloss over
that but there is also raf conningsby
which her majesty late majesty visited
in 1976.
this is the home of the typhoon fast
jets they are the heroes that fly up
into our skies to protect us at uh
very short notice but it is also the
home of the battle of britain memorial
flight
they are the historic plains that form
the part of any flypast over buckingham
palace we saw them in their joy uh in
the recent celebrations of her late
majesty's jubilee
and they include spitfires hurricanes
and thumper a lancaster one of only two
remaining that can fly in the world
today and we know from those pictures of
her majesty on the balcony the joy that
those fly past used to give her and so
i'm incredibly proud that my
constituents have played their part in
bringing her such happiness so on behalf
of my constituents i give thanks for her
extraordinary public service over seven
decades and also for the more private
acts of kindness and humor and humility
that we've heard in recent days in this
place and on television
but as we mourn the end of this great
elizabethan era we look to the future
and with hope to the reign of king jars
iii he will lead our nation and indeed
the commonwealth with the same devotion
and skill as his beloved mother
he has our sincerest condolences for his
loss
our admiration for his steadfast
composure in assuming the crown in the
midst of his grief and our heartfelt
thanks for his quiet determination to
serve our nation as as well and
devotedly as his late mother
god save the king
fabian hamilton
thank you mr um madame deputy speaker
um
the right honourable member for sutton
coalfield uh said something that i think
chimed with all of us and that is when
we visit primary schools what is the
first question the children ask us
and it is that
have you met her majesty the queen
and so i was asked the same question by
chapel allen
primary school in my constituency by
saint paul's roman catholic primary
school when i was there recently
my right honourable friend
the member for pontifract and castleford
said
her majesty the queen
will always remain the forever queen
and i was reminded of that when my
younger daughter ruth told me yesterday
that when she went to school following
the death of her majesty
one of her six-year-old pupils said
but she's been the queen all my life
my daughter said well mine too and by
the way my dad's as well
that's how long she's been with us
madam deputy speaker i had three
encounters i remember
clearly with her majesty the first was
when i was a councillor in leeds and she
came to
a dinner at the banking suite in leeds
civic hall to celebrate and to open the
royal armouries
which had moved to the city of leeds we
were very proud of that
but she was struck by grief because it
was days after the appalling dunblane
massacre
and in those few hours she was with us
she seemed to epitomize and sum up
in her demeanor
the grief that we all felt
about that appalling
tragedy
and then some years later
i was privileged to be at the golden
jubilee event in westminster hall
and i invited my dear late mother of
blessed memory to sit with me
and we heard in that dignified address
to all of us those of us who were there
will never forget it
the stories that the queen recounted
about living in london during the blitz
well my mother was a child here in
london during the blitz and when i
looked at her
she was in tears because the queen had
summed it up so brilliantly so perfectly
what life was like for everybody living
through that terrible time and then the
final encounter that i recall was the
only time i ever had a conversation with
her majesty
and that was at buckingham palace many
members here will recall
that once a parliament we were invited
to buckingham palace back benches
and there we were we've been presented
to her majesty and she came to the group
that i was with and she looked at my
name badge and she said ah you're from
leeds are you uh do you represent my
cousin uh the earl of harwood and i said
yes i do ma'am of course i do uh he's in
northeast leeds
and she said
wasn't there a fire
on the set there i said sorry do you
mean the set of she said yes that soap
opera
emmerdale
and i said yes you're quite right you're
quite right ma'am there was a fire there
and have they now recovered yes indeed
they have and i was struck
by the extraordinary knowledge of
everyday life in our country the
programs that people watch on television
the life that we lead of which she was
so much a part woven into the fabric of
our lives in that way so let me conclude
madame deputy speaker by saying on
behalf of the people of round a more
town meanwood chapel allerton and all
woodley that make up north east leeds
may she rest in internal peace long live
king charles iii
jane keegan
thank you madam deputy speaker thank you
for calling me to speak in this debate
and may i start by sending my heartfelt
condolences to his majesty the king and
the entire royal family and royal
household
i rise today to express the love
gratitude and respect that all those who
live in the chichester constituency have
for our late queen
in all parts of the country and indeed
the commonwealth our lake queen has
touched every generation
our young still have fresh memories of
planting saplings to mark the recent
platinum jubilee for forming the greek
the queen's green canopy which like her
reign will live on for decades
those of us a little older will remember
the street parties for her silver
jubilee and still treasure the mugs and
the memories
memories which remind us what it means
to be british
and our unique traditions
in no other country anywhere in the
world does the whole population
celebrate by sitting in the middle of
the street usually in the rain eating
sponge cake
unique and highly differentiated
her majesty visited my constituency
several times to offer support uh to the
chichester festival theatre
her first visit was with his royal
highness prince philip for the inaugural
season in 1962 and they came back again
in 1964 for a performance of othello
with lord lawrence olivier and a maggie
smith
it was during her most recent visit that
i had the incredible honor of meeting
her majesty
now growing up in noseley gives you many
life skills but a proper curtsy was not
one of them
so after much practice than i care to
admit i found myself a waiting
introduction placed between our bishop
and our chief constable who reassuringly
were both as nervous as i was
as she entered the room as everybody has
said you were immediately struck by her
smile not her smile her smiling eyes
as i was introduced to the queen
she immediately smiled and she said how
long have you been the member of
parliament for chichester
on hearing my reply i'd been elected
just a few months earlier in 2017 she
shot back ah you're a snapper she was of
course referring to the snap general
election
she then asked me how it was all going
and i had to be truthful and admit it
wasn't going all that well
she replied kindly
good luck i think you may need it
with experience comes wisdom
my brief introduction and the subsequent
lunch i spent with our late queen is a
memory i will treasure forever
now the queen is an extraordinary role
model for all of us but our queen also
had the most marvelous role models in
her parents they had seen our country
through the perils of the second world
war her father had even seen action in
the battle of jutland in 1916 and on the
death of her father queen elizabeth sent
a message to her first prime minister
winston churchill which was read to this
house on the 11th of february 1952 and
in it she said that her father had set
before me an example of selfless
dedication which i resolved with god's
help to follow
i think we may all conclude that she
honored her promise to the british
people and met it in full
on behalf of everybody in the chichester
constituency i want to say thank you for
everything
and god save the king
joe stevens
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
so many words have been said and written
already about the late queen but i'm
very grateful to you madam deputy
speaker the opportunity to speak from
the back benches today and pay tribute
on behalf of my constituents in cardiff
central to the late queen
cardiff central's a really young
constituency the average age of the
people that i represent is amongst the
youngest of any constituency across the
united kingdom
so for nearly every one of them nearly
every one of them the late queen was the
only monarch that they and i have ever
lived under
and being the constituency at the center
our capital city of wales we were very
lucky that the lake queen visited it on
many occasions where she always received
a very warm welsh welcome
in 1948 princess elizabeth as she then
was was the first ever person to be
awarded the freedom of cardiff and in
july 1953 just a month after her
coronation the late queen made her first
official visit to wales to cardiff
central where thousands of well-wishers
lined the route of the royal procession
to cardiff city hall
and it was during the sixth british
empire and commonwealth games in 1958
that the late queen in a recorded
message to those assembled at cardiff
arms park announced her intention to
make her son prince nanking charles the
prince of wales
and so yesterday our new king announced
his decision to pass the title on to our
new principal and princess of wales and
we look forward to welcoming them both
back to you yeah yeah yeah
the late queen was a dedicated patron of
many charities and organizations right
across wales including for 50 years the
welsh rugby union and to mark the
centenary of the wru in 1980 she wrote a
message on a rugby ball which was
relayed all the way from london via
numerous rugby clubs in wales before it
eventually arrived at cardiff arms park
where a joint england and wales team
played against a joint scotland and
ireland teams a special
game to mark the wlu centenary
and then in 1999 when we hosted the
rugby world cup final at the brand new
millennium stadium the late queen
presented the trophy to the winning
australian team so there are very many
people who have lots of fond memories of
those royal visits to cardiff central
and on behalf of my constituents i send
our deepest sympathy but also our
gratitude to king charles iii and all of
the royal family
gratitude for her majesty the late
queen's absolute dedication to a
lifetime of public service for her
dignity and for her decency thank you
mom
dame caroline darny
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
the overwhelming theme of the last two
days has surely been our late queen's
unparalleled service duty and dedication
and these are qualities that are
particularly understood and valued in my
gospel constituency set as you know
madam deputy speaker on the shores of
portsmouth harbour firmly in the heart
of our royal navy
community
home to a vast number of service
personnel and veterans people who show
enormous duty dedication and service
in every aspect of their professional
lives
but not solely their commander-in-chief
her majesty had very strong personal
links to our armed forces her father was
in the royal navy she herself served in
world war ii
and of course the enduring love of her
life was that very handsome naval
officer
the longest serving head of any military
unit she led by example with an entire
life and reign of service and duty
one of my greatest memories was her
visit just that short hop away across
portsmouth harbor for the commissioning
ceremony of her namesake the flagship
royal navy aircraft carrier hms queen
elizabeth in december 2017
it took place in a mammoth hangar inside
this colossal ship packed full of
members of the ship's company their
families dignitaries and many many more
who served in her name and i watched
this tiny figure surrounded by enormous
crowds giant objects in this vast space
dressed in beautiful purple command the
respect the dedication the love and the
service of all those who gathered
exuding warmth putting them all at their
ease it was quite a sight
this incredible woman
a female leader in the days decades
before that was fashionable
but she wasn't a job she hadn't applied
for a responsibility she hadn't sought a
role she wasn't even born to do
on her 21st birthday as we've heard she
said i declare before you all that my
whole life be it long or short shall be
devoted to your service
if ever in history there was a promise
or a commitment that was kept
my goodness it was that one
now i found some great comfort in the
last
couple of days from seeing very precious
video clips of her majesty in her
downtime enjoying herself cheering on
her horses at royal ascot or petting her
beloved corgis it's clear and many
others have said she had a zest for life
a sense of mischief she had the most
incredible ability to surprise and
delight us many have spoken of her
mission with double 07 her love of
marmalade sandwiches with paddington
bear but her majesty once said herself
grief is the price that we pay for love
and the sadness that's felt by my
constituents across gosport leon solent
stubbington and hill head surely surely
shows just how much we all loved her
so
in the words of paddington bear madam
deputy speaker
thank you ma'am
for everything god save the king
chris stevens
thank you madam deputy speaker you do
not require to be
a slavish royalist or indeed a fanatical
follower of the institution to recognize
seven decades of extraordinary public
service and duty not just to the nations
and regions of these islands by the
commonwealth and influence in the wider
world and therefore on behalf of glasgow
southwest constituents i want to extend
uh
my condolences and theirs to the royal
family
who are remembering a mother a
grandmother and a great grandmother
in glasgow southwest of course her
majesty had opened the govern walkway
during the silver jubilee years
which had which has parameter views of
many of glasgow city's landmarks
including of course the shipyards which
do so much uh for the royal navy where
you can see the riverside museum in the
lost side of the city just just across
from it and many of the landmarks
heading into a glasgow city centre it
also hosts
a state-of-the-art medical facility the
largest hospital
perhaps in these islands
at the queen elizabeth university
hospital which is providing so much
medical treatment and care to thousands
of people in scotland but i think that
i've heard many of the personal stories
madam deputy speaker i'm going to share
one and it concerns my grandparents
charlie and isabel alcorn who in the 3rd
of july 2004 just one day before their
diamond wedding anniversary received a
letter and card from her majesty
the sheer joy and delight that that gave
my grandparents and the weather family
that 60 years of marriage was being
recognized i i think i is something
that's not just shared with my
grandparents but many people across
these islands because how many cards
will his new majesty
give to people who have 60 years
i i i celebrate their diamond wedding
anniversaries i would suggest not very
many it was of course a traditional
marriage madam deputy speaker my
grandmother always graciously allowed my
grandpa to think that he was head of the
house
but we of course
knew different
but
for so many members of the house i have
mentioned madame deputy speaker it's
just so small acts of of a late majesty
those that lack of kindness those little
acts i think are perhaps something that
we should think about when we discuss
our deliberations in this house
and and they have my constituents mishi
rest in peace
madam david speaker i rise to pay
tribute on behalf of my constituents in
reading west and myself to our late
great queen elizabeth
the queen was a comforting constant
through our lifetimes she was indeed a
unique beacon of wisdom of grace of
kindness and of courage at the head of
our country in the commonwealth for
seven decades
she was a rock
we turned to as a nation in times of
uncertainty and sadness and indeed when
we celebrated occasions of national joy
now our great queen has gone
leaving a void in all our lives
and as we mourn
our hearts go out to her family as they
grieve for their profound loss
madame devin speaker the queen's was by
any measure the most extraordinary of
lies and she touched the lives of
countless other people across the world
the first time i saw the queen in person
was as an excited ten year old
lined up with others along the bath road
in reading during the silver jubilee
celebrations all of us clutching and
waving our miniature union flags as her
car sped past
we only got a fleeting glimpse of her
majesty we talked excitedly about the
occasion for days
afterwards such was the reaction she
inspired
in world leaders and sculpture and alike
the first time we got to meet the queen
properly was in 2014 when she came to
open formally the magnificently rebuilt
reading train station
and i can tell you madame deputy speaker
i felt the same schoolboy excitement of
37 years earlier at the prospect of
meeting her majesty
and this time i got to shake her hand
and i'll always cherish that moment and
indeed a photograph of that occasion of
the queen smiling that famous radiant
smile is nestled among photographs of my
own family in our home
now other right on board members have
already described the trepidation felt
during the ceremony to join the privy
council indeed to collect your seal of
office as a secretary of state
the worry about kneeling on those pesky
footstools
but her majesty would always be a kind
calming influence and she had a unique
ability to make one feel at ease
we all know that the queen and the royal
family champion many causes
and one of those is protecting our
environment and our planet
the queen was sadly not able to attend
cop 26 in person as she had intended to
but she was kind enough to share a
message with world leaders
acknowledging her pride in the leading
role played by prince philip prince
charles now our king
and prince william in encouraging people
to protect our precious planet
and in concluding her remarks she said
i for one
hope that this conference will be one of
those rare occasions where everyone will
have the chance to rise above the
politics of the moment and will achieve
true statesmanship
it is the hope of many that the legacy
of this summit written in the history
books yet to be printed will describe
you as leaders who did not pass up the
opportunity and that you answered the
call of those future generations
madame dev speaker that history is still
to be written and i hope and i pray
that the leaders of today here in our
own country and across the world will
heed the queen's wise world words
now of course we have a new monarch king
charles iii a long-standing leader in
the fight against climate change
through my work over the past few years
on the cop26 agenda i've had the
privilege to support the work of king
charles sustainable markets initiative
he is a great man
and he will be a great monarch who has
the same instinctive understanding of
his people and what matters to them as
his mother did
god save the king
madam deputy speaker is with great
sadness that i rise today to pay tribute
to his majesty elizabeth ii
and send my condolences to the royal
family on behalf of the people of
preston and myself
the queen has been with us most of all
of our lives
through many times of difficulty and
crises
wars
her reign began as the korean war was
just coming to an end
and ended
six months into a war closer to the home
in ukraine
this is having huge economic and
security effects on all of our lives
she reigned through suis the falklands
the gulf war
bosnia
libya just to name some
in addition
pandemics such as covid and foot and
mouth
she's seen massive employment in the
1980s
and the cost of living crisis today the
like of which this country has not seen
in 40 years
throughout all of these extremely
difficult times
the nation could always look to the
queen
as a sign that whatever happened in life
life for most of us would continue
and we would come out of the crisis in
hand
she offered reassurance
she provided a sense of security and a
feeling that because of the length of
her reign
and the fact that she was around at the
time of the second world war
life would go on in this country and
most people would get through whatever
difficulties we faced
continuity
was her hallmark
all of us
have our own memories of our meetings
with her
my fondest memories of her
were when preston was selected to
receive city status in the year of of
her golden jubilee in 2002.
she came to preston
and i had the pleasure of accompanying
her
and chatting with her and prince philip
as she walked around the newly anointed
city
she was charming
polite
witty
kind and interested
in taking time to speak to people in the
crowds and thousands who turned out to
greet her
she'll be an impossible act to follow
but i am confident that king charles iii
will step up and make his own unique
mark on our public life in this country
the member for reading just
commented on his views on climate change
and i remember the work he was doing on
conservation in eastern europe i'm sure
he will make his mark and have his
influence on whichever prime minister
serves in the future
rest in peace queen elizabeth
and god save the king
andrew jones very much madam deputy
speaker it is a privilege to pay tribute
personally and on behalf of the people
of harrogate in ezra to her late majesty
one of the greatest figures in our
national story and to send our deepest
condolences to his royal highness the
king and all members of the royal family
her late majesty had been a regular
visitor to our part of yorkshire so many
people have met her and beautiful
stories have been shared she was held
very dear
the outpourings of
love and grief and her passing have come
from right across the community
but the depth and breadth of emotion now
from across the uk and across the world
shows her astonishing connections with
us her people
our relationship with her late majesty
was profound and based on love respect
and inspiration over so long
a lady in my constituency who has told
me when she was a young girl in the war
she looked up to the young princesses
and their role in our national effort
that was over 80 years ago
now i never met her late majesty i never
knew her
but i felt like she knew me
in her broadcasts she spoke to our
hearts she has been a part of our lives
almost a part of our families
the depth of the grief that we are now
all individually and collectively
feeling also shows that we're starting
to understand
just what she has given us
how she has helped us through tough
times how she helped make our country
and so many others
better places immensely so immeasurably
so
the tributes in this chamber across our
communities and across the world have
highlighted the magic that she brought
to all that she did
her remarkable life leaves a powerful
legacy
she has defined the standard for service
wisdom and compassion
dignity and humility
in speaking less but saying more and
above all duty
there is a deep sense of loss for a
beloved figure so from the people of
harrogate and nurseborough thank you
may your late majesty rest in peace and
god save the king
thank you man
i never met the late man you see
the queen but i have been in her garden
and she was a unifying presence wasn't
she for all of us and her loss
leaves a huge hole after a remarkable
iconic 96 year life recent years have
seen her starring with paddington bear
and james bond
which demonstrate her sense of fun
alongside the sense of duty
but for me memories of that remarkable
reign start with 1977 and the silver
jubilee i remember my five-year-old mind
being blown by the fact that i was
sitting eating cake in the middle of
pixar lane a very busy thoroughfare in
healing and it was transformed from my
first ever street party i went to dozens
more as mp for her platinum jubilee
she was a constant comforting presence
whether it was from her early days as
princess elizabeth telling evacuated
wartime kids not to worry right up to by
the time she'd mastered zoom her covered
reassurance with the same message to a
worried nation and her remarkable reign
spanned
15 prime ministers from churchill when
she was just 25 years old to her 15th
this week when she was obviously the
older and wiser one current pm half her
age she's head of state to 15 other
nations she oversaw transition from
commonwealth from empire to commonwealth
but for locals my age it'll always be
1985 when she opened ealing broadway
shopping center that we remember it felt
that half the school had bunked up for
it except for square old me
and
many classmates who pulled a sickie got
rumbled when the teacher saw them on the
evening news
but she couldn't get to cross in the
same way it's actually this year i
actually requested for my
sixth former son that he be let off
lessons for the queen's garden party and
the teacher allowed it making his
absence part of the lesson that they
were doing on constitutional monarchy
which of course she personified
superlatively
her seemingly endless limitless work
ethic
and work load that continued two days
until
her death
but the signs were there that
non-attendance of the last garden party
and the queen's speech
both delegated to the king
even septics who came into orbit became
converts like kieran gavin may revealing
in 2002
when she came to gunnersbury park for
the golden jubilee
he said i asked if she was ever tempted
to take the head off while knighting
with her sword someone she didn't like
she replied it'd be totally
inappropriate but
she might nick the neck a tiny bit if it
was one of those people she found really
irritated
he told me that she was charming witty
smiley utterly delightful company kieran
said i'm a republican but i became a
huge fan if she ever stood for election
i'd vote for her
we will never see the likes of her again
she trained as a mechanic in the war had
children from the 40s to 60s who kept
the line going presided over un and
commonwealth summits
and was genuinely beloved end of an era
cannot sum up 70 years
but as one elizabethan area era ends
another begins it'll take some time of
getting used to new stamps and coins in
time but may she rest in eternal peace
god save the king
poplar
thank you madam deputy speaker for
allowing me to speak about the long and
dedicated life of her majesty the queen
on behalf of my constituents in harrow
east my my friends family and myself
harrow has a unique
uh royal link being the first borough
being created when emergency the queen
came to the throne
we've had many royal visits over many
many years
and indeed we've celebrated every
jubilee and earlier this year of course
we celebrated the platinum jubilee with
civic functions
but more importantly
those street parties that many people
have spoken about
for me i want to mention two of those
visits which contrast the way that
harrow and indeed the country has
changed over her reign
the first
some 50 years ago when she visited
harrow school
on the 400th anniversary
of the school being created
far better than that school just down
the road from windsor castle
the second and demonstrates that harold
now
has literally people from every country
on the planet
every religion
and every language spoken on earth
within our borough
and so the second visit was of course
during her golden jubilee in 2012 when
we
celebrated her coming to krishna avanti
primary school
the first state-sponsored hindu primary
school in the country
where children from across the borough
came together to meet the queen
my personal memories i remember parading
at windsor castle as a queen scout
meeting the queen at the queen's garden
parties as a councillor as an assembly
member and also as an mp my favorite
memory was of course as a newly elected
mp being allowed to drive through the
gates of buckingham palace park in the
centre of buckingham palace climbing the
stairs and being greeted by her majesty
the queen directly
now madam deputy speaker i'm an avowed
royalist and monarchist
and i think it's fair to say that as we
pass on our grief
to the royal family for the loss of her
majesty the queen
it is fair to say that king charles iii
has had the longest apprenticeship in
history
and for those that don't believe in the
heritage system
i think it demonstrates and he's already
demonstrated the wisdom of having that
system
so to her majesty the queen
we say
god bless
thank you for your dedicated service mom
um shanti
rest in peace and to the king king
charles iii
may you live a long life
long live the king
sarah owen
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
pay tribute to her majesty queen
elizabeth ii on behalf of my
constituents in luton north our country
has lost its queen and a family has lost
its mother grandmother and cherished
great-grandmother
my thoughts are with the royal family
during this immense time of loss and
also with the people mourning the death
of the sovereign who played such a
pivotal role in their lives for so many
years
many will have sadly experienced the
painful hole left after the death of the
head of a family a matriarch
they will know the emptiness that echoes
through the generations because the
loved one is no longer there
but they will also know the fullness of
a lifetime of lessons and devotion those
things never leave us
since news of her death there have been
displays of affection for the queen
across luton north but especially from
younger generations
yesterday morning students at lee manor
lined up outside school to pay their
respects
lewton's sixth form college fell silent
in remembrance there was time for
reflective prayer at cardinal newman
school and the head teacher of chalk
hills academy addressed students and
staff about the need to mourn but also
honor and celebrate the queen's life
and what better place
to honor significant occasions than in
luton
indeed her late majesty chose luton to
mark a very significant life event
celebrating her honeymoon with prince
philip in luton who yeah
well they say some things cannot be
fixed they can only be carried
and the queen was the master of carrying
on
whether it was during the second world
war at times of national crisis and most
recently during the pandemic
the queen was the epitome of the british
keep calm and carry on
easy to say often harder to do
especially during times of grief
i understand that her christian faith
was a driver in that she was never shy
about her beliefs and how they motivated
her service
i know that churches mosques temples in
my diverse constituency will be keeping
the royal family and the country in
their prayers during this period of
mourning sunden park baptist church have
opened a book of condolence and i know
that many others will be doing the same
the queen came to power when the nation
was recovering from the aftermath of war
the king comes to power at a time when
the world is also recovering and facing
many challenges
in 2002 during her christmas broadcast
the queen spoke words that are just as
relevant today nearly 20 years on
our modern world
places such heavy demands on our time
and attention that the need to remember
our responsibilities to others is
greater than ever
wise wise words
you don't have to be a staunch royalist
to appreciate that this in every sense
is truly the end of an era and the
beginning of another rest in peace your
majesty
david morris
thank you madam deputy speaker
on behalf of my constituency my whole
community
i cannot convey how heartbroken we are
to lose to lose her majesty the queen
i have had the honor of meeting her
majesty
i met the queen in october 2013.
she asked me about my constituency and
my community
and how we were all getting on there she
was very very warm and down to earth
she was no stranger to malcolm either
and my surrounding district
imagine her majesty the queen visited
morkum not long after her coronation
in april 1955 signing a royal portrait
in august 1989 she visited heating port
on route to a beloved balmoral
my whole community welcomed her in
morkan in july 1999 when she unveiled
the eric morcom's statue
the queen told david miles president of
the eric morgan fan club
that both her majesty and the duke of
edinburgh
were big fans of more common wise and of
eric bartholomew or eric morgan as
everybody else would know
we also have royal patronage in our area
the shifting course of the river kent
and the fast-moving tides in the area
make the task of leading a safe crossing
across morkan bay a very perilous task
in 1985 the queen's guide to the sand
cedric robinson guided princeton across
the sands in the hall strong carriage
today i remember
her majesty's reign in my life with
fondness
and the past few days with very very
deep and great sadness
only a few weeks ago i welcome king
charles
to the winter gardens
to see what my community has done with a
marvelous old building and to also visit
the eden north site
may her majesty rest in peace
my thoughts are with the royal family
of the royal family
god save the king
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
speak on behalf of people in plymouth to
express our condolences to the royal
family on the death of the queen
i've dated a lot of queens in my time
but i've only
i've only ever met the queen once and
that was shortly after being elected in
2018 it was a wet day at plymouth train
station and i was doubly excited firstly
as a trained nerd i was going to get a
site of the royal train we don't get
regal rolling stock in devon very often
so i was excited about that and secondly
it was a chance to see a true icon of
our age
a leader like no other the queen
she toddled off the train meeting the
dignitaries on the way through looking
resplendent in a pink outfit and a pink
hat at the same time i look down at my
tie bright pink as well queens really do
wear pink i thought to myself and she
said to me when she got to me
why aren't you in parliament i'm
thinking oh dear i get this i said well
the whips let me off and she said
i hope they would too
and gave me a little smile and i thought
that was all okay and that was the
spirit of the queen meeting so many
people putting them at ease
the queen was in plymouth that day to
decommission hms ocean before her sail
to brazil as the head of our armed
forces the queen visited plymouth and
devonport dockyard on a number of
occasions
she was a very part of our
military command structure a part of our
royal navy and a part of our royal
marines
she first visited 1942 at the age of
just 16 visiting the dockyard with her
father king george vi
four years later she visited again as a
sea ranger to visit the battleship hms
duke of york
the queen's visits to our city parallel
our recovery from the ashes of the
plymouth blitz to the renewal and
evolution of our military tactics with
the royal navy and the royal marines the
rebuilding of plymouth city center the
opening of the civic center in 1962 and
in 1988 as we marked the 400th
anniversary of the spanish armada she
opened this sundial in plymouth civic
center and city center giving our
teenagers somewhere to meet their mates
in town for 40 years since
it has been
an incredible legacy that she leaves as
a daughter a wife and a mother to royal
navy officers the queen's link to the
royal navy into devonport in particular
is plentiful
not just when she presents the navy with
new colours as she did in 2003
but often to express sorrow for those
members of our armed forces family for
whom we have lost in action often visits
without fanfare conversations with real
heart
for my generation she was the grandma to
the nation
a towering figure of female leadership
and for a lifetime of devotion selfless
public service and duty
we say thank you
long live
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i rise
uh with humility and sadness
on behalf of myself and the people of
bangkok and buchan to pay tribute
to her late majesty the queen
i also offer my condolences to king
charles iii and the royal family
as we remember that they have lost a
mother a grandmother and a great
grandmother
most of us her majesty has always been
there continuing and reassuring
presence from the ashes of the second
world war
to the covert 19 pandemic in more recent
years she has been there providing
reassurance and inspiration to people
right across our united kingdom
she's also been a much admired and loved
figure across the commonwealth of course
but right around the world
i sadly unlike many others
in this place never had the opportunity
to meet the queen myself
however growing up and living in and now
representing and at in this place one of
three constituencies in aberdeenshire it
will come as no surprise perhaps that i
know a fair few people who have had the
privilege to not only meet but to
actually know the queen
and when i hear the tributes from
honorable and right honourable members
in these last two days
who have known her majesty i recognize
the warmth and the affection in the
stories that i've heard from those who
have known the queen
whether in a formal or a social setting
we have all heard how well her majesty
could make people feel at ease
and this wasn't just a case or just a
matter of decorum or just a case of
being a nice and kind person which of
course she very much was
uh but she somehow knew she somehow had
this sixth sense or superpower to
precise to know precisely what actions
she needed to take to make that one
individual person feel at ease
as a member of parliament the closest i
ever got to the queen is in the peers
lobby watching the state opening of
parliament on the screen
before i was elected however her majesty
visited the tariff agricultural show in
my hometown in 2014
uh on the occasion of the 150th
anniversary of that occasion
and on that occasion
i was able to get as close to the queen
as offend myself now to my honourable
friend the member for whit from whitney
sitting on the on the front bench um or
rather i found myself in the adoring
crowd
through which her majesty was moving
through gracefully as she always did
engaging with everyone as she did with
that famous smile and twinkling eye
we've heard so much about in the last
two days
that smile which
with which we have all become very
familiar and we will always remember
the organizers of third show she meant
that they were moved by humility or
warmth of humor not to mention our
expert knowledge of the livestock and
animals on display horses of course been
a particular passion for her majesty
as they are for our daughter the
princess royal who returned to visit the
show earlier this year the people of
tariff will remember fondly uh the visit
uh of her late majesty as well the
people of frasier when she visited that
town celebrating the 400th anniversary
of that town in 1992 and when she
visited mcduff and banff on a launch
from the royal yacht britannia in 1961.
in scotland we saw the queen at our most
relaxed and happy particularly on our
regular visits to our much loved bulb
model in west aberdeenshire we've heard
the stories from our stays there
including from former prime ministers
who had the joy of being driven around
balmoral the state by the queen herself
in the land rover
i know it would have been a comfort to
her her family to spend her last days in
the place she loved so much the united
kingdom the commonwealth of the world
will come together in the coming days to
mourn the passing of a great perhaps the
greatest world leader and as we reflect
on her long life
and of reign of loyal service we also
remember fondly her compassion humor and
warmth she continues to be in all of our
hearts may her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii rest in peace god save the
king
paulette hamilton
thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker on behalf
of my constituents in birmingham
erdington i would like to offer my
sincere condolences follow the following
the passing of her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
our thoughts and prayers are with the
king and the royal family at this time
the sad loss of our greatest and longest
serving monarch is being felt around the
world
and she will be greatly missed
but we should also celebrate a lifetime
of extraordinary service to our nation
the king's devote the queen's devotion
to the united kingdom
and the commonwealth should be an
inspiration to us all
a dedication
to the christian faith as the head of
the church of england was also a shining
example of duty and integrity
most people across our country have
never known a time when the queen was
not there and this is especially true
for me as one of our burn of one up as
one of our birmingham mps as i represent
the youngest city in europe
during a 70 year reign the queen visited
birmingham over a dozen times including
castlevale and the jaguar car factory in
my constituency in 1998.
she met thousands of local people during
that time and we know that every person
she met went away with a memory that
will be treasured for a lifetime
as a birmingham city councillor i had
the privilege of being invited to share
afternoon tea with members of the royal
family at buckingham palace and talk
about my work to improve mental health
in birmingham
the time i spent there was an honor and
i will never forget the royal family
showed me a true commitment to tackling
real issues like mental health and i
know this commitment will continue under
the new king
i also want to mention the queen's
incredible ability to be died to bring
diverse communities together in
celebration
this summer i actually lost count of the
number of amazing events i attended at
local schools and community groups to
celebrate the historic platinum jubilee
with food music games and of course
dancing in a royal in her majesty's
honor
miss
miss
deputy madame deputy speaker
this is a sad occasion but the queen has
left such a positive legacy for us to
celebrate
on behalf of the people of erdington
king standing and castlevale i offer my
deepest condolences god save the king
madam deputy speaker i rise humbling
with great sadness to pay tribute to her
majesty the queen on behalf of my family
my constituents and the people of
worcestershire
the late queen was an inspiration and an
example to us all she taught us the true
meaning of duty and she reigned and
worked for so long and so hard more than
85 percent of the population of this
country have never known anybody but the
queen as monarch and nearly one-third of
the population say that they have met or
seen her many of my constituents have
told me about their own interactions
whether it be putting the matisse when
they received an honour at the palace
chatting to her to the event in the
constituency or just seeing her perhaps
from afar at a sporting event and of
course we all know her special love for
racing
millions more never saw the queen but
nevertheless felt that there was an
intimate relationship there because of
the way that her majesty communicated
when she gave her christmas broadcast it
felt like she was there with us in our
own homes when she told us that we will
meet again it was as if she was sending
that message to us all individually and
personally and of course she remains and
will remain for some time on 29 billion
coins and four and a half billion
banknotes we will be seeing the queen
and thinking of her for a long time to
come
i myself first saw the queen when i was
at university and her impending sudden
visit uh suddenly led to a considerable
refurbishment of the common room the
student common room
which of course we were very grateful
for but i fear may have added to the
legend that wherever the monarch goes
smells of fresh paint
and the last time i saw her majesty was
at the launch of the queen's baton relay
last october outside of buckingham
palace where she placed her message to
the commonwealth to be read out at the
opening ceremony into the baton had it
uh handed it to kadena cox the athlete
and that baton then
started its journey around the 72
nations and territories of the
commonwealth including many
of the constituencies and memphis in
this room hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people turned out to cheer
on the baton bearers the baton but of
course it was the queen's baton we were
also cheering on her majesty and i'm so
pleased that we're all able to show our
love and affection for her also and she
saw it during the jubilee celebrations
this year
madam deputy speaker the queen was the
epitome of duty service dignity and
grace her constitutional powers were
limited but her global influence was
immense
because of the way she conducted herself
the way she wore the crown
no matter what any of us here can do it
will be as nothing to what a call an
invitation or a visit from her late
majesty could do
but all of us who saw king charles's
speech last night will have also seen
glimpses of his mother he appeared well
aware of the awesome responsibility
ahead of him
he was regal yet relatable expressing
love and warmth that consoled us all
so we say goodbye to the queen and the
elizabethan age
but we will never forget her
may she rest in peace
god save the king
like so many people
i have only known a world where queen
elizabeth the second was our queen
the wonderful tributes we've heard
have often included reference to the
amazing longevity of her reign
and i was reminded of this
when i looked at the dates of her many
visits to sefton
when the queen first visited brutal
crosby and southport in the early 1950s
they were all in the county of
lancashire
they only became parts of the borough of
sefton
some 20 years later
with local government reorganization
a story familiar to
many people in fact i'm sure across the
country
the queen also visited brutal in 1962
and as part of her silver jubilee tour
in 1977
and she went to orc car training camp in
my constituency in 1985
and again to visit southport at the same
visit
entry racecourse is in my septum central
constituency
and it is of course home to the world's
most famous horse race
so given the queen's love of horses
it was perhaps no surprise that she
first attended the grand national in
1956
and it was fitting
that red rum
saved his record third win in the grand
national for 1977 and the queen's silver
jubilee
people across sefton have fond memories
of the queen's visits
none more so
than when she joined the commemoration
of the 50th anniversary of the battle of
the atlantic at brutal town hall in
1993. the links to the armed forces and
to the merchant navy which she
recognized through her visits to sefton
have provided service personnel and
civilians fond memories
and demonstrated the queen's gratitude
for their service to our nation
the messages of condolence from my
constituents have displayed warmth and
gratitude to the queen
memories offer will be treasured for
years to
come queen elizabeth ii did her duty for
my constituents and she deserves a
heartfelt thanks for our service her
service to our nation
may she rest in peace
long live the king
henry smith
madame deputy speaker thank you for
allowing me this opportunity to express
my respect
uh my sorrow
and my thanks to her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
on behalf of my constituents in crawley
myself and my family
much has been said
in the last few days since we heard the
news we all feared
on thursday with her passing away
about how she has been a constant
presence
in our lives personally and
nationally
and there are very few people
alive today who have known any other
monarch but her late majesty
my thoughts on her passing away were the
first time
i ever saw the queen
i was born and brought up
in my early formative years in the epsom
area in surrey and
when i was a young child
my
late mum
took my brother and i uh up to the derby
at epsom and again much has been said
about her majesty's great love of horse
racing and she attended the derby
virtually every year of her reign
we
positioned ourselves about half a mile
down the road where we knew her official
car would be leaving after the race and
i remember waving my union jack
a passion for flags that i've had ever
since as a vexologist
and
i remember
as her car passed her wearing those
vivid bright colors that she always did
so that people
at public events
could see her
and i was amazed when she waved back
over three decades later
i had the distinct honor and privilege
of officially greeting
her late majesty the queen when she
visited crawley at the time i was leader
of west sussex county council and one of
her duties that day
was to
open a school that had been rebuilt
thomas bennett community college
with great nervousness and excitement
i met
harmonic and as she did with all of her
functions and occasions carried them out
in a way that put people at ease
and a way where our whole community
celebrated
but
her late majesty madame deputy speaker
visited my crawley constituency on five
previous
occasions in an official capacity
first in 1950 when she was then the
princess elizabeth
she came to my constituency to open what
is now one of the largest industrial
estates uh in the country
she named that industrial estate
apparently she had looked over the old
tithe maps
of where it was to be located
and called it manor royal
then in 1958 as then
our sovereign
she came back to my constituency to
officially open gatwick airport
the world's busiest single runway
airport
and a great driver of the local
economy
her next visit was in 1969 the year i
was born
when
she
came
to crawley
to um
to to
dedicate uh queen square
and where she came to
uh open the holy trinity school
officially a school which is uh soon to
be rebuilt as well her next visit was in
1982 to lay the foundation stone of
saint catherine's hospice and in 1988
again back to gatwick airport to open
the
north terminal
madam deputy speaker
we
all feel
that we have lost
somebody
that we have a personal connection to
even though
she was somebody who was
not only a mother to this united kingdom
but the commonwealth
and recognized and respected throughout
the world
that was typified
when on
september 11th
in 2001
she
spoke
about grief being the price we pay for
love
after the
attacks in the united states on
september the 11th
that is so true
i watched with great respect and
interest
his majesty's address
last night from buckingham palace
and i'm grateful
uh for the message that the service that
we had from the queen will be continued
uh in the reign of charles iii we are
fortunate in this country to have a
constitutional monarchy and long may
that continue
may god
rest the soul of her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
may god give wisdom
to
his majesty charles iii
god save the king
um i just do need to remind colleagues
that um
the speaker
his guidance was three minutes if
colleagues take six minutes then it
means that somebody else has much less
time i'm sure that would be born in mind
sarah aldi
thank you uh very much madam deputy
speaker for allowing me to make this
tribute on behalf of the people of
richmond park it was in our very
constituency that the first queen
elizabeth passed away in 1603 at
richmond palace and it is a great
privilege to speak on behalf of my
constituents at the conclusion of the
equally great and historic reign of the
second queen elizabeth
i wanted to offer a personal reflection
on the queen
when i heard the sad news of her death
on thursday my mind went back to april
2020. as everyone here will remember we
had just gone into an unprecedented
lockdown in response to a terrifying
pandemic
i was a newly elected mp
suddenly receiving hundreds of emails
from constituents with complex questions
and requests
and they were sharing stories of great
sacrifice and suffering
i didn't know how best to support them
as a parent
i was seeing my young children sat at
home staring out of the window
wondering when their lives would restart
i was beset with uncertainty about what
would happen next
and it felt almost overwhelming
and then the queen's message
that gentle but firm insistence that we
will meet again
it meant so much to me
that message that the road ahead might
not be visible but that we would get to
the other side
i think it resonated partly because as
so many people here have said the queen
was someone i'd always known and
respected so i intrinsically trusted her
it was also the knowledge that her great
age gave her the perspective that
however dark the current day better days
would come
but i think it was also
that she was our nation's link to the
past and all our previous ages
she reflected all the troubles and
triumphs of our nation's past that have
brought us to this point
her message at that point
was tremendously reassuring to me
and i know to thousands of others
and of course she was right
it was so wonderful to come together for
her platinum jubilee this summer we had
fantastic celebrations right across
richmond park
and it was a particular pleasure to join
the very joyful jubilee party at the
queen school in queue which is named
after her late majesty
there could not have been a better
opportunity for all of us to have a
national celebration than in honor of
the woman who has always united and
elevated us
i'm so glad that we had the opportunity
to celebrate her life while there was
still time
and i think as we whistled stamped sang
wang off waved our flags to say thank
you i think we knew in our private
hearts that we were also saying goodbye
so on behalf of the people of richmond
park i extend my condolences to the
royal family on their sad loss
may her majesty rest in peace and in the
hearts and memories of her grateful
nation and may god save the king
paul
how thank you madam deputy speaker
it's a privilege to rise today on behalf
of my search for constituents on an
occasion we never want it to occur
i'd like to begin by giving my
condolences to the queen's family for
whom this is a personal event as much as
it is one of state
and although no one can deny that living
to 96 constitutes a long life the demise
of the crown has still come as a shock
to us all
we're most deeply felt by her family
the queen's stood in absence reminds us
again what a steady presence she was for
the nation and the love they had for her
was so fully demonstrated through the
platinum jubilee celebrations
it didn't matter which one of my 40-yard
towns and villages i went to there was a
street party going on
hers was not the sort of presence one
necessarily thought about on a daily
basis but since most of us cannot
remember a time without it it just
seemed like a fact of life
her reliable consistency is all the more
impressive given this was not a role she
chose and she must have been such a
daunting prospect at the start
the values held and lived out by the
queen provide an example to everyone she
embodied virtues such as respect
endurance and restraint in as
comprehensive aware as we've ever seen
from anyone anywhere
nevertheless no one is eternal and we
know that as a christian she believed
there was something more to look forward
to
in trying to work out what to say today
i found inspiration from one of my own
constituents
yesterday a local resident of wingert in
my sedgefield constituency stephen
atkinson shared this poem he wrote in a
community group and he's kindly given me
permission to read it to the house
it's called our lily
our lily of the valley has shed her
petals free
to drift upon the winds of time in her
own sweet galilee
the mother of our nation so along its
beating heart
offers her earthly shelter rest for her
soul must now depart
so free it roams through gilded veil and
bunny locks and mowers past staggering
hair and freight and fragrant fare to
dusks mr yellers
where lies a smile she knows so well her
waiting strength and stare
together two souls reunite and dance the
night away
and here we are elizabethans it's all
we've ever been
for 70 70 years you've tried your best
to live up to being all clean
you'll always be our true foundation the
soil of our sceptidial a constant in our
thoughts and hearts great britain's
greatest smile
i hope you sit upon burmese with your
father by your side and in his long-lost
face you'll see only love and endless
pride on behalf of all my setfield
constituents i thank our amazing
queenslanders for our service wish king
charles iii the fortitude to deliver it
his mother did she is an amazing actor
follower but i have every confidence he
will deliver may she rest in peace and
god save the king
lily in greenwood
speaker it's with great sadness that i
stand to pay tribute to her late majesty
queen elizabeth
over the past 48 hours we've all
reflected on her unparalleled role in
our national life and have witnessed the
tremendous affection and admiration in
which she's held both at home and around
the world
yesterday evening we heard the words of
our new king as he paid tribute to a
dearly loved mother
on behalf of my constituents in
nottingham south i extend my deepest
sympathies to king charles and all the
royal family as they experience this
very personal loss
as so many colleagues have said having
reigned for a remarkable 70 years the
queen has been a constant throughout our
lives and the milestones of her reign
have left their mark in our own stories
i still have my silver jubilee envelope
but sadly not the coin that we received
in primary school
a photo of my youngest daughter as a
toddler dressed up in gold crown and red
velvet cloak for the golden jubilee
hangs on the wall at home and of course
i'll never forget meeting the queen on
her diamond jubilee visit to nottingham
having waved to the crowd from the
council house balcony she confided that
their cheers were even louder than
outside buckingham palace
the queen has provided that much-needed
point of stillness through some of the
most turbulent times in our country's
history offering leadership comfort and
hope in the darkest hours
but she's also been a vital part of
collective celebrations including in our
city of nottingham
her first official visit to nottingham
in 1949 was princess elizabeth was the
highlight of the city's quince centenary
celebrations
half the city will have joyous memories
of presenting the fa cup to nottingham
forest captain jack burkett at wembley
in 1959 but everyone will have cheered
when she came to congratulate ice
dancing gold medalist torvill and dean
following their triumph in the 1984
winter olympics
the queen witnessed huge change in our
city on a 1968 visit she toured the
immense rally factory in radford
31 years later she was back on the same
spot
bicycle production was all but over and
the triumph road site was being
transformed into the university of
nottingham's jubilee campus now
attracting students from around the
globe and researching cutting-edge
technologies for the new century
perhaps the city's most familiar
manifestation of her majesty is the
queen's medical center the biggest
purpose-built hospital in europe when it
was officially opened by the queen in
1977
it was also over budget controversial
and delayed features of infrastructure
projects i suspect weren't unfamiliar to
the queen then and certainly not later
madame deputy speaker the loss of our
queen has moved people around the world
on behalf of myself
the people of nottingham south and
nottingham's everywhere i say thank you
for a life of exceptional public service
of dignity kindness and good humor may
she rest in peace
long live the king
jackie doyle price
madam deputy speaker it gives me a it's
it's a great honor to speak on behalf of
uh the people of thorax to give my
tribute
to our much missed already at queen
elizabeth ii
it has been both moving and comforting
to listen to the tributes here at
westminster and also
on the media
this is an amazing nation and queen
elizabeth epitomized the best of it but
in terms of what we've heard in the
chamber over the last two days we've
been reminded
just how important uh her
the position that monarchy is in our
system of governments and how
intricately involved she was in all our
affairs of states
you know as she applied to herself to
that work with such dedication and those
weekly audiences with the prime minister
were not just a matter of formality they
were an important part of how we are
held to account how prime minister hale
took out on behalf of her subjects and
also of course
an opportunity to
access her very great wisdom and i've
much enjoyed hearing those accounts from
our from our former prime ministers uh
yesterday
now i had the fortune good fortune to
meet um the queen when she came to visit
parliament ten years ago
and uh not surprisingly as as many of
you know i i never tire of talking about
tilbury and uh and i'm afraid that queen
elizabeth will also have that to enjoy
it too but the one thing
that the one thing everyone knows about
tilbury is that queen elizabeth the
first made her famous speech there well
queen elizabeth ii also has an
association with tilbury uh in 1953
there was a massive tidal event in the
north sea which led to many thousands of
deaths in north europe and 300 deaths in
this country and tilbury town had to be
evacuated and
queen elizabeth visited tilbury
and it's again one of those occasions
that she did so well at times of
national tragedy she would coach she'd
show leadership she'd be giving comfort
and reassurance to those uh who had been
affected by these tragedies and that we
will miss and i know she's over the
years she's given thousands of thousands
of thousands of people at such comfort
and in that respect we have lost our
anchor we've lost that anchor that
steadied the ship in those rough seas
whenever anything was going bad as well
as the focus of great celebration
but we've already seen by the turn that
king charles has taken uh in his
addresses to the nation over the last 24
hours that that leadership is being
passed into safe hands
and we send our good wishes to king
charles
we send our respect and our admiration
as well as mourning the loss of our
much-loved queen elizabeth may she rest
in peace god save the king
mitchell thompson
thank you madam deputy speaker for the
opportunity to convey and to
share on behalf of my constituents and
gordon their
sadness at the passing of her late
majesty queen elizabeth and to express
there in my own gratitude for our
lifetime of service as our monarch and
head of state
it's been an incredible privilege to be
able to listen to
so many generous tributes both yesterday
in this place and today and so to hear
so many personal stories about how her
majesty's life and reign touched so many
people
many have already spoken in this place
and elsewhere of the
sense of permanence that her majesty
brought to us that
she wasn't ever present a constant
presence in her public life
and of the fact that for so many perhaps
we didn't realize the importance that
she played in that backdrop of our lives
and the presence that she had until that
presence was no longer there
it was a role which she carried out with
diligence with grace with the quorum
with a deep deep sense of duty and
obligation
for which we're all incredibly grateful
she was a
quite extraordinary person called to
serve us in
quite extraordinary times
in an on quite extraordinary role
uh serving as harmonic through a
tumultuous period of technological
social and political advance
she was a head of state of course of
many different countries and territories
and as the the winds of change blew
throughout the last century she saw many
of them achieving self-government in
their own right and saw many changes
internally within the uk with devolution
to scotland to wales and to northern
ireland but throughout
she demonstrated a sure-footedness a
steadiness and that she was a unifying
presence symbolizing all that whatever
change was happening around about her
symbolizing all the the remained in
common
as has been said she had a particular
affinity with scotland particularly with
aberdeenshire in the northeast of
scotland but especially her beloved home
mel moral castle it was
an area in scotland where she was
greatly loved and which she loved very
much in return
madam deputy speaker her majesty's loss
is one that is going to be felt deeply
with even those who might be ambivalent
themselves to the institution of
monarchy nevertheless
realizing the enormity of the passing of
someone who served in that role
so steadfastly and so diligently and
with such commitment to our people
as his majesty king charles has said we
mourn profoundly the passing of a
cherished sovereign and a much-loved
mother i know her loss will be deeply
felt throughout the country
the realms and the commonwealth and by
countless people around the world
in that he speaks for each of us may she
rest in peace and god save the king
craig
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
rise on behalf of my constituents uh of
the calder valley to thank her majesty
for her lifetime of service to us
her peoples and to her country the
commonwealth and territories
for all the very very many reasons that
have been mentioned here by caller
colleagues over the last two days
but i'm deputy speaker i won't repeat
them all again
but instead reflect on my own wonderful
experiences of meeting her majesty the
queen
now i'm what i would call
a true working class lad
we emigrated to australia when i was
five
i'm the son of a boilermaker and a
seamstress we were ten pound poms who
immigrated to the once great steel and
shipbuilding
towns and cities of australia
now my first experience of actually
seeing the queen in person in real life
i remember was back in the late 1970s
i was just age 15.
i know you're a guest that um
but watching in awe
at the royal yacht britannia bringing
her majesty the queen and prince philip
to meet the then australian prime
minister uh malcolm fraser
what a magnificent sight it was
and the amount of people that turned up
to greet them
and never once then did i ever in my
life imagine
that i would be her majesty's vice
chamberlain and having audiences with
her
at buckingham palace
on one to one
now just slightly and briefly back to my
working-class roots
now my mum when i left school was
horrified absolutely horrified that i
left school to work in an office
she often asked why i didn't get a
proper job like my dad and my brother
who also had a trade
such was the harshness of my background
although i will say i wouldn't change it
for anything
now this bad dream from my mum has gone
on my whole life
where even when i became an mp in this
place
endeavorment she would say to me so just
remind me what exactly is it you do
so a few years ago when my mum was in
the late 70s she came back here to the
uk from australia for a holiday at
around the same time as the state
opening of parliament
so not telling her a thing i brought her
here to london for a visit
i got a receipt in the house of lords
gallery overlooking uh the queen
straight in front of the queen
then for good measure
i gotta sat in the special seat over
there here on the floor of the house
courtesy of mr speaker's predecessor
now madam deputy speaker
no one
ever
has ever seen my mother speechless in
her life
but i can tell you she was and what i
can also tell you is that she has never
once
say to me so tell me
what is it you actually do
now that though was the power and the
respect of her majesty uh gained from
every generation of britons my good old
mum included
and i will take to my dying day
the ease the compassion
and the love
i felt for my queen our queen
as her vice champion
her interest and knowledge of the calder
valley or any subject we discussed was
flawless
may you rest in peace your majesty
you have more than deserved and earned
your peace
god save the queen and god save the king
stephanie peacock
madam deputy speaker it is an honor to
rise today to prove to pay tribute to
our late majesty queen elizabeth ii
the whole country the people of barnsley
and millions across the commonwealth and
around the world are all mourning the
loss of britain's longest reigning
monarch i express my sadness and i give
my condolences and those of the people
of barnsley east to our new king and to
our royal family
anyone who knows me knows i am a strong
supporter of our constitutional monarchy
i am a proud royalist but i have been
struck
by how both those who share my view and
those who hold the opposite one are
unified in admiration for our late
queen's service commitment and duty
across the country there is a profound
sense of loss
queen elizabeth ii was part of that
incredible generation of women the most
prominent of them my grandmother's
generation who lived served and survived
the second world war at a time when
attitudes to women were much different
she perfectly understood the role of
constitutional monarch of public service
and of duty she knew it was not her job
to solve the problems of the day that
falls to us in this place
but she often spoke to our nation at
times of peril of danger and of division
delivering a message of comfort and of
unity for me most notably in 2001 in the
wake of the horrific 9 11 terrorist
attacks
she said grief is the price we pay for
love we draw on that sentiment today at
a time of profound national sadness and
mourning
members across this house have rightly
spoken of how our queen elizabeth has
been a constant in our lives in an
ever-changing world in difficult times
and in happier ones in 1977 she had been
on the throne for a quarter of a century
when she visited barnsley as part of her
silver jubilee celebrations
our town was built on coal and when she
visited in 1954 she was given a
commemorative piece to mark the occasion
i know the people of barnsley celebrated
then as they mourn today
the late queen has a unique ability to
unite us all and today we are united in
our grief
as the poet laureate yorkshireman simon
armitage wrote in his collection
queenhood to mark the platinum jubilee
for generations we will not know such
majesty
as our elizabethan age closes those
words ring true
as we mourn her loss as we celebrate her
life as we thank her for her service we
say rest in peace and we say god save
the king yeah
nick fletcher
thank you madam mr speaker i'm deeply
saddened as i know the entire country
are in the passing of our queen
i never actually had the honor of
meeting her like most people i saw her
on tv and the occasional glimpse through
the car window
finally i thought i had my chance when i
became an mp and i could attend the
opening of parliament first to put a
prayer card in first to the chamber i
was sat in my place eagerly waiting for
proceedings to begin
only to realize as things took place
that first in the chamber means last out
there i was watching the front bench
file out while i was trapped behind
several annoying members of parliament
who wouldn't get out of the way
in fairness it's not because they
wouldn't it's because they couldn't and
they have probably made the same error
as me
sadly i never did get that glimpse
however something that i did get was a
memory that came flooding back from my
younger days a message that said here is
first will be last and here is last will
be first
like our queen i am a christian and so
while i have this moment i want to let
you know of a recent sermon i heard it's
very short
and the pastor spoke of being able to
tune a piano from another piano and
another piano and so on it can be done
many times but each time the next piano
becomes a little more out of tune than
the previous one
what should happen is that each piano
should be tuned to the same tuning fork
that way they will all be perfectly in
tune his analogy was that we should all
use christ as our tuning fork not the
world
that way each of us could try to live
like christ
i believe our queen through her faith
did just that and by doing so showed the
rest of the world what a life in christ
look like
a life of faith hope and most
importantly love
since i became an mp i have spoken much
of the importance of good role models i
cannot think of a finer example than our
lakeway
if we all seek to serve as our
acquaintance putting god duty and others
first
then this world we all share will be a
much better place for it
remembering always he who puts himself
first will be last but he who puts
himself last will be first
our queen always put herself last and
others first
i finish by thanking our queen on behalf
of all in don valley for her 70 years of
incredible service on behalf of my
constituents again i would like to pass
on my second sincere condolences to the
entire royal family god save the king
long may you reign
thank you madam deputy speaker
only three months ago the country was
celebrating the late queen's platinum
jubilee and we gathered in this place to
pay tribute to her majesty for her years
of dedicated service to our country and
the commonwealth
we could not have imagined that we would
be gathered here today to pay our
tribute tributes upon her death
but a mystery amidst the sadness it's
surely comforting to remember that in
what were to be her majesty's last days
and months she enjoyed a massive
outpouring of admiration affection and
gratitude witnessed at the many events
across the country to celebrate her 70
glorious years on the throne
we enjoyed many jubilee celebrations in
my constituency of north hindsight where
we have always given the queen and royal
family the warmest of welcomes whenever
they visit
the earliest visit i can recall was in
1967 when the queen came to open the
then newtown tunnel it was a school day
but one boy in my class lived near the
tunnel and was given half a day off to
join his family in the crowds welcoming
the queen
i was in all that and a bit envious i
must admit
little did i know that 45 years later
i would be welcoming the queen as a new
mp
joining the crowds including school
children when the queen made her last
visit to north hindsight to open time
tunnel 2.
madame deputy speaker myself my family
all my constituents have a great
fondness for the queen
during her reign she gave us so much
much hope much pride much inspiration
and much joy
on behalf of my constituents i send my
heartfelt condolences to the to king
charles and all the royal family as they
mourn this such a personal loss
may our gracious queen rest in peace and
may god save the king
angela richardson
yeah yeah thank you madam deputy speaker
i it's a privilege to speak on behalf of
my constituents and i will focus my
remarks on her majesty's role in marking
the milestones of guildford throughout
her reign
queen elizabeth first visited guilford
in 1957 with his royal highness the duke
of edinburgh to mark the 700th
anniversary of the town's charter
she was presented with a traditional
gift for royal visitors to guildford on
the balcony of the guildhall which was a
plum cake though i'm not sure whether
she partook of it given her fondness for
chocolate cake instead
the queen then visited the
half-completed guildford cathedral
signing with the duke two bricks to be
incorporated into the structure
there they remain along with many
thousands of others signed by
guilfordians she will be indelibly with
us in guildford for centuries to come
four years later in may 1961 her majesty
attended the consecration of the
cathedral it was the first new anglican
cathedral to be built in 500 years
in 2011 she returned with a duke to mark
50 years since that consecration
during the second world war her majesty
served in the auxiliary training service
in and around the surrey area and
retained her connection to the successor
women's royal army corps during her
reign
in 1964 she opened the wrac barracks in
guildford which i'm glad to say cast off
its nickname of the powder puff barracks
to become the queen elizabeth barracks
and today the community
of queen elizabeth park
her majesty returned 15 years later in
1979 to mark 60 years of the wrac
association and unveiled a plaque to
mark the occasion
in february 1981 she opened the royal
surrey county hospital and spent time
touring the new facilities speaking to
staff and patients she returned in 1997
with a duke to open the amazing st
luke's cancer center
her majesty was also a visitor to the
university of surrey she attended the
service of thanksgiving for the
university silver jubilee in 1992 and
opened the surrey space center in 1998.
in october 2015 the queen returned to
open the school of veterinary medicine
with the duke of edinburgh when as well
as touring the facility she spoke to
professor noel fitzpatrick about
prosthetic limb use for dogs
her majesty was a monarch who retained
an interest in the lives of her people
she returned to cathedral she
inaugurated hospital she opened
organizations of which she had been
apart and universities where the future
scientists artists and leaders of her
nation were being educated
madam deputy speaker it was that
interest and warmth that drew so much
affection from her people
her investment in this country and its
people was total and unwavering
it was the greater part of her and she
an irreplaceable part of us all
may she rest in peace may god save the
king
before i uh leave the chair mr speaker
has asked me to
remind members and staff that there is a
church service tomorrow at 6 pm
at st margaret's church for the
parliamentary community
to remember her late majesty the queen
those wishing to attend please contact
mr speaker's office
and
can i also say it it has been an honor
to hear so many
moving tributes to queen elizabeth ii
and i know i speak
for my constituents of doncaster central
when i say thank you to our late queen
for her
a lifetime of public service and she
rest in peace and long live the king
stephen ferry
thank you very much uh madam deputy
speaker it is a real honor uh to have
the opportunity to pay tribute to the
life and achievements of her mostly the
queen on behalf of the of the alliance
party and also my constituents in north
down
hers was a life of duty and service
she was a leader and a healer
indeed she was an exemplar as to what a
constitutional monarch should be
she was loved and respected not just
across the uk but around the world
and it was very interesting to note that
whenever the uk hosted music
international gatherings it was clear
that other heads of states
and other heads of government looked up
to the queen greatly
at times of tragedy she was our
comforter in chief
this was especially so responding to the
pain and suffering was experienced in
northern ireland and of course troubles
affected her so deeply personally as
well
in return she honored the service and
sacrifice of the royal ulster cassavary
through awarding them the george cross
and also recognized the role and service
of the royal irish regiment in terms of
providing them with a conspicuous
gallantry cross
the queen did so much to promote
reconciliation in ireland and to improve
anguirish relations
this was encapsulated in the reciprocal
visits made by her first of all to
ireland in 2011 and that very memorable
state dinner
and then the return state visit of the
irish president michael d higgins to the
uk in 2014
sadly that reception in windsor castle
was the last time i had the opportunity
to meet her
she paid some very memorable visits at
two north down in 1961 and 2009 and
there is an iconic image of her
in vanguard harbor on that 1961 visit
we were enormously grateful that bangor
was awarded city status as part of this
year's platinum jubilee civic honours
and indeed getting what has now happened
this was particularly poignant
i have confidence in the leadership of
the new king
indeed he has served the longest
apprenticeship in history
i particularly
particularly
appreciate what he has done for the
environment and also for young people
notably through the prince's trust
i wish him every success as he steps up
at this most difficult time may the
queen rest in peace and god save the
king
said okay give me a clue
give me a clue
jack breton
you ma'am deputy speakers so many people
here in the uk and in my city of socon
trent and across the commonwealth will
be feeling a great deal of loss and
sadness which is hard to express the
queen visited stoke on trent on a number
of occasions first in 1949 and people
across our city will be mourning her
loss our heartfelt condolences go out to
his majesty the king and the entire
royal family there are a few alive today
who can remember a time without her
majesty the queen and for many it will
be difficult to imagine a life without
her over 70 years of dutiful service a
constancy and strength to guide our
great nation and 14 other commonwealth
realms each of which she cared for very
deeply
over that time the world has changed
almost unrecognizably but she has always
been there to offer stability to us at
times of great change and reassurance in
times of crisis
even in these final few years of her
life despite declining health and the
loss of her dearly beloved phillip at
the age of 96 she continued to perform
her important duties as our head of
state just as her royal highness his
royal highness the duke of edinburgh was
his her majesty's strength and stay she
was our strengthened stay and this is
how she will be remembered
she was our longest reigning monarch and
probably our greatest if not one of the
greatest leaders the world has ever seen
one of her greatest abilities was to
remain above politics bridging divides
whether political or across communities
and generational divides along with
thousands of others who had the chance i
was lucky enough with my wife laura to
attend one of the queen's numerous
garden parties at buckingham palace a
few years ago a day which i will never
forget i'm sure will all those who had
this chance whilst many never had the
chance to meet the queen directly there
is still great feeling of loss and
sadness that she was and that she was a
significant part of our lives she was
loved by all of us
it was clear to see a great deal of
affection and respect shown to her
majesty through the huge outpouring of
support shown earlier this year with the
platinum
jubilee celebrations just as we now see
the massive expression of sympathy
around the world
we will now join in mourning her loss
and supporting our new king
i know from meeting him the king
previously on a number of occasions
following his following in his mother's
example he will do all he can to support
our great nation i know he has a great
deal of affection for my city in stoke
on trent
let us never forget our elizabeth the
great she is now at peace reunited with
her beloved phillip her achievements and
memory will live on god save the king
alex norris
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
speak in tribute to her majesty queen
elizabeth ii on behalf of my
constituents from the north of
nottingham we loved her dearly and a
united in grief today the values that
she exemplified duty love of country
commitment to your fellow person are
ones we strive to live by every day in
our part of the world
i have two short memories that i wish to
share on behalf of our community firstly
from the diamond jubilee in 2012 the
queen visited vernon park in basement in
my constituency i was the local
councillor then and as i left my home
and walked to that event it felt like
every door you passed somebody else
joined the throng walking down to the
park and as you got there we were this
massive humanity um just so thrilled to
be able to show off our community to the
queen to sing to dance to play sport as
well and virtually everybody in our
community has a story about that day and
that was the sort of connection that the
queen made with british people up and
down this country and the markers that
we have that commemorate that day we
will have forever
and that was echoed 10 years later on
the occasion of the platinum jubilee we
had over two dozen events across our
constituency all locally organized
spontaneous demonstrations of love of
queen and country and the desire to get
back together after so long apart and
that's what our queen did didn't she she
brought us together she united us so my
community is united in mourning today
but also united when we say god save the
king
right who wants to go next
mary robinson
thank you madam deputy speaker for
calling me to speak
it is with immense sadness that i rise
to pay tribute and give thanks for the
life of our late queen elizabeth on
behalf of myself my family and the
people of cheadle i'd like to send our
heartfelt condolences to king charles
and the entire family who remain in our
thoughts and prayers at this sad time
the queen has been hailed as a golden
thread which binds countries and people
together
and her reign has been the single thread
of continuity throughout my life and the
lives of many people across the world
who have known no other sovereign
i didn't get to meet her
but the wonderful personal and moving
tributes following the death of our
beloved queen allow us to glimpse the
human face behind the monarch
many stories relate their meetings and
audiences some privileged people were
allowed to attend others recount those
brilliant occasions where a visit would
lead to a chance encounter with a few
warm words and gestures forever
imprinted on memories to be retold to
children and grandchildren
for our parents and grandparents and
those who lived through or fought in the
second world war it was the photos of
the young princess in her ats uniform
which showed her steadfast spirit and
solidarity with them and were an example
of her desire to serve which later came
to exemplify her reign
indeed the appetite to see the queen not
just in the newspapers but live on
screen
set off a surge in sales of tvs with
millions of people gathering to watch
the coronation in 1953 on newly
purchased or rented grainy black and
white televisions
since then her life of public duty
and her personal family life too
has streamed directly into people's
front rooms
and that personal connection remained
throughout her decades of service
we may not have met her majesty
personally
but we knew her and welcomed her into
our hearts and into our homes
especially at christmas when our
families gathered together and we heard
her christmas message
always perceptive compassionate guiding
sharing her wisdom
and her love of god
as we have heard on her 21st birthday
she declared a whole life whether it be
long or short be devoted to our service
her majesty was happily blessed with a
long life and as a nation we have been
blessed by her service
we are feeling a profound sense of loss
as we mourn our queen
we will miss having her in our lives
but the golden thread of duty love and
service which knits our communities and
nations together will pass unbroken to
her heir
king charles iii
god bless her majesty may she rest in
peace
and god saved the king
ruth jones
deputy speaker and i'm very grateful to
have the opportunity to say a few words
today and it's a very real and genuine
honor for me to speak in this important
debate
um on behalf of the people of newport
west to pay tribute to the late queen is
elizabeth ii
and i want to echo the sentiments of
expressed by my honorable and right
honourable friends and colleagues from
across this house
um and i've been really inspired and and
enjoyed listening to their elegant witty
words and stories about the queen that
they've shared with us and i'm very
grateful to them for that
by any measure her late majesty was one
of a kind
she led she served she cared she
inspired she comforted and she
challenged
queen elizabeth will be irreplaced
irreplaceable and we were lucky to have
her
hers was a life well lived from
traveling to all parts of our world to
serving as our longest head of state she
made history and she was our present for
so long
madam deputy speaker it doesn't matter
if you're a royalist or a republican we
can all recognize the queen's dedication
integrity compassion and sense of humor
and to acknowledge the lifetime of
extraordinary service to our country
of commitment to the people of wales the
united kingdom and the commonwealth and
her calm strong and stable leadership
i've heard many stories about the visits
the queen paid to our area in south
wales indeed to my own constituency like
a visit to someone's cathedral in stowe
hill in newport west
and i think of the visits to the
official openings of the assembly of
wales and now the senate when the former
assembly member for newport west and
presiding officer dame rosemary butler
welcomed the queen and the duke of
edinburgh to cardiff bay the home of the
welsh national parliament
today i want to give voice to many
people who live learn and work in
newport west who will mourn her
majesty's passing and who through me as
their member of parliament extend their
condolences to the king and the royal
family
in particular i want to mention a
message i received from mubarak ali on
behalf of the islamic society for wales
he said at this sad time we all share
our grief and tears with the members of
the royal family
queen elizabeth will be greatly missed
rest in peace in heaven your majesty
thank you for your love and dedication
for our country and the world
in 1944 the then princess elizabeth made
her first visit to newport my 87 year
old mum and others of her age remember
that visit and the boost it provided
during those difficult war years in 2002
to celebrate the queen's golden jubilee
newport was granted city status a moment
of immense pride for our city and again
her majesty was there to celebrate with
us and i must admit i was very proud my
four-year-old daughter elena was able to
be one of the first to give her majesty
a posie of flowers as she arrived in the
city center hashtag proud mum
we politicians come and go but her
majesty endured and was a constant for
all of us
as we move into a new world with a new
monarch and a gaping hole in our
national life we give thanks for the
life of queen elizabeth ii
we mourn her loss and we send our
prayers condolences and love to the
royal family the country the
commonwealth and the world she's left
behind
may she rest in peace
fiona bruce
speaker
it's a privilege to pay tribute to the
life of dutiful service of queen
elizabeth ii
on behalf of my congleton constituents
how did the holder of such high office
and in the face of
rightful adulation of millions across
the world sustained for over seven
decades a life of such dedicated and
selfless service to others
may i suggest it was because she
recognized in a very real and personal
way
that there is a higher authority even
than her own
an authority by whom she had been called
to her role
and to whom ultimately she was
accountable
in her own words she said
to many of us our beliefs are of
fundamental importance
for me the teachings of christ and my
own personal accountability before god
provide a framework in which i try to
lead my life
her example of servant leadership is
unparalleled in our time
in many of her christmas broadcasts she
spoke publicly clearly and boldly of her
christian faith and is loved and
respected for it by many
christmas broadcasts are the one
occasion when a monarch can write their
own speech and convey their innermost
thoughts and she spoke of the importance
of family and of small acts of kindness
and in 2011 she said
god sent into the world a unique person
neither a philosopher nor a general
important though they are
but a savior with the power to forgive
forgiveness lies at the heart of the
christian faith it can heal broken
families it can restore friendships it
can reconcile divided communities
and whilst having a deep enduring
christian faith herself she was also
mindful of the importance of freedom of
religion or belief for all
indeed she was ahead of many when she
spoke of this in 2000 speaking of the
good samaritan saying
the man who is robbed and left at the
roadside is saved by someone who did not
share his religion or culture
this wonderful story of kindness is
still as relevant today
good samaritans have emerged across
society showing care and respect for all
regardless of gender race or background
reminding us that each one of us is
special and equal in the eyes of god
and then to the church of england at
lambeth palace in 2012 she said the
church has a duty to protect the free
practice of all faiths in this country
an environment for other faiths and
communities and indeed people of no
faith to live freely
and in 2014 she spoke of how we need to
respect freedom of religion or belief
for all faiths
a view which is shared by her son
and successor king charles iii
may she rest in peace and god save the
king
jim shannon thank you madam deputy
speaker um can i say one-on-one sorry
clear that just because the honorable
gentleman is on his feet it doesn't mean
we've come to the end
[Applause]
this is
this is unusual i
i wouldn't like the chamber to empty
unnecessarily
jim shannon
[Applause]
i could tell but they they gasped from
around the chamber people said it's all
over
but thank you no that's not i'm very
pleased to have the honor of speaking on
record my thanks to god above for the
life and rein of queen elizabeth ii on
behalf of my constituency of strength
and also of my own family
i will remember my mum and dad going to
the garden party 2012. uh they were
pleased to be there they're real
loyalists uh and they they were able to
engage and enjoy the occasion with the
queen and prince philip also we they
they got their 60th wedding anniversary
card again they they carved especially
for them which of course it is uh but it
also
exalts the occasion so
i'm very pleased to be able to say we've
got a couple of uh
things we can
apply to and respond to as a family
the page before me lay blank for a long
time which may be shocking to many of
you who know that i'm never short of a
speech or perhaps even two speeches
but the truth is i don't i didn't know
what to say of my and our own parallel
queen how to express the depth of sorrow
and loss we feel hard to convey my
thanks to almighty god for giving me the
privilege of serving my queen or our
queen in uniform and in this house and
for my constituents the security of
living under the greatest reign in
history i spoke at the jubilee of my
admiration for this godly example of
service loyalty faithfulness with humor
and grace and even then i was emotional
at the fear of the day that we never
wanted to come
that day came and wasn't the death of
sorrow and lost far away what i thought
possible and yet weather has also come a
piece a piece because i know that our
queen this lady who gave and excelled up
until a matter of hours before her death
as now with her savior that she loved in
heaven the queen gave her royal seal to
only one book um about herself in her
whole life the servant queen and the
king she serves and this i believe says
all to me she was a woman of history
royal blood impeccable birth she never
bowed the needy any power on this earth
and yet she willingly abide to jesus uh
and and served him faithfully
and in in giving jesus her heart she was
able to dedicate to us her all the
ultimate example of the best of british
the best of the greatest generation the
best of us all in this house and this
one and across this country super
therapy for her name elizabeth alexandra
mary means and i call it
god is my oath a helper and defender of
mankind and beloved queen elizabeth
radiated her oath of service made to her
god that she loves she has helped and
defended this union commonwealth and her
faith and she was certainly most beloved
the inspiration of so many fought in her
name who gave up their lives in defense
of her and all she stood for queen and
country was an easy youth to make and
one eye health beer as have my
constituents annoying deference to her
to the queen and in the hope for the the
foundation that she has laid and heard
from me with my whole heart i say long
live king charles iii indeed god save
the king
craig tracy
thank you madam deputy speaker and
it's with great sadness and also some
pride that i rise today to pay a tribute
to the late queen elizabeth ii on behalf
of myself my family and my constituents
across north warwickshire and bedworth
and also send out condolences to the
royal family
thursday was a deer we always knew at
the back of our minds was inevitable
most wished it wouldn't arrive
but i think few of us actually
considered the impact it would have on
us all when it did actually come
and i'm sure i wasn't alone to wake up
on friday morning with the most profound
sense of grief that i really couldn't
rationalize
like many people i hadn't actually met
the late queen but i still felt like i
knew her
she'd been part of our daily lives
forever not just here in parliament but
her image was seemingly everywhere
she was in our wallets on our letters in
our shops and on our walls
we shared our troubled times with her
and we shared our successes
we even shared our christmas day
together
she loved our country and it loved her
and that was never more evident than
recently at the jubilee celebrations
across our constituencies
and although
queen elizabeth ii was of royal blood
she also had an amazing ability to
connect with people and we felt that she
was one of us but i think what is most
incredible is that unlike us here in
this place she did not ask for her role
to be our head of state but it was
rather imposed on her which makes it
even more incredible that she kept the
promise that she made as a 21 year old
princess right up until the very end of
the days that she would devote her life
to service
and for that we should be internally
grateful
no other person has had such a profound
impact on so many lives over such a long
period of time
the word icon is often bandied around to
describe various people but never has it
been more appropriate than for our queen
elizabeth she defined our nation and
represented it unfailingly for 70 years
it now seems very strange to be
contemplating the future without her
late majesty in it
in an uncertain and dynamic world she
was a reassuring constant
and her death is not just a tragedy for
the royal family but a dreadful loss for
us all
but we should remember it was a life
lived with true purpose and on behalf of
my constituents and myself i would like
to say thank you your majesty for your
dedication and service to our country
may you now rest in peace and god save
the king
[Music]
matt weston
thank you madam deputy speaker yesterday
morning i bumped into helen a
constituent she was visibly upset it was
an ungodly hour according to seven and
she was walking in early for work at a
local butcher shop in the heart of royal
lemington spa a shop so well regarded
that it holds a warrant to supply the
royal household
she told me how she dreaded the coming
of this day like so many of us she was
shocked by the news
an hour later as i stood in the queue
for a train ticket the guy in front of
me and jeans and a tall and black
leather jacket confided he was going to
buckingham palace because he needed to
be there
two simple vignettes replayed i'm sure
up and down our country
for a person of such slight figure the
queen seemed to stand above presidents
prime ministers and other heads of state
it wasn't simply her longevity or her
manner invariably there was a genuine
respect for her for her experience and
her wise counsel
her virtues were many dedication
diligence
integrity respect loyalty humility
compassion and constancy
for at times of turmoil she provided
calm
at times of national self-doubt
she reassured us
throughout her reign and even before in
wartime after various bombings the
aberfan disaster and then during the
pandemic when she proposed hope and that
we would meet again
her state visit to ireland in 2011 the
first visit there by any british monarch
for a hundred years where she made one
of her most significant speeches
but also she celebrated with us in
moments of national joy the e day
imagine the liberation she felt being
able to be out on the streets with the
people
and then of course that magic moment
presenting bobby moore with the jewels
roommate trophy
and dropping by to the olympics in 2012
she was madam deputy speaker the woman
for all seasons
warrick and livington was blessed by
her visits
on three occasions firstly in 1988 to
commemorate the 150th anniversary of
queen victoria's granting of the royal
warrant to levington then in 1996 when
she visited the lord leicester hospital
in warwick castle and finally in 2011 to
open the royal justice center i'm not
sure if she had time to drop by the
butchers but hopefully uh
king charles iii will make time in the
coming years
madame deputy speaker on behalf of the
good people of warwick lemington with
national villages i pay tribute and
offer our thanks
for the life of her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii for her dignity and
commitment to our service and may i
express our sincere condolences to his
majesty king charles of the and all the
family
her late majesty the queen was not given
to sentimentality she would have wanted
us to look forwards and perhaps she
would have put it this way
the firm has a new boss
may our late queen rest in peace god
save the king
conor burns
thank you madame speaker
place on record our gratitude to the
speaker for allowing ministers to
participate in this debate from the back
benches today what is really striking
about listening to the many
contributions today and yesterday is how
many of our constituencies had visits
multiple visits by her majesty the queen
over her seven decades of service i was
in my own constituency at bournemouth
west yesterday and talking to some local
people who remember her last visit uh to
bournemouth a to peer approach
she had views about all our
constituencies
so did her late husband
i
was introduced to the duke of edinburgh
in 2013 at a reception of buckingham
palace
and he looked at me and said
where are you from
i said almost sir bournemouth full of
old people
i said yes sir many of them are good
deal younger than you
for a split second i thought i made a
serious mistake
um but he burst out laughing and called
the queen over to tell her what i had
said and she looked and said well philip
that isn't hard is it
madam deputy speaker our late queen
embodied our values as a nation when you
go abroad people
recognize the english language our legal
system our arts and our culture but
because of her
long long reign they identify the united
kingdom today very much with the person
of the late queen
and i was constantly struck
by her reach in may of this year i
attended in washington at the rupaul's
drag race british invasion tour
brilliant concert
where i met
a young person called joss josh cargill
now josh is more commonly known by his
stage name of blue hydrangea
and he is one of northern ireland's
preeminent drag queens
my conversation with josh took a novel
turn
as he told me of his own connection with
her majesty the queen when she opened
his primary school downshirt primary in
royal hillsborough when he was a pupil
there madam deputy speaker it was to
downshift primary school that i went in
may to launch the northern ireland
office platinum jubilee rug competition
where we asked the young people of
northern ireland to design a rug on the
theme a postcard from northern ireland
to present to the royal household as a
token of the appreciation of the young
people for the queen's
service
madam deputy speaker as a an enduring
sign of the queen's role as someone who
was at the forefront of reconciliation
the famous visit to ireland in 2011 and
the many conciliatory gestures she made
in northern ireland to aid peace and
reconciliation that project was
supported by over 2 000 entries from
primary schools of every type catholic
protestant and integrated from every one
of northern ireland's six counties and
madam deputy speaker it was one of my
great
delights that we were able to finish
that project and have that rug made up
by the young lady emily who who won the
competition by that great royal warrant
holding exporting company ulster carpets
in northern ireland madam deputy speaker
the queen
was one of us that is why she was held
in such deep and enduring affection over
those four days of that magnificent
jubilee weekend we were able to show her
majesty how deeply we cared for her and
how grateful we were for her long
service our new prince of wales has
reminded of his of his grandmother's
words grief is the price we pay for love
madam deputy speaker i think our country
can be very proud of those four days
because through those four days there is
no doubt that her majesty the queen died
securing the knowledge of our love and
affection as we look back
that was the moment we brought the queen
close to us for one last time and in a
very real sense also let her go
madam deputy speaker
may our
wonderful
servant and sovereign
rest in peace
and may god save the king
matt rodden
thank you madam deputy speaker it is an
honor to be able to speak in today's
debate and to pay tribute to her late
majesty queen elizabeth ii on behalf
both of myself and my constituents in
reading east
queen elizabeth was our longest serving
and arguably our greatest ever monarch
she was deeply loved and admired and we
all feel a deep and profound
sense of personal sadness and great loss
at this difficult time
like many of us i'm still trying to take
in the events of the last few days
we all knew this day would come but part
of us somehow felt that the queen would
always be there because she'd always
been there throughout our whole lives
she was truly a constant for all of us
in what was a rapidly changing world
her reign
covered a period of unprecedented social
and technological change and yet at the
same time she also linked the modern
world to the wartime generation
madam deputy speaker her life was
defined by service as a young woman
during the war she made a solemn vow to
serve her people as long as she lived
and she kept this promise over more than
70 years as our queen during a lifetime
dedicated to our country and the
commonwealth
she led by example in good times and in
bad through her kindness humility quiet
determination and with her dry sense of
humor
her majesty was both our head of state
and the head of the commonwealth but at
the same time we also felt a deep
personal connection to her one which is
actually very difficult to put into
words
she was a mother a grandmother and a
great grandmother and we sometimes felt
that she was like a grandmother to all
of us in this country and in the
commonwealth
locally there is a deep and abiding love
and respect for the late queen across
our community
she visited a number of times during her
long reign including opening the new
reading station in 2014.
i can vividly remember madam deputy
speaker the sheer joy and enthusiasm of
children families and older people at a
local platinum jubilee street party
which i attended
people of all backgrounds all faiths and
none celebrating their queen
it was a more than fitting tribute to
her late majesty and to the elizabethan
age may the queen rest in peace
god save the king
dr matthew offered
thank you madam deputy speaker
it really is an honor to speak on behalf
of my constituents in hendon and uh the
queen was no stranger to the
constituency of hendon and in fact she
visited on over 12 occasions
in 1945
on three dakota aircraft bearing their
majesties the queen the king and
princess elizabeth and a press entourage
left raf hendon for the first royal
visit bayer to northern ireland
this was followed by a visit by a
pregnant uh her majesty as she visited
the draper's cottages in mill hill she
subsequently planted a cedar tree to
commemorate the 150th anniversary of the
foundation of meal hill school
she formally opened the raf museum in
hendon
she opened the pill center at hendon
police college
she performed a royal review at the
hendon police college as part of her
majesty's silver jubilee
in 1982 as colonel in chief of the royal
engineers she spent the day english
barracks visiting the home postal depot
royal engineers and unveiled a
commemorative statue called letter from
home to mark the centenary of the bfpo
in 1985 she visited the central public
health laboratory in collindale
in 2001 she laid a wreath to inaugurate
the metropolitan police memorial in the
grounds of the metropolitan police
training establishment in collindale
and the golden jubilee and north
cornwall celebration was held at coptil
stadium and i was pleased to be one of
those newly elected councillors who was
able to be there to meet the queen in
person
in 2005 she visited the emergency call
center hendon police college after the
tsunami disaster
and in 2012 and her final visit the
procession of her majesty and his royal
highness the duke of edinburgh came
through edgware on the her majesty's
north london diamond jubilee procession
but within my constituency the regard in
which
the
uh her majesty is held by ethnic
minorities and religious communities are
second to none
as we've already heard today the people
of hendon hold the queen in high regard
and it still impresses me that at the
end of every sabbath service without
exception my constituents in synagogue
say a prayer for the queen and the royal
family
they've been saying this prayer since
1952 when her majesty ascended to the
throne but there's been more than a
dozen versions to reflect the changes in
marriages and indeed deaths but the one
constant in the prayer throughout the
last 70 years has been our sovereign
lady queen elizabeth
i've often said that none of us are very
important in politics and it is my
belief that there is only one person who
is important in politics and that is the
monarch
as we've seen in the last two days prime
ministers and members of parliament come
and go
but the monarch remains
each and every one of us have made
particular sacrifices to be here in this
place but the queen has made an even
greater sacrifice for over 70 years
that commitment to public service must
be unimaginable to each and every one of
us in conclusion a friend left a message
on a facebook page that really summed up
what i would say to the queen right now
if i had the opportunity
that would be
good night
god bless
and thank you for everything
long live the king
jessica morden thank you very much madam
deputy speaker and like
that so many honorable members have
waited patiently over the last two days
to pay our tributes in the chamber on
the passing of her majesty the queen is
indeed testament to the real depth of
feeling the sorrow and of the love that
we all want to convey on behalf of our
constituents and ourselves at this
moments of huge loss so on behalf of all
of our communities in newport east can i
also honor the memory
and
put on record our deepest condolences to
an extraordinary monarch who faithfully
served our country all her long life and
who's just always been there in
challenging and ever-changing times and
to send our love to her family as they
grieve
as princess elizabeth her majesty's
first official visit outside of london
was to newport where at the time
hundreds of men and women were working
at the royal ordnance factory on
corporation road producing munitions for
the invasion of occupied europe it's
fair to say that this generation
felt a special kinship with the queen
not least because of her dedication to
support the war effort herself as a
serving member of the auxiliary
territorial service that service
initiated a lifelong bond with our armed
pharmacist community which as other
members have said is clearly something
she took great personal pride in
throughout her life and was much
appreciated in newport east as queen she
opened landmarks which still produces
world-class deal today she returned to
officially open the severn bridge and
granted newport city status all
transformative for our part of south
east wales and the queen was at the
heart of it but a constituent in an
email summed up for many the loss of our
queen feels personal for our family a
sentiment echoed by many constituents
for the morsi's who sadly passed on
recently for whom meeting the queen at a
garden party was one of the highlights
of their lives for the constituent who
shared a photo of their daughter heather
presenting a bouquet to the queen for
maisie who was presented to her at the
opening of the senate and who felt as
she put it in her words her astounding
presence and warmth but whether you
would matter or not mattered little she
was a constant presence in an envelope
of 70 years of monumental change love
and loss in the lives of millions
in the prayers in this chamber which
begin each day we focus on service above
self something that's easier to say than
to do
the queen's seven decades of public
service exemplified that commitment it
was a service not the grandeur of her
status not the ceremony that surrounded
her but her embodiment of the values the
integrity the history and the standards
we all seek to live by and to have at
the heart of british life
she demonstrated those values every day
yet at the same time she was seen not as
someone remote and distant but personal
and human while still unique her last
service madam deputy speaker has been to
unite the country in mourning her loss
and our task now is to integrate her
unifying legacy of service and integrity
into all we do
rest in peace and god's hope the king
nikki aiken
thank you madam nephew speaker i am
grateful to have the opportunity to
place on record on behalf of my
constituency the huge appreciation that
we all share for the life and service of
her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
i also place on record my condolences to
his majesty the king and to all the
royal family about which much has been
already said in this place i feel
humbled to stand here today as member of
parliament for the cities of london and
westminster to represent a constituency
with such rich links to her majesties
reign starting with her birth in brewton
street in mayfair to her funeral which
will be held in westminster abbey
the two cities was the vessel for which
she ruled advised and steered our nation
indeed than two cities is home to so
many of the physical monuments of her
reign
of course buckingham palace which as
we've seen in the past two days has
become the epicenter of the nation's
grief
the mao the nation's stage for the pomp
and ceremony that binds us to our past
and to our future
it has seen coronation processions daily
roots of the queen's guard to the
celebrations we saw back in the summer
with the queen's platinum jubilee
st james's palace and clarence house
where the queen spent much of her youth
and raised her young family before she
took the throne in 1952
and of course westminster abbey and st
paul's cathedral
the former of which is so pivotal to her
life from her marriage to her coronation
and now sadly to her funeral
and later st paul's cathedral has also
played an integral role in making her
extraordinary reign especially the
services celebrating her silver gold
diamond and only a few months ago her
platinum jubilee which i was honored to
attend and of course last night the
cathedral led the first in many
thanksgiving services to our late
sovereign
when thinking about my own
thoughts about the queen i think of her
role as the head of state
for me one of her everlasting legacies
will be how she brought together the
commonwealth nations
growing their union from eight countries
to 56 collective nations walked together
under her stewardship
i often think how unappreciated her
majesty skills and diplomacy were
just think about our world how our world
looked
like at the beginning of her reign
and what it is now
and by sheer force of her character she
healed a deeply fractured world
post-empire
she fostered a family of nations that
bore no resemblance to the empire of the
past
and was instead built on the values of
friendship freedom and peace
and looking at the two cities i see the
epitome of the commonwealth legacy in
both people and values and we have the
late queen to thank for that
like everyone else when we heard the
news the late queen's passing it all hit
us personally because she had been such
a constant throughout our lives and we
have all shared in the celebrations of
her life
one of my first memories of the queen
was the silver jubilee in 1977 and as a
brownie receiving the 25 p silver coin
and i recall the excitement of being
receiving that gift
and then moving to the golden jubilee
when my own daughter georgia then aged
eight was invited to present her majesty
with the bouquet of flowers when she
visited fortnight masons in piccadilly
on her first stop on her diamond jubilee
tour
for me the queen had a unique ability to
tap into the hearts of every single
person and i think a lot of that was
because of her characteristic sense of
humor and sense of fun which cut through
people of all ages and all backgrounds
in fact i remember sitting on the sofa
with my son harry watching the opening
of the olympics in 2012 and the joy on
his face of seeing the queen jump out of
a helicopter with james bond and he
still i think believes it happened to
this day
i felt a similar feeling for the new
generation of children as we saw her
share tea with paddington bear this
summer and it is comforting to me that
she placed such a premium on our future
generations especially now as we look to
the next generation of the crown in king
charles iii indeed i was moved to see
the new king and the queen consult walk
into buckingham palace as monik and
queen for the first time
and madame deputy speaker as a new
chapter in our history begins the two
cities now prepare for another landmark
in the crown's passage through history
the funeral of elizabeth the great and
the coronation of king charles iii in
westminster abbey
for that i say
god bless the queen and long live the
king yeah
john nicholson
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker
madam deputy speaker i keep thinking of
that final photo of the queen
taken only this week as she welcomed the
prime minister to belmoral
it's the most poignant of images
she's standing by an open fire with a
familiar no-nonsense hairdo and she's
wearing a comfortable kilt
but a closer examination of the familiar
figure reveals that she's struggling
struggling to lift her head her right
hand looks badly bruised and she's
leaning heavily on a stick
i suspected she must have been feeling
tired and sore
but she's wearing makeup and smiling a
warm welcome
how brave that was
how beautiful
we look at the photo with affection and
respect because it's queen elizabeth but
also i think because for so many of us
her bravery so close to the moment of
her passing will remind us of all those
that we have loved and lost
all the mothers and the grandmothers we
have known and admired for their quiet
anonymous courage
few of us knew the queen personally but
we all felt somehow that we did and as
the tributes pour in there are recurring
themes she was a woman of great
religious faith who did not fear death
she was capable of many quiet acts of
sensitivity and compassion away from the
public eye she could be very funny with
a dry wit and a mischievous talent from
mimicry and she didn't like folk who
were pompous or overly grand despite i
suspect too often finding herself
surrounded by them
she loved scotland the most of any
country and was at her happiest driving
around in the lashing reign of balmoral
gently torturing urban westminster
politicians who arrived with city
clothes and sometimes starch
personalities
and while no one imagined that she was a
political radical those who talked to
her privately report that she'd moved to
the times whether on climate change
gender equality lgbt rights and a recent
decision to stop wearing fur
and though she was possibly
probably not a passionate scottish
independent supporter
[Laughter]
she she seems to have enjoyed warm
relations with recent first ministers
who appear to have been as charmed by
her as the most ardent unionist she
loved apparently being called elizabeth
queen of scots
perhaps recognizing that the title of
elizabeth ii all those decades ago was
not the most inclusive advice given to
her
she was amongst the last of the wartime
generation this gave her a special bond
with politicians who'd served heath and
healy callahan and jenkins they were a
generation who saw the devastation war
caused in our continent and were
committed to building a new more united
europe
my much loved mom who died recently was
the queen's age and a passionate
supporter of european integration
because she'd known the horror of war
and celebrated the peace our generation
perhaps appreciate too little
one of the most moving tributes to the
queen this week as we all know has come
from the french president
we will miss her madame deputy speaker
and will together celebrate her life
over the coming days
and weeks may she rest in peace
madam deputy speaker and i rise on
behalf of the people of shrewsbury and
surrounding shropshire villages to pay
tribute to her majesty
when i
met her majesty at buckingham palace
she looked at me
and
immediately started to tease me
ridden me mercilessly about the
difference in height
is she being five foot two and me being
six foot nine
and of course that immediately broke the
ice i was so nervous at meeting my
sovereign for the first time and that
joke at the start of our interaction
was so good to have
later on in the evening she was standing
at the other end of the room and i was
at the other at the other end and in
front of everybody she just went like
this
to demonstrate and to continue teasing
me that she was recognizing the
difference in height
but the most important thing that
happened that evening is that she
realized i was the only
polish-born british member of parliament
and she started to talk to me about her
pride of the contribution of polish
fighter pilots during the second world
war
she referenced the fact that the polish
303 squadron shot down more enemy
aircraft in the battle of britain than
any other squadron and she paid tribute
to the extraordinary contribution of
polish mathematicians and cryptographers
helping to break the enigma codes at
bletchley
and for joining the british eighth army
in north africa and at monte cassino
of course my heart
melt
of course being the only polish-born
british member of parliament and
listening to our sovereign outlining her
pride and talking about how her father
had outlined his pride to her about the
polish contribution
was something i will always remember
she reigned so successfully
because she used emotional intelligence
and emotional intelligence was her
driving force
the communist regime in the country of
my birth has been consigned to the ash
heap of history
because it ruled through fear
through intimidation
through the secret police it is gone
whereas her majesty's memory is eternal
because of the love and kindness she
showed us all thank you
helen hayes
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise
today to pay my tribute to her late
majesty queen elizabeth ii on behalf of
my constituents in dullich in west
norwood my sincere condolences go to his
majesty the king the royal family and
all who grieve her loss her late majesty
made a commitment at the age of 21 that
she would dedicate her whole life to the
service of the british people and the
fulfillment of that promise over more
than seven decades is truly
extraordinary
unlike other honourable and right
honorable members i did not have the
privilege of meeting the late queen
personally but i know that she
maintained as she did with communities
across the country a very strong
relationship with our part of south
london
most notably with king's college
hospital
the late queen visited king's college
hospital three times during her reign
first as part of her coronation tour in
1953 just five years after the founding
of the nhs
she visited again in 1968 to open the
ruskin wing of the hospital and once
more in 2003 to open the golden jubilee
wing at the time a much needed
improvement in facilities at king's
the late queen also visited brixton as
part of her silver jubilee celebrations
in 1977
and a lovely photograph held by lumberth
archives shows brixton's diverse
community coming out to welcome her and
the queen smiling and clearly making eye
contact with a child in the front row of
the crowd
most recently in 2013 the late queen
visited a small but hugely important
charity in brixton in my constituency
ebony horse club
ebony horse club is a riding centre
situated in an area which has a high
level of deprivation
it is brilliant enabling children from
all backgrounds to learn to ride a
relatively rare experience in any inner
city setting
and to benefit from being around animals
and learning equestrian skills
the late queen's love of horses is well
documented and i know that it was very
special to ebony horse club to have her
support for their work in making the
experiences that delighted her so much
being around horses caring for them and
riding them available to everyone
irrespective of income or background
this is a connection that continues
today because the queen consort is the
patron of ebony horse club and recently
hosted not only the staff and the riders
but also a number of horses at a
reception at clarence house
our country has seen huge changes and
great challenges during the 70 years of
the late queen's reign
it is testament to her character her
humanity
and her willingness to reflect and adapt
that she has been able to be a constant
throughout such a long period and
through so many changes
especially
in her relationship with the
commonwealth
her late majesty's lifetime of service
will be remembered with gratitude may
she rest in peace
gareth johnson
mandela speaker i'm particularly
grateful to be able to contribute in
this debate despite being the whip on
duty at the moment
and
as you know madam deputy speaker we make
comments about the contributions that
every member makes in this debate and so
i'm looking forward to writing
mike
i'm also
very pleased to be able to contribute
this debate because i want to con to
convey the gratitude i know that my
darfur constituents have
for the service given by her majesty
at dalford is heartbroken madame deputy
speaker we all are
we all dreaded this day coming
almost believing that it would never
happen
but here we are
it seems so odd to be without
the queen being around it
we've all grown up with her majesty i
the honourable member for the cities of
westminster and london
made comment about the silver jubilee
crown that she was given that exactly
happened to me when i was a young boy i
was given this crown
um on that day which was absolutely huge
and i thought i was rich beyond my
wildest dreams that i had this huge coin
in my hand
and then i confessed to being
disappointed sometime later by when i
found out it was only worth 25 pence
but nevertheless it is actually
priceless because the queen gave
everything for us
her whole life was committed to us
and our welfare
she was the perfect monarch who loved
her people
and she was in turn
loved by the people
nobody in this chamber
has or will ever have
approval ratings
like she had
nobody
and so
although much will change
we will never for example sing god save
the queen ever more in our lifetimes
but we are so incredibly fortunate madam
deputy speaker
that we have a king
with a huge sense of duty who genuinely
cares who genuinely cares about his
people and genuinely cares about his
country
he is
just as much at home walking around some
welsh farm
as he is walking around the london
council estate
and whilst we are
deeply deeply saddened
we can be optimistic
about the future
thanks to the legacy
that her majesty the queen
left to us
god save the king
[Applause]
simon lightwood
thank you madam deputy speaker it is has
been an honor and a privilege to listen
to the tributes and anecdotes from
members on all sides of the house
i would like to pay tribute both
personally and on behalf of the people
of wakefield constituency for the
service of our remarkable queen
her devotion and sacrifice to this
nation over her 96 years as an
inspiration and guiding light to us all
however long we've been in public life
it is with immense sorrow but with a
deep personal pride that i will have
been one of the last members of
parliament to have taken an oath of
allegiance to a late majesty the queen
when taking my seat in june
the queen visited wakefield several
times
i believe the first time was as princess
elizabeth in 1945
when she visited pinderfield's hospital
she returned as queen on a silver
jubilee tour in 1977
and again in 1992 to officially open
wakefield hospice
her efforts to extend the hand of the
monarchy to all her subjects across the
united kingdom led to the decision to
take the traditional monday service out
of london choosing a different part of
the country each year
so it was in 2005
that the queen and duke of edinburgh
visited wakefield cathedral to
distribute the monday money with people
from all over the district lining the
streets desperate to see a glimpse of
her
i was fortunate enough to be there
myself and remember her shining through
the crowds in her inemitable style
wearing brilliant blue
but it was a unforgettable smile
and a characteristic twinkle in her eyes
that we will remember most
she was so loved by so many in wakefield
and our nation for her warmth her
dedication and her unshakeable sense of
duty
over a 70 years in the throne she
reigned over huge social cultural and
political change across the united
kingdom and indeed the world
but through all of this
she was a constant steadying presence
she met every moment every crisis every
problem with a reassuring presence and a
calming words always reflecting the mood
of the nation
madam deputy speaker
her majesty was and will always be our
nation's north star
the example that she set for all of us
will continue to shine bright in our
memories to guide us to inspire us
towards a better tomorrow
on behalf of the people of wakefield
hawaii and aussies we thank her majesty
queen elizabeth ii for her love and his
service to our nation and our thoughts
and prayers over king charles iii and
the royal family god save the king
matt mormont
madam deputy speaker in 2012 prior to
the diamond jubilee the queen hosted a
reception at buckingham palace for
national newspaper editors the usual
great and the good and to my surprise
technology editors as well it induced
the unique gut-wrenching dual anxiety of
having both to meet her majesty and to
do so with your boss
thankfully the duke of edinburgh said
technologists such as myself were there
because people like us knew what was
going on
it put me uniquely at ease at least for
the seconds before i realized he had
just said something explicitly that i'd
only ever optimistically inferred from
my bosses
but perhaps surprisingly that digital
jubilee reception wasn't a novel concept
the queen
understood she had to be seen to be
believed we knew her first in the 40s
and 50s via black and white photos on
the wireless that scratchingly televised
coronation there was so many people's
first
experience of television
by the 2020s it was ultra high
definition video and in the lockdown of
2020 itself it was zoom
she moved with the times
and the times moved with her
she was present in our lives in a way
that moved even places like boston or
skegness that she never visited to hold
street parties in her honor and now
moves many there to tears
i met his majesty king charles at a
reception perhaps surprisingly for
robert's radio
long-standing warrant holders he too
knows that technology can make his
family's warmth and service palpable
around the world and he used the
opportunity to do an impression from the
goon show which sadly only time
precludes me from recreating in this
house today
now
with tv cameras in the accession council
we've already seen more of what it is to
be a monarch than we ever could have
done previously and long may that
continue it is familiarity and closeness
that fosters hope and togetherness with
our sovereign
i said a minute ago that we first saw
her majesty in black and white and later
on zoom i should of course have said
that we are unlikely to see such a
lengthy reign with its diligence its
humility its uplifting love ever again
thanks to the times in which she lived
we are blessed to have felt uniquely
close to so much of it
that makes its absence
feel so personal so acute grief is the
price we pay for love god save the king
dave dugan
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
speak to the memory of her late majesty
the queen on behalf of my many
constituents and angus who hold her held
her close in their affections
the queen was a very popular figure
across much of scotland and especially
in angus a fondness that was a result
and a consequence of her personal
characteristic her demeanor her warmth
and her character much more than it was
any sort of institutional devotion
her length of service over seven decades
afforded people a sense of continuity
and stability in a world which changed
immeasurably over the period of her
reign
her great appreciation for scotland and
angus is a source of great pride for
many scots
her mother was a child of angus being
born in glams and her majesty visited
angus multiple times in karimur in 1969
returning to kirimur in 2004 at 2004 and
visiting her growth and fought for at
the same time it's well understood that
she was happiest in balmoral in west
aberdeenshire in kincardine
and her very public fondness for her
highland home was a source of pride in
scotland naturally also the astonishing
landscape in which balmoral is set is
adjacent to our iconic angus glenns so i
know very keenly why she valued
her time in this part of scotland so
much and i believe it must have been a
great comfort to her
to be there in her final hours with her
family around about her
unlike many other members in this house
i didn't get to meet the late uh queen
either
but as a four-year-old in perth
i can actually still remember the
excitement in the streets as we queued
and waited for the young or still quite
young queen to pass as part of her
jubilee celebrations in
1977 and again in perth as a local
councillor this time in 2012 i witnessed
her incredible professionalism and charm
and pace and patience as into as she
presented the keys to the city restoring
perth to city status as part of a
diamond jubilee celebrations
i wish to extend my condolences to the
millions of people grieving at the death
of her late majesty
but death bears hardest on the family
and madam deputy speaker especially the
death of a mother
no matter who that mother is
so i convey my sympathies to all her
family in closing the queen was also
defender of her faith a role which she
took very seriously and as such
demonstrated her extending credentials
as a committed christian
so when i pray for the pose of her soul
i have great confidence that she will
now be in the arms of god
may she rest in peace thank you
paul maynard
yeah yeah thank you marlon dr speaker it
is my sorrowful task to
express the grief and sadness of the
people of dr north and cleveland's at
the loss of her late majesty and also to
send our best wishes to our new king
charles iii
as part of the red rose county we have
not just lost
our monarch but also our duke of
lancaster
i am one of those today who never had
the chance to meet her majesty like the
vast majority of my constituents have
not done so but i know the affection in
which we all held up every flag
displayed on every house every strip of
bunting hung up in every street every
cupcake consumed at every event last
summer for the for the platinum jubilee
demonstrated the affection
in which it was held across the front
coast and now blackpool has even dimmed
its famous illuminations out of respect
for her passing in blackpool we remember
fondly the last time she came to our
town in 2009 to see the royal variety
performance
i've often wondered what a woman in her
early 80s at the time made at the pop
sensations of 2009 and she sat there
poorly wishing that it would all be over
soon as she'd go to bed
but one lesson i took from that is that
for pop stars and indeed for politicians
fame is transitory
but the renown of a monarch such as her
will echoed down the ages
for seven decades she has inextricably
been intertwined with our nationhood our
sense of identity of who we are as a
nation she has shared our highs and our
loads our successors our triumphs and
our disasters and we have shared hers as
well
the high times the good times the
jubilees are celebrations but also the
lows and who will ever forget the sight
of her sitting alone in saint george's
chapel in windsor the funeral of her
late husband the member for ashford used
the word uncertainty as we began our
tributes today and i feel that sense of
uncertainty myself somewhat
be rest we face difficult uncertain
times ahead of us but we look to her
example of duty of sacrifice of regard
for others of steadfastness that
whatever the coming years or months may
hold that we will hold true to her
memory and the example she set may she
rest in peace
god save the king
jill ferlis
thank you madame deputy speaker
i rise today to pay tribute to her
majesty queen elizabeth ii on behalf of
my constituents in sheffield broadside
and hillsborough for people across
sheffield
her majesty was a great source of
comfort and stability across her 70-year
reign she was our queen she belonged to
us we had the good times we had bad
times but all the time she held a
special place in all of our hearts i
want to briefly talk about one occasion
where importance to my city really shone
through in 2001 sheffield had the great
honor of welcoming her majesty to our
city as she opened the fabulous brand
new millennium gallery it is impossible
to overstate what this meant to the city
never before or since have i seen so
many people it seemed like thousands in
the streets of sheffield just to try and
catch a glimpse of their beloved queen
their joy and enthusiasm and
anticipation was humbling
as a council lead for arts and culture
for just a few weeks i had the privilege
of meeting her majesty in the duke of
edinburgh at the door of the gallery and
managed a courtesy without falling flats
on my face this was a great relief
she was incredibly generous with her
time ensuring that she spoke to as many
people as possible dignity compassion
and sense of humor shone throughout the
entire day that's evening we welcomed
her majesty to a very fancy dinner
hosted by the then lord mayor this was
as you can imagine a carefully
orchestrated occasion which took many
months of detailed planning
however on the day we learned that her
majesty's favorite drink was none other
than ajubane and lemonade
not having any to hand we we quickly
sped to the lord mayor's office in order
to go through the drinks cabinet to see
if there was any there i have to report
there wasn't so
someone was sent out to scour the
streets of sheffield because no way was
sheffield going to be known as the one
city that couldn't provide the queen
with her favorite tipple
so i'm pleased to say we were able to
find one just in time for the dinner i
will always have home memories of that
day not least as it was one of only two
occasions where i've worn a hat it
brought such joy to sheffield bringing
so many people from across the city
together
her magi majesty represented a unifying
figure above the divides of politics who
everybody looked to for comforts in good
times and solace in bad
her sense of duty was truly felt by all
myself and all my constituents in
sheffield brought brightside
and hillsborough express our deepest
sympathies and condolences to the royal
family
we share in their grief and sorrow and
will miss her greatly may she rest in
peace and may god save the king
jack lopresti
thank you madam deputy speaker
sadly i never met the queen it was
something i'd always hoped to do however
like most people in our country and the
commonwealth she was always a positive
presence in my life
and we do remember that her majesty
queen elizabeth ii was not only our head
of state and the mother of our nation
she indeed had the same responsibilities
and duties for the peoples of our
dependent sovereign territories as in
far away places like the falkland
islands and the governments and the
peoples of the commonwealth nations
around the world now this was brought
home to me in an amazing way when i was
chairman of the all party group for
gibraltar
join nasa gibraltar national day which
is today the 10th of september gibraltar
celebrates its unique identity and its
britishness there is normally a huge
rally in casemate square which is right
in the middle of gibraltar it is a
fantastic occasion when the whole place
is festooned with union flags and the
red and white of the gibraltar flag
today the celebrations have been
postponed until next year and the
proclamation of king charles iii was
shown on the screens in casemate square
failure fabian picada the chief minister
spoke yesterday of a cloud of sorrow
over the rock and the royal gibraltar
regiment had a 96 gun salute now during
happier times national day in the
diamond jubilee year of 2012 there was a
huge picture of the queen at the rally
every speaker on the platform gave
thanks and appreciation for her
majesty's service and spoke of their
pride in their britishness and their
queen and some speakers referred to the
fact and reminded us of the queen had
previously visited gibraltar
now on the platform that day in 2012
fabian used a phrase which i haven't
heard before but what i think
encapsulates the way the queen was a
great unifier
of many different peoples and nations he
said the people of gibraltar other
sovereign territories and the
commonwealth are all part of the great
british family now even more so in a
place like gibraltar which is a small
piece of rock that is a real melting pot
of different religions and cultures
within physical sites of the north
african coast everyone was united on
that day with an outpouring of love
pride and appreciation for our monarch
i was reminded of the old latin quote
sevis
meaning i am a roman citizen which you
could be from africa to northern
britannia regardless of the place of
your birth or your religion
yesterday even i was rushed back from my
constituency to attend a church service
at saint peter's church and filter the
congregation was told by the reverend
lizzie gregory that it wasn't a service
of commemoration that would come
but yesterday was a time for the
community to come together support one
another grieve together and give thanks
it was a wonderful service and it was
great to see so many people there most
had come on foot from nearby and you
could really sense the pride the depth
of emotion and the community supporting
one another so in conclusion madam
deputy speaker i don't normally quote
french heads of state unless they were
born in corsica
but i thought that president
but i thought president macron's
comments on the passing of the queen sum
up how we and the rest of the world see
her all sort
he said to you
she was your queen
to us
she was the queen she will be with us
all forever
deputy speaker today i rise to pay
tribute to a mother
grandmother great grandmother and our
longest servant monarch
i want to extend my sincere condolences
and those of everyone in my city of
coventry to his majesty the king and all
the royal family
the reign of queen elizabeth ii
was one of intense social and economic
transformation
and yet she remained the firm
cornerstone of our collective lives
people all over the globe were reassured
by the queen
as a force
of constancy and dependability
when all around them was ever changing
coventry
has been blessed with many visits from
the queen over the years
in 1956
just four years into her reign the queen
visited the ruins of the first state
michael's cathedral in coventry to lay
the foundation stone for the next
cathedral next door
after years of relentless bombing
throughout the second world war
bombing which destroyed so many of the
city devastated thousands of homes
schools and took countless lives
the city was beset by grief and a deep
sense of loss as it is today
however
a visit from her majesty the queen we
breathed new lives into our community
the impact the queen had on our city was
certainly significant
as a city of peace and reconciliation
the queen's presence gave people hope
for the future despite the tragedies of
the past
in 1994
the queen visited the then jaguar
factory in browns lane in my
constituency of coventry northwest
and it was a visit that my constituents
valued and fondly remember
this year during the various platinum
jubilee celebrations that i attended
across my constituency
many shared stories about their love
and adoration of the crew
to many in coventry
she was a symbol of optimism
the new world
and the future
and it is certainly how our city will
remember her
madam deputy speaker
my own prayers are with the members of
the royal family during this difficult
time
the queen was a spiritual leader for so
many christians and a moral guide for
anyone in public life
and i know that in churches and in
places of worship in coventry and across
the country
we will be taking this time to reflect
her values and her exceptional life
today we mourn our beloved queen and we
are grateful beyond measures for
everything that she has given us may her
soul rest in peace and god saved the
king
wendy morton
[Music]
thank you madam deputy speaker and thank
you for allowing me to speak
this afternoon um as chief whip an
opportunity
that is very rarely afforded to cheat to
whip members of the whips officer as you
know
never
indeed normally keep quiet but this is
such a special occasion a very important
occasion and i also want to recognize
that the wips office also has a very
special and unique relationship with her
majesty's household in terms of the
positions that some of the whips
holds but i really wanted on behalf of
my constituency of aldridge brown hills
and
on behalf of all my constituents to pay
tribute to her late majesty we all have
personal stories and memories for me i
never actually met the queen but often
saw her at a distance
but i wanted to reflect on the silver
jubilee back in 1977 when i was a little
bit younger than i am now and i would
cut the pictures out of my mum's
magazines and the newspapers to create a
scrapbook and i see
honorable friends nodding and i think so
many of us did that in the days before
social media yeah and somewhere at home
i still have that scrapbook and when i
get back i want to go and find it but i
have so many memories of of that and i
remember the village coming together as
a community and everybody was part of
this and i reflect more recently on the
platinum jubilee celebrations across my
aldridge brown hills constituency the
many community events the tea parties
the street parties but most of all the
community spirit the tremendous
community spirit it's the hallmark of
aldrich brown hills but it's also a real
testament of the huge amount of love and
respect that so many had for her late
majesty someone who
not only really understands people
and communities the nation but also had
a unique way of bringing our country
together
and madame deputy speaker in speaking on
behalf of my constituency i alwa i also
want to say that i think above all we
remember and recognize her service and
her duty to all across our nation the
commonwealth and indeed the world she
has been truly remarkable she was
and will remain to many of us
an inspiration
and as we come together as a nation to
mourn the loss of her late majesty
and to say farewell i do so while also
pledging my total commitment and
support to
king charles iii
and i end by saying god save the king
yeah yeah yeah
paul girvin
thank you deputy speaker and
it's an honour and privilege to be able
to take part in the debate giving
tribute to our greatest queen that i
ever
and and many of us probably around this
room knew no other monarch
and uh i must say that
a great debt of gratitude is owed to
the royal family and to the queen
for the service that she has given to
this nation and not only
to this nation but to the commonwealth
and the duty that she has performed in
that
i can say that
i i did get to meet the queen unlike
some people who've said everyone seems
to have known her
and i think there was a statistic came
out
in recent days to say that 30 percent 31
of the united kingdom population had
actually met
or had been introduced to the queen now
that's a as a tremendous
number of people
and a population of the united kingdom
but i just wanted to just highlight a
point i met with
king
charles iii
but he was prince charles at that stage
and i made a mistake
i was the introducer for a group of
people that were being introduced to
prince charles i made the mistake of
putting my hand round prince charles
shoulder as
i tend to do i was i got threatened with
being thrown into
the tar
and i i
remembered that i had i had committed
that crime
and when i was asked
at hillsborough gardens
party to introduce a group of 10 people
to her majesty i made sure i did not
put my arm around her majesty at that
stage but you know it's with fondness
that i remember the queen and everyone
has mentioned how she had this bright
vibrant way but there were some people
in our community who could not tolerate
the queen
and the queen came to northern ireland
in 1966
to open a bridge called the queens
bridge
and
a gentleman who decided that he would
throw a brick from a building
onto the queen's car
now that was in uh the fourth of july
1966 there was a police officer who
arrested that gentleman
was mr john mciver
sergeant john mcivor who has since died
but i can only say that that man had
more hatred in him for our monarch and i
think that she showed more grace she
continued on as though nothing had
happened and her duties of that day and
that says far more about what the queen
that queen that we had i want to say
thank you to the queen and to the family
and for what they've done and i want to
say god save the king
robert courts
thank you uh madame deputy speaker
last thursday was one of those days
where it seemed as if the world had
stopped
people in crowds on the streets looking
at notifications coming up on their
phone and stopping and looking at each
other not speaking because everyone was
thinking the same thing
everyone was thinking that that day that
we all hoped would never come
had finally come
it was the day in which we lost the best
servant uh and the best leader that this
country could ever hope to have and it's
since then we've been
thinking we've heard from the speeches
in the house about the incredible honor
and privilege it is for all of us to be
able to call ourselves elizabethans
and as i rise today to pay tribute to
her majesty on behalf of myself my
family of course and my constituency of
whitney and west oxfordshire
i'm also thinking about
the early contact that west oxfordshire
had with her majesty and i think perhaps
the first may have been
from 1928 when west oxfordshire's most
famous son winston churchill
stayed with the royal family at balmoral
during the reign of king george v
and his wife clementine he wrote
there is no one here except the family
the household and queen elizabeth
age two
the last is a character
she has an air of authority and
reflectiveness astonishing in an infant
now madam deputy speaker isn't it
extraordinary and yet not surprising
that winston churchill picked out those
very qualities in her majesty that would
make her such a revered individual the
most famous woman in the world and the
most revered monarch in our history so
early it's that easy authority that she
had that we've heard referred to by so
many honourable members today
and throughout those 70 years of service
she saw change unparalleled when she was
a girl the raf was flying aircraft that
were wood and canvas and now she we've
gone through to where the planes don't
even need a pilot and they're fast and
supersonic utterly extraordinary levels
of change yet she
remained the same and yet changed as
society changed but it's not just that
she's always been here true though that
is
it's not just that she's a constant it's
that she was a unifying constant
we'll all have our different memories
madame deputy speaker
but
what's gone is not lost
the memories we have of her remain her
guide her example remains with us and
they give us an example of how he can
reach the storms of today and tomorrow
and as we saw in the electrifying speech
from his majesty the king last night
that duty will continue and so whilst
our voices are choked with emotion
we can all rally with the timeless cry
god save the king
aaron bell
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
sad privilege to rise to speak on behalf
of my constituency newcastle underline
to offer my condolences and theirs to
his majesty and to the whole royal
family and to give thanks for the life
and service of her majesty
as britons we are lucky to live in a
constitutional monarchy but to have had
the queen as our constitutional monarch
we were more than lucky we were blessed
i believe she is the greatest public
servant this nation has ever seen
through 70 years she has led this nation
through profound challenges and seen
profound change not just in this nation
but throughout the world across the
commonwealth and she has led us and
guided us throughout
with her grace with her wisdom
and with her example
and in newcastle underline she visited
us in 1973 for our octo centenary the
constituents of mine of a certain age
will remember that and as we prepare to
celebrate again next year 850 years
those memories will be all and more
poignant all the more poignant now madam
deputy speaker
but i think
as we remember her majesty
i i would like to pay tribute to the way
that she has led this nation only
earlier this week we had the transfer of
power and that is something that she
continued to take her responsibilities
her constitutional responsibilities with
the utmost seriousness to the end and
i'm sure the prime minister was
extremely grateful for her advice only
on tuesday
and i've stood and listened to i've sat
in this chamber and listened to much of
the debate both yesterday and today
there have been some very fine and
moving speeches some very funny ones as
well on all sides i think the finest
speech i've heard was not from the
dispatch box it was not from these
benches but it was not even from the
opposition benches it was from those
monitors yesterday when we listened to
his majesty addressed the nation
it was a profoundly fine and moving
speech and it confirmed to me what i
already knew from his many years of
service as the prince of wales that the
crown is in very safe hands
and that we can look forward with
confidence as we go through yet another
trying time for our nation
he will follow in his his mother's
example
leading us
into a new era as we say
god save the king
joe churchill
yeah
thank you very much indeed madame from
deputy madam speaker and thank you for
the indulgence of allowing
the whips to speak in this debate
or in this tribute
i rise to give thanks for
the wonderful
long life of her majesty elizabeth i
queen
on behalf of myself but also the people
of the varys and evans constituency
as many others have said
she was as
each and every one of us
she was special to us individually young
and old in this great country in the
commonwealth and beyond
we have relied on her to be there her
constancy her service
her humor
and her love
many in this chamber as others have said
have
recounted amusing tales of those
twinkling eyes resting on them and that
sense of fun
and like others she's visited my
constituency on many times
the final occasion for the maundy
service in our cathedral
and she left her mark
but as
my honourable friend said
as i sat in this chamber and we listened
to the king yesterday
i wanted to say that our thoughts
and prayers are with her family
and her friends
who for all their lives
their entire lives
have had to share with us
their mother their grandmother their
great grandmother
and their friend
and to her dear late husband his wife
may they now be comforted by us
as our expressions of gratitude and love
for the late queen
as they carry on as she did with duty
and stoicism
constantly and consistently showing us
the way
so to her we say thank you
from the bottom of our hearts and
although it feels not enough
as her faith took her through her life
may it take her on her final journey
and may she rest in peace
finally earlier this week i was truly
honored to be appointed vice chamberlain
and i say
with feeling in anticipation
of having to write
to his majesty the king daley
god save the king
jason mccartney
[Applause]
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise on
behalf of my com valley constituents to
pay tribute to her majesty the queen's
decades of service to our nation
decades of service delivered with
humility
with warmth with wisdom
and with gentle humor
madam deputy speaker as chair of the all
party parliamentary group for woods and
trees i wrote to all my local schools
earlier this year
inviting them to take part in the
queen's green canopy scheme
planting a tree for the jubilee
i visited many of my local schools and
we planted a tree
and of course afterwards we had a q a
session
i was often asked if i knew boris
yes he's my boss i'd say oh was my boss
am i rich
um i tried to not really answer that one
and and then of course i'd always be
asked have i ever met
the queen
and i would say yes
a number of times i've been very
fortunate
and the children would gasp with
excitement
i would tell them about the number of
times i met her whilst as a young royal
air force officer i was based at raf
west raynham in norfolk near fakenum
sandringham was just up the road so her
majesty was a regular visitor to our raf
station
and then some 20 years later
as an mp i was invited to buckingham
palace as mp's r for an audience with
her majesty
she was asking me about my constituency
and i told her that the market town of
home firth
is in my patch
and i said your majesty it's where they
film last of the summer wine on bbc one
and her face lit up with a big smile
i don't know whether she watched it or
not but to this day
i have this lovely image
that on a sunday tea time
after a busy week
she would sit down in an armchair
put on bbc one
and enjoy the gentle antics of nora
batting compo and cleggy
not that cleggy
and relax
madame deputy speaker the past 48 hours
have been
a very emotional time for our nation but
having listened to my constituents today
i know they were very much reassured
by his majesty the king's
reassuring and very deeply personal
address to the nation last night
i look forward to heading back to
yorkshire this evening
so i can be at huddersfield town hall
tomorrow for the royal proclamation
and i'll just end by saying madame
deputy speaker
god bless her majesty the queen
and god save the king yeah
simon fell
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise
with um
quite a lot of weight um to pay tribute
and offer heartfelt condolences on
behalf of the people of barrow and
furnace and
of my family to king charles and his
family on the death of the late her
majesty
her majesty served our nation for 70
years with a remarkable and an
unstinting sense of duty that should
inspire us all but even with tens of
thousands of hours of her life captured
on film and written about in column
inches we didn't know anything about her
politics or her views on policy debated
in this place despite what we may have
thought or suspected
to hold audiences with prime ministers
through wars pandemics and times of
national crisis and to keep her counsel
even with the passage of so many years
speaks volumes of her character and of
her sense of duty
her majesty was a fixture in our lives
all my life she's been there she's been
a constant
when i was young and fell in love with
books for the first time she was there
she was greeting sophie and the big
friendly giant at the end of roald
dahl's novel
what i saw in my mind wasn't a character
in a story with a crown on her head it
was our queen
she was so much a part of our world and
of my world
and so magical at the same time that of
course it was entirely possible that it
was her majesty taking breakfast with a
giant
and i'm glad that same sense of wonder
and magic has crossed through the ages
my own children were delighted to see
her sharing the screen and her jam
sandwiches with paddington bear
she was at comfort with herself and her
role
always a steady hand at the tiller of
our nation our unflappable constant
monarch
but still aware of what she meant to
people and the joy and the comfort that
she could and she did bring
her majesty was a friend and a frequent
visitor to barrow and south lakeland she
launched hms dreadnought our first
nuclear submarine
she also launched the aircraft carrier
hms invincible with a crowd of 15 000
people gathering in the drizzle to
witness her blessing the ship
christening it with a bottle of
elderberry wine
she visited furnace general hospital our
town hall and the northwest evening mail
and she opened our market too
celebrating her platinum jubilee i was
struck by just how many constituents
came forward probably part of that 30
with stories of the time they'd met her
majesty and of just how important those
moments were to them
many of those moments were fleeting but
the impact they made was substantial
the quote's been used a few times today
and and yesterday as well but um her
majesty once said that grief is the
price we pay for love
we love that remarkable lady for her
service for her dignity and her
instincting dedication to the nation and
to her people
in grief we can reflect on that
dedication to us and perhaps draw some
comfort from her service and her life
certainly i hope that her family and his
majesty king charles will find solace
and gratitude
in
the grace and gratitude of our grateful
nation
may she rest in peace and god save the
king yeah
deputy speaker uh it's a sad honor to be
called uh contribute to her majesty
um
many colleagues have spoken of the fact
that she was a constant throughout our
lives and i've said before that i regard
myself as a son of the commonwealth and
one of the proudest moments i've found
in the last 48 hours is that while we
may have lost our queen the world has
lost the queen
she visited southwest hertfordshire a
few times um the last two visits that
i'm aware of i think were really
symptomatic of who she was
back in 2010 she opened up
the joint headquarters in northwood in
the south of my constituency
and all of my friends that i speak to
are ex-military
are sadly
sorrowful over the fact that she has now
passed
her most recent visit was in 2016 when
she came to visit birkensted school i
know the honourable member for whitney
is a former alumni
she was the patron of birkensted school
in 2016 they were celebrating their
475th
anniversary
when i went to see the school recently i
could still see the look of wonder in
the eyes of the children that had the
honor of meeting her i never had that
but every time my parents when i was a
lot younger used to drive past
buckingham palace on the rare occasions
we drove in
we always looked with fondness to see if
the wall standard was up
and my father probably treasonously used
to say his auntie lives in
my brother-in-law
like most families have been speaking
about the queen over the last couple of
days but he mentioned that normally you
would have photos of your loved ones in
your wallet or purse
and i would argue we do each and every
one of us have a photo of our loved one
the queen by virtue of the notes
i thought that was a fitting tribute for
what i regard as an amazing woman
on behalf of my constituents of
southwest hertfordshire can i send my
condolences to the whole world family
they have lost a loved one the country
has lost a great champion for our values
and i don't think there'll be another
one like you know many many generations
to come
god save the king
laura farris
mr deputy speaker it is with profound
sadness that i rise to pay tribute to
her late majesty the queen on behalf of
my constituents in west berkshire
she was the lord star of our national
life and in west berkshire she was
treasured for her passionate engagement
in our signature pastime
racing
she was a frequent visitor to newbury
racecourse sent multiple champions for
training in lamborn and even purchased
her own racing stables in west illsley
the legendary lamborn trainer nikki
henderson told me that when a foal of
particularly promising parentage was
born in the spring of this year she said
nikki when this one runs for the first
time as a four-year-old i'll be 100
you'll be 75 and we will be the oldest
owner trainer combination in the world
in the end it wasn't to be but it was at
newbury racecourse that she saw some of
the greatest triumphs of her racing life
in april 1958 six years into her reign
she was there when dutel gave her her
first winner in the john porter stakes a
year when howard macmillan was prime
minister sputnik one was launched into
space elvis topped the charts with
jailhouse rock and vietnam stood on the
brink of war
she saw victory again in august 1967
with hopeful venture in the jeffrey
freyr stakes it was the era of harold
wilson and the beatles where nasa was
putting the finishing touches to its
preparations for launching man onto the
moon
just after margaret thatcher's 1979
election landslide she was there again
with rhyme royale who came home for her
in the london gold cup
it was the year of the iran hostage
crisis and the assassination of lord
mountbatten at the hands of the ira
she saw phantom cruise to victory in
1996 the year of the dunblane massacre
and just months before the assassination
of yitzhak rabin
2017 was her last visit to newbury
she entered the winner's enclosure just
one day after her 91st birthday when
call to mind was victorious in the dubai
duty-free maiden maiden
the country was in the midst of a
general election campaign and was
reeling from terrorist attacks in
westminster london bridge and manchester
through her reign
war and peace
triumph and disaster presidents and
prime ministers she was our strength and
our comfort and we in newbury will
always be proud that she derived moments
of pure joy in the place that we call
home
i send my sincere condolences to the
royal family and also to the family of
the princess
of wales who are my constituents may she
rest in peace
miles wattling
thank you mr deputy speaker it's a great
honor to stand here
representing the people of clacton um i
know from what i've heard and seen and
read
that the people of clacton
loved our queen
and they're in deep mourning now
she was an incredible woman and i
had the honor
of meeting her on a couple of occasions
and many members of her family but she
had that one
now not so secret weapon
which was that
devastating smile
that she would unleash mercilessly
and bring people to her
this is why
in many ways her personality shone
through that smile
she was my queen she was your queen she
was
each individual's queen
she was the people of clacton's queen
she was the uk's queen
and her realms overseas
she was also the queen
to so many people around the world and i
read only yesterday that 93
of the world's population have known no
other queen
she is the queen she has gone
and we mourn her deeply
but i'd like to tell a very short brief
story about my father's relationship
with the queen
he had to introduce her he had the
unenviable task of having to introduce
her to 25 members of the board of the
royal theatrical fund
now my father on a good day although he
was a great actor had difficulty
remembering his own name
so
he was it was with great trepidation he
had to face this task so he came up with
this wonderful scheme i still remember
one in five of you so i only have to
remember five names so i'll introduce
tom and tomorrow introduce bert george
harry and fred
and that worked tremendously
on the morning of the meeting everybody
brought their husbands and wives with
them
so the room was full and crowded so my
father's scheme still worked my mother
was there my father's scheme still
worked he introduced tom he introduced
fred harry jane sheila
but he forgot to introduce introduce my
mother to the queen
and so the queen said
and who is this
and my father couldn't remember
so he said
at home we call her mother
[Laughter]
to say the queen was amused is advanced
she immediately asked for a drink and
went to the bar
um
my father had many happy memories of the
queen as do i
may she rest in peace
god save the king
david rutley yeah yeah
this is deputy speaker many great
tributes have already been made and uh
it's great to be able to follow the
honourable member for clacton and i hope
that his mother
was able to overcome that experience
um
it's an honor to be able to add to those
with the great
tributes to the people of macclesfield
constituency who are in mourning with a
deep sense of loss like so many others
across the nation her majesty's life was
a beacon indeed the embodiment of the
principle of public service and
unfailing duty we're all very grateful
for her example he'll be cherished for
the rest of our lives and throughout
history my wife rachel and i were
fortunate to meet her majesty in
buckingham palace with a number of other
colleagues several from scotland on the
bench's opposite she loved scotland
she loved the union and she loved the
commonwealth
and what impressed both of us the most
though was the sincere interest that her
majesty showed to those she met she
showed genuine love
and concern to all those she worked to
serve
and we're most grateful for that
on that occasion prince philip talked
about fond memories of carriage driving
in henbury and enjoying services at
saint auburn's church in macclesfield
the queen visited macclesfield as a
young 23 year old princess to celebrate
the town's unique silk heritage at
herdsfield mills and then again in 2002
as part of the golden jubilee tour
visiting king's school
sadly she was not able to visit the
iconic jodrell bank telescope site to
celebrate it receiving unesco world
heritage status in 2020 due to the
pandemic and she would have been so very
proud of its new first light pavilion
that has just opened
mr deputy speaker
we think we know our constituencies well
but the queen really understood the
communities and geography that she
served throughout the entire nation
historians will write about queen
elizabeth as a statesman a diplomat a
defender of all faiths and a much loved
and respected monarch through 70 years
of dedicated service
but it's what she wrote in our hearts
millions of people
throughout our constituencies across the
country and the commonwealth's family of
nations that will be her real lasting
legacy
with a sad passing we all now have the
responsibility to live up to that legacy
to renew
and recommit ourselves in our service to
others
and in so doing will show our true
gratitude to this wonderful servant who
only a little over
five foot or tall was a towering figure
in our nation's history
may she rest in peace mr deputy speaker
our thoughts and prayers remain with the
royal family and with our new king
charles iii as he takes forward his new
duties we pray that he'll be granted
with strength with wisdom
and with the enduring influence of his
much loved mother
god save the king
yeah it's a paul barristan
thank you mr deputy speaker
i've visited or was visited by a number
of my constituents yesterday and i
forgot what we were there to discuss and
so were they all i could talk about was
the queen
sad to begin with
moved across the positive things and the
condolences were combined with feelings
really positive feelings for her
but it was in the
1953 at the end of 1953
the queen and the duke visited new
zealand
right at the end of it
now new zealand is as far away as you
can get from buckingham palace without
coming back
so
it's still heavily royal
it certainly was at that time
and
i was knee-hearted hi to a grasshopper
and
public reaction towards the visit was so
positive that i suddenly realized even
though i was the hydro grasshopper
that there was a very important person
called the queen
and i certainly found that because
the queen and prince philip
had a really positive flowing behind
them when they arrived just before
christmas
but they greatly engendered it
as a result of their sympathetic and
instant positive reaction
in response to what
people won't know here was the tangawai
disaster
the royal couple arrived in new zealand
on the 23rd of december and the
following day
christmas eve 1953
a railway bridge
over the tamworth gorge collapsed
and it collapsed just as a heavy loaded
express train
rolled onto it
the locomotive and the first six
carriages derailed into the river
carrying 151 people
the tour
stopped
and the royal couple were involved in
all the sympathy
the memorials the meeting the people
those that had lost relatives and those
that have survived
and their position in new zealand rose
as high as you can possibly think
it really solidified this very strong
standing in the eyes of all of the new
zealand public
whether they were pakeha or maori
they charmed their way throughout the
country
and those who've talked particularly of
the commonwealth today and yesterday
that was the way the queen became the
linchpin of the commonwealth
because she charmed her way with
presidents prime ministers and the
people of those 56 nations
and the two and a half billion people
that make up the commonwealth
the commonwealth
is vital to our position and to some
sanity on this earth
we now look
to our new king to continue her success
it's a huge job
i wish him well because his feelings
filling some enormous huge shoes
that were worn by a very small lady who
was enormously successful
i wish him well
and pray that it works as well as it did
with this mother
just before i call mark logan say that
just put on the record my appreciation
and that from the people of the rebel
valley as well she had a very strong
relationship with rouble valley i met
her then also was honored to meet her
here in london as well it was rumored by
a lady in waiting that if ever her
majesty retired she would want to retire
into the rebel valley
but we all know she never intended to
retire because hers was a lifetime of
service for which we are incredibly
grateful we will miss her god save the
king
mark logan
it's a privilege a sorrowful one to rise
and speak on behalf of bolton north east
to pay tribute to her majesty the queen
mr deputy speaker we are faced with the
indescribable loss of the guardian of
our traditions the soul
of our nation
but her majesty was more than that for
evermore she was
the united kingdom
we are feeling this loss
echoingly so in bolton
you only had to be there during the
platinum jubilee celebrations to get a
sense of the adulation felt for the
queen in our time indeed bolton was on
many occasions the preferred destination
of her majesty
in 1953 not long after taking the throne
the queen's first ever football match
was the fa cup final between blackpool
and bolton wanderers at wembley stadium
wonders lost 4-3
though this was later remedied in 1958
when the duke of edinburgh awarded
bolton wanderers with the fa cup after
beating mine united two-nil
in 1954 her majesty first visited bolton
where the royal train pulled up into
trinity street session and in 1968 she
visited saint paul's church in hollywell
1988 queen elizabeth ii visited bolson
to celebrate the town's 150th
birthday witnessing investment into the
town centre and 30 years on the town is
being revamped once again
in her last visit a visit that she made
to warburtons where the rock that was
forever by her side the duke of
edinburgh joked with factory workers and
i was going to say imagine being a fly
on the wall for some of those jokes
but the warbertons has the best hygiene
regime in place and therefore no flies
mps only think we're busy running around
our constituencies when her majesty was
able to see
so many people and places in each of our
respective places
indeed she was there all along as our
living environments and country went
through inevitable change
we as people can learn from her
integrity
living up to higher standards
for she was the standard
the wave of her hand
the comfort of her words
at 3 p.m on christmas day
the steps she took on every footpath
across the kingdom and the commonwealth
keeping us all on the one road
we'll never cease to miss
and to cherish her and as her majesty
said during june's celebrations i hope
this renewed
sense of togetherness will be felt for
many years to come
and as we're brought here together today
to mourn our collective loss i say god
bless the queen god save the king
jonathan gillis
thank you mr deputy speaker it is with
great sadness that i stand today on
behalf of the people of stoke on trent
north kidsgrove and talk to sharing our
collective grief in the loss of the
grandmother of the nation her late
majesty queen elizabeth ii like many
across this house stoke-on-trent north
kids grab and talk was blessed to host
her late majesty the queen on a few
occasions
dating all the way back to 1949 when the
then princess royal visit the potteries
in the mother town of berlin before
returning in 1955 visiting 30 000
excited school children at the old home
of stoke city football club victoria
ground and again in 1999 when her late
majesty visited the dozens center
meeting members of the touring hale
orchestra
the right honourable member for uxbridge
in south reislip was right when he said
that we allowed ourselves to believe her
late major the queen to be eternal
in preparation for this speech i
reflected on some words from the famous
stoke-on-trent author arnold bennett who
said
we shall never have more time
we have
and always had all the time there is
whilst bennett is right that we shall no
longer have her late majesty the queen
as a physical presence in our lives
something i have tried to explain to my
daughter in media who only on tuesday
whilst on face on me as i was lucky
enough to sit here in his palace in
westminster said daddy meet the queen
her late majesty's legacy will continue
to live on forever
in generations yet to come
her dedication to public service and
duty her national pride and her
unwavering personal faith provide
lessons for us all to pass down to our
children and grandchildren enabling us
to help support her successor our king
in taking us forward into the future
unsure of what lies ahead but
collectively empowering us to stand
shoulder to shoulder undeterred in our
love and belief in our united kingdom
the people of stoke-on-trent north kids
graven talk as well as i give our
heartfelt condolences to his majesty
king charles iii and his family at this
time
for they have not just lost their queen
too
but they have also lost their mother
grandmother and great grandmother
as we pray that her late majesty the
queen lays an eternal peace and
happiness i and the people of
stoke-on-trent north kids grab and talk
wish to bear our true faith and
allegiance to his majesty king charles
iii as she would have wanted god save
the king
catherine fletcher
mr deputy speaker i want to on behalf of
my family my friends and the people of
south ripple pay tribute to
her majesty que elizabeth ii
it's it's a sad loss that
many people across south ripple have
been in touch with penn with them
leyland crosston tarleton and the
villages surrounding
but what a theme within that especially
today has been that they've felt very
deeply that they want to celebrate a
life
celebrate a remarkable life and a
remarkable woman
so if the house will go with me i would
like to give you two examples of why to
me she was absolutely the epitome of
that
she's a woman of global influence and
respect
in the commonwealth as the honourable
member recently mentioned of the an
african commonwealth country we're sat
around a fire and the and in that
conversation is new zealand zulu
australian shanghai
afrikaans english french australian and
american and that conversation turns to
the queen
it's fair to say that not everybody
understands our system and many
questions were asked and ultimately a
little voice sat in an african
commonwealth country in a kiwi accent
said
oh
she's like the ultimate pressure valve
on your system
and she is that's what a constitutional
monarchy is and she has borne that on
her shoulders since she was 25.
a remarkable life and a remarkable woman
but more personally for me growing up
where i was in the 80s
we had a female prime minister
we had a queen we even had a lady in the
speaker's chair and it did not occur to
seven-year-old me that women were
anything other than in charge
and i'm sure with her famous sense of
humor that has come across in many of
the contributions here today she would
have enjoyed my surprise when i grew a
bit further up and discovered that it
wasn't the norm that women run
everything
from a global icon to an inspiration for
little girl
well
the one and only queen i might even say
she was the original spice girl was she
the originator of girl power it's
possible
but on behalf of all of us i think what
i can say simply is
thank you
for everything
may she rest in peace
rise in glory
and god saves the king
celine saxby
thank you mr deputy speaker it is a
privilege and yet with great sadness
that i rise to pay tribute to queen
elizabeth ii
on behalf of my north devon constituents
and myself
as well as sending north devon's deepest
condolences to the royal family
the queen has been such a constant in
our lives dedicating her life to public
service as she said she would
it is hard to imagine life without her
her beautiful outfits and hats
her smile and her constant reassuring
presence will be sorely missed
thank you for all you have done the joy
you have brought us and memories you
leave us with
the queen visited barnstable back in
1956.
the royal train arrived at the station
at 10 a.m and other than a slight hiccup
with an official opening the wrong door
went off smoothly
she was greeted by 5 000 children in our
pannier market who cheered wildly
and i hope many of those present who are
still with us will have recalled that
day this week and indeed still frequent
our paneer market
unfortunately i was not there in 1956
and have never since had the opportunity
to meet the queen
unlike so many of my longer serving
colleagues
it has been one of the joys at this sad
time
to hear their fun memories and wonderful
anecdotes
as we continue to mourn
we
also with this morning's proclamation
must look to the future
i have no doubt king charles iii will
follow in his mother's fantastic
footsteps
and i have met him
20 years ago
he'd already supported a wide range of
charities which saw him meet ladies from
the moon walk a breast cancer charity
walk at highgrove
and if i do have the privilege to meet
our new monarch again
i was the one in the bra decorated as
two strawberries
may she rest in peace god save the king
so christopher chose
mr deputy speaker
my my constituents and i thank
his majesty the king for his words of
comfort
and reassurance following today's
proclamation of accession as sovereign
and we also send his majesty and the
whole royal family our deepest
condolences on the death of her majesty
the second elizabethan age has received
many references during uh these
last
day and a half of debate
christchurch probably has more people
than any other constituency who can
remember the beginning of the second
elizabethan age in 1952
and i'm among those privileged to have
lived throughout the queen's 70-year
reign
i first saw the queen at her coronation
in 1953 when my parents were invited
to look at a friend's black and white
television i think it was also the first
time i'd ever seen
television
i've been lucky enough to have met her
majesty on several occasions
first at an investiture in 1982 and on
the last occasion as an investiture in
2018
but the meeting to which i wish to elude
is that when i was asked by the
secretary of state for transport to host
the occasion when her majesty opened the
qe2 bridge across the thames
linking the two parts of the m25
as a junior minister i was
tremendously nervous
but her majesty put me at my ease
and we had a long
private conversation about the bridge
its construction
its funding
and i can remember telling her and
assuring her
that the tolls would be lifted as soon
as the bridge was paid for
and uh i'm pleased to say that her
majesty kept her counsel on that as as
we find today the tolls are still there
and the bridge has been paid for several
times over
and so on but um that that i remember
that that occasion distinctly so also i
remember the occasion when her majesty
attended
the
80th birthday party of margaret thatcher
and what was really moving was the way
in which her majesty
showed her support and encouragement
to a margaret thatcher on that occasion
because she herself wasn't in the best
of health and i thought that was an
example of the way in which her majesty
rose to the occasion and on that
occasion she wasn't doing something
which is party political because i think
tony blair was there as as well but her
compassion showed through to all those
of us who were privileged to be uh
present the queen encapsulated and the
mr deputy speaker in my view exemplified
all those qualities that make our nation
the envy of the world
and make us so proud to be british and
this
second elizabethan age which has drawn
to a close uh this week is one which
will be revered for centuries to come
and won't be lucky to be part of it
names daily
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
the 22nd of october 1954 was a rainy
cold day in berry
but thousands of people
lined the streets having waited for
hours in the pouring rain
they'd done that to see the young queen
elizabeth and the duke of edinburgh on
their
post-coronation trip to the northwest of
england to see the great towns and the
great cities of the north
and there is a wonderful pathe video or
pathe film of the occasion
and one can feel coming down the ages
the happiness the excitement the passion
the pride of everyone in from every
different town in knowing that for one
second just one moment they may see
their queen they may see their queen
that means so much to them and that was
1954.
now berry has changed greatly since 1954
in all sorts of ways
socially the buildings now look very
different to what they did
on the pathe video back there
but the excitement the pride the love
the devotion of the people of bury for
their sovereign has never changed
the young princess elizabeth first came
to very 1938 when she was a very very
very young she came back in 1945
berry was one of the great uh towns of
the north producing armaments and she
came with her father she came again in
1954 in 1968 she was in radcliffe for
town just outside of my constituency
with a great industrial town and in 1992
she came back again to visit berry town
hall that she'd opened on that rainy day
in 1954.
the queen to me
represents something
which is unique and personal she's
linked into every household every person
every village every street every town in
this country she means a different thing
to us all
but what she is is a constant and what
she is is an example of what she lived
her life by was a set of principles for
which we all
loved and admired her when she said to
this nation
many decades ago i give my life into the
service of the of micro of this country
and the people of this country in the
commonwealth she did exactly that she
stands for something
if theo she stands for something more
than we are she is somebody who has
touched the lives of every single person
in berry rams bottom and tottington
she touches your life and she
i speak to and we all we all have this
it doesn't matter we've all lived
through the elizabethan age whether you
are six months old or 70 years old you
all share the same values we have been
honored to live through a period in time
that has linked our towns our heritage
to our histories our families in the
same feelings of love joy and pride in a
unique wonderful woman
may she rest in peace god save the
mr holden
thank you very much mr deputy speaker i
rise today to pay tribute on behalf of
myself and my northwestern constituents
they've already been some very moving
reflections from many members and it's
felt like a privilege to actually be in
the chamber over the last couple of days
especially reflections of my right
honourable friendly member for
maidenhead the honorable the right
honourable member for camberwell and
peckham whose charming personal
anecdotes exemplified i think the
private charm of someone who'd lived
their life in the pull for
full public view
these stories captured the affection and
personal touches
of a graceful sovereign whose humor and
kind heart transcended generations
languages continents like no one else
and uh yesterday my right honourable
friend the member for oaxray and south
rislip in his traditional style
rightly noted that her exemplary
commitment to public service means she
will enter the annals of our history and
out of the world as elizabeth the great
and as the prime minister rightly
remarked yesterday the late queen's
spirit of public service will serve as a
shining example to empower
and inspire future generations including
her son as he takes on his immense new
task as his majesty king charles iii
but her late majesty did not just live
by the principles and values of public
service
but the length depth and breadth of her
dutiful commitment not only to the
united kingdom but also to our realms
across the seas the commonwealth and the
world
made her
into essentially a human embodiment of
selfless public service
over the last few days one quote from
ecclesiastes has returned to me again
and again and that is to everything
there is a season
and a time to every purpose
under heaven
throughout her life as she grew with us
the queen fulfilled many purposes as a
constitutional monarch to passing
generations
a friend
mother grandmother and in recent years
perhaps even a great grandmother
we can find some purpose in her passing
too
her majesty the late queen epitomized
that duty in public service so much so
that when we hear those words today we
even see her and her example
she will be sorely missed but she will
never be forgotten
may she rest in peace and rise in glory
god save the king
kieran
thank you mr deputy speaker it's a
privilege for me to pay tribute to her
majesty queen elizabeth ii today on
behalf of the people of crew and antwich
and surrounding villages i did not have
the honor of meeting the queen but in a
testament to her decades of service and
the diligent attention she paid to every
corner of her realm her majesty visited
the area numerous times
in 1972 she opened leyton hospital
in 1987 she opened cruise heritage
center and visited crew works
in 1995 she was greeted by 200 south
west cheshire scouts at cru train
station and in 2010 she visited reese
heath college in nontwitch
as others have said a visit by the queen
the handshakes the conversations even
just distant glimpses stay in people's
memories
leighton hospital's longest serving
member of staff phil malham now aged 69
talked about the visit as part of
hospital's recent 50th anniversary
celebrations
the visit took place just a few days
after the then 19 year old began working
as a hospital reporter
he wrote
it was a very special day i remember we
lined the corridor and the queen spoke
to quite a few of us as she walked past
she was really interested in what we did
and thanked us a lovely lady
that is just absolutely typical of how
people describe interactions with the
queen
she was really interested in what she
did what we did and thanked us
over 70 years i can't even begin to
imagine the number of conversations
handshakes school and hospital openings
state occasions visits by dignitaries
the tours abroad 70 years of unwavering
service to this country and her people
always interested always smiling always
polite
and in the age of celebrity where to be
famous is to be of interest to others
the most famous woman in the world was
more interested in others
what drove her was a sense of duty and
as others have said her wish to keep
that promise she made at just 21 to
devote her life to our service
our promise solemnly made and solemnly
kept
why does that stir such strong sentiment
in us i think because we know our
failings as humans are often rooted in
self-interest of one kind or another our
desire to be important or admired to
achieve things to be celebrated to think
mostly of ourselves and our family and
friends
when someone extends the bonds of
service to an entire nation as the queen
did
to people she would never meet or know
when we see someone embodying the best
of what it means to be human the
opposite of self-interest i think that
inspires us it gives us a glimpse of
what we are all capable of
that is why i admire the queen
but as she embodied us the millions who
undertake acts of community and
voluntary service embody her as well
the scout leader the children's sunday
league football coach the park runner
marathon steward the parish councillor
the samaritan's helpline volunteer the
little pit group member all follow her
example
and now i look at that final picture of
her taken this week and in retrospect i
think there was a deeper meaning to that
final laptop service than i realized at
the time
right at the end of her life
when perhaps for the rest of us our own
comfort would come first
her majesty was absolutely determined
again to put her promise to us first
one last desire to help her people and
her prime minister entering another
period of difficulty and uncertainty
to take that first step towards it with
her yet again at our side
now rest in peace your majesty god save
the king
richard bacon
mr deputy speaker it's an honor to offer
my tribute to her late majesty on behalf
of the constituents of south norfolk and
personally
i won't resign from anything that our
scottish friends have said about her
majesty's great love of scotland
and i think perhaps it may
not even be a coincidence it may have
been
by choice that her majesty chose to
spend her last days in the place
she loved the most
but she also loved norfolk
and my honourable friend the member for
northwest norfolk spoke of sandringham
in this debate yesterday
soon after her late majesty's accession
in 1952 the queen became patron of the
royal norfolk agricultural association
in south norfolk which hosts
the royal norfolk show one of england's
premier agricultural events the queen
attended the show in person in 1981 and
again in 1986
his majesty the king as the prince of
wales has twice attended the royal
norfolk show within the last two decades
and i was privileged as the local member
of parliament to meet him on both
occasions and indeed all the children of
her late majesty have also visited the
royal norfolk show as have other members
of the royal family we were delighted to
welcome the princess royal just over two
months ago
farmers and food producers across the
county of norfolk deeply appreciate the
commitment of her late majesty and the
wider royal family to food and farming a
commitment over many decades
long before the words
food security were even thought of
the queen visited south norfolk in
february 2002 to open the headquarters
of norfolk constabulary in wyndham and
again in february 2004 to open the north
canada university hospital
i particularly remember the queen's
visit to the new police headquarters
when i was honoured to meet her i was
standing next to the chief constable in
the receiving line the then lord
lieutenant said timothy coleman
introduced the queen to the chief
constable with the words
your chief constable man
and i suddenly reflected that he was
indeed her chief constable just as it
was her royal navy her courts her civil
service that this parliament was sitting
under her authority with our mace as
that symbol
and that the system of constitutional
monarchy which we have evolved is a
pearl of great price
precisely because it allows us to change
and at the same time
offers constancy perfectly embodied in
her late majesty
on behalf of my constituents in south
norfolk i say
thank you to her late majesty for all
her extraordinary service
offer my deepest condolences to the
royal family
and also look forward with confidence
and optimism to the new era
before us may the queen rest in peace
god save the king
laura trott
thank you mrs deputy speaker and it's
been a privilege to be part of some of
the incredible tributes that we appeared
here today
um
her majesty touched the lies and hearts
of everyone in seven oaks and swamny
when i went to go and sign the book of
condolence yesterday it was full of
incredible stories uh and and tributes
but i thought i would reflect today on
her majesty's relationship with one of
my more famous former constituents
her first prime minister sir winston
churchill
describing her on the day of her
coronation sir winston said her majesty
was a lady who we respect because she is
our queen
and who we love
because she is herself
a sentiment i think that is shared
across the house here today
chartwell kurtz country home for more
than 40 years
is filled with his most cherished
possessions
however in my most recent trip there one
photo really stood out and it's been on
my mind since we heard the statement
that we all dreaded from buckingham
palace on thursday evening
in churchill's bedroom amongst many
pictures of horses um you will find a
framed photograph of sir winston on
bucky and palace's balcony on ve day he
hung it there himself
in the photograph he is standing next to
the then king and queen and princess
elizabeth and princess margaret
the photograph is signed by all four
members of the royal family and
celebrates one of the most important
moments of churchill's life and career
as well as in the history of britain
however for churchill to hang this
picture on his bedroom wall his inner
sanctum shows just how important it was
to him
the photo symbolizes not only victory
against tyranny but the vital role that
the royal family played in his wartime
leadership and the strength of the
relationship between parliament and the
crown
a relationship that has never been ever
been more evident i think in the past
few days
on behalf of everyone in seven oaks and
swanny i say thank you mom for
everything we owe you so much
may she rest in peace
god save the king
thank you mr speaker it's a pleasure to
follow my honourable friend from seven
oaks and that was a warm and glowing
tribute of which we've heard many over
the last 48 hours many tributes
anecdotes and indeed many many recurring
themes and i'm aware mr speaker of your
guidance and the guidance of uh mr
deputy speaker um on uh timing
and indeed repetition and it's it's on
the latter i fear i may have an issue
because
i rise to speak after my honorable
friend from milton keynes south who
essentially gave the speech that i
wanted to give but
just better so
i'm grateful for him remaining in his
place
possibly to see what i come up with
so with the house's indulgence i might
just share
a personal reflection
it is
a huge honor
a a genuine privilege to serve
her majesty the queen
in this place
as a member of parliament
and as member of parliament for milton
keynes north
and it is a privilege
to rise today to pay tribute
to our late queen
on behalf of the people of milton keynes
north
this summer
her majesty the queen in her jubilee
year
bestowed city safe status on milton
keynes
and that means so much to the people of
milton keynes
and
people from outside militaries often say
well what does it mean what exactly does
it mean to the people of milton keynes
and indeed
it's quite baffling and hard to explain
we got this letter on behalf of her
majesty
which doesn't quite explain what it does
mean but it does go at some length to
explain what it doesn't mean so
in lieu of a speech i thought i might
read some of that
i'm delighted to inform you that i was
able to
make a favorable recommendation for
milton keynes to receive
city status
and that this has been approved by her
majesty the queen
as you will know
this honor does not confer any
additional functions
funding
all powers
nor does it confer upon the mayor or
promised the title of lord mayor or lord
provost
the grant of this privilege being an
entirely separate matter however it is
this rare honour
granted by the queen and given the
standard a number of applications
was very high
you should be very proud
we are proud we are so proud thank you
your majesty
it is an honor that goes well beyond any
of those things in that list it is in
our souls i'm proud to have served the
queen and i'm proud to serve our new
king
long live the king
mike wood
thank you mr deputy speaker and it's a
privilege to pay tribute on behalf of
people in dudley south to our much loved
late monarch queen elizabeth and to
offer our condolences to his majesty the
king and the royal family
there is a poem popular in funerals that
begins do not weep
that i have gone but rejoice that i have
been it seems appropriate
for while we grieve for the loss of a
beloved sovereign we rejoice at all that
she has given to us
to our country and to the commonwealth
whether through providence or good
fortune we are surely blessed
to be granted uh such a selfless service
from one of the world's great leaders
for so very long
but it is not just her longevity that
she will surely be remembered in the
words of my writing friend the former
prime minister as elizabeth the great
long after we are all gone
the late majesty guided our country from
rebuilding after the ravages of war with
rationing still in place
into a modern 21st century society
she took a disintegrating empire and
created a strong commonwealth family of
nations
she was integral to our national
identities and embodied so much of what
we like to think of as particularly
british values and qualities
she united communities and helped to
heal divisions between countries and
between governments
queen elizabeth will be remembered for
her contribution to every part of our
national life
because she not only reigned over us but
was there alongside us
she celebrated with us during times of
national jubilation
and she provided comfort and constancy
during times of great challenge
she met more people than possibly
anybody else in history and for all who
met her
it was an experience they never forgot
her late majesty visited briley hill
now part of my constituency in 1957 not
long after the start of her long reign
it was the first of three visits to
dudley borough and 65 years later
people still have vivid memories of the
day that the queen came to town
more recently as a student barrister i
was privileged to meet her during a
training weekend at the westminster
estates
and i can only hope that the prime
minister and those other ministers
were more coherent when they were sworn
of the privy council than i suspect i
was
that day
she has been such a central part of our
national life for so long at the
standing here even now
it is difficult to truly accept that she
is gone
may she rest in peace and rise in glory
her late majesty queen elizabeth his
majesty the king and the royal family
will always remain in our thoughts in
our prayers and in our hearts
god save the king
kevin holland
thank you mr deputy speaker it is a
great privilege
on behalf of myself my family
um my mum as a adoring fan of the queen
and the royal family would have been
particularly proud and my constituents
to pay tribute to
and pair my their majesty the queen and
pay my respects to her family
sadly we never truly appreciate what we
have until it is gone
and there is no fine illustration of
that than the passing of her majesty the
queen
she has been such a constant presence
that
throughout the inevitable peaks and
valleys of life
it seems she'd always be there
a golden thread woven through each of
our lives
she has though
always been there for us
as strong and steadfast has their
beloved highlands
seemingly faultless i'm sure she would
argue with that but seemingly seemingly
faultless
infallible but accepting
understanding
forgiving of fallibility
she was truly the best of us
an exceptional sense of public service
duty
responsibility and selflessness
combined with good humor hope and
optimism
she made us proud to be british
yet she herself was always humble
unassuming
and deeply interested
in everything and everyone around her
it was never about her
the finest tribute and greatest legacy
we could ever give is to follow her lead
to be better versions of ourselves
more selfless
more charitable
more optimistic
more forgiving
less judgmental
in her memory
perhaps it's understandable that we
didn't fully appreciate what we had
so now let's appreciate what we have
god bless her
and god save the king
jacob
thank you uh mr deputy speaker i rise
with sadness to send my condolences and
those of my constituents to his majesty
the king and to the entire royal family
it's an honour to pay a tribute to her
late majesty the queen today for all she
did for my community and for the country
over the last few days i've read many
memories from the people of t side about
the times they've met her on her visits
like at t's dock in 1997 or pali park in
1993
the charity issues championed like the
rnli the scouts and the girl guards or
the horses that she raced at red carace
course where she won that twi where she
twice won the zetland cup
for myself i never had the honor of
meeting her late majesty but i have a
wonderful portrait of her given to me by
my mum in my office from when she
visited middlesbrough on her first visit
to t side as queen
it's a photograph of her in a car
driving towards the ici-wilton site on a
warm summer day in june 1956
where she was met by chemists and
industrialists who were at the forefront
of british innovation and chemical
processing
at 3 pm that day the royal standard flew
over wilton site as her late majesty was
shown a range of products from molding
powders and synthetic fibers to perspex
glasses
more than 60 years later at 3pm i
remember gathering around a tv on
christmas day on that very fir same site
as my shift pause work briefly to watch
her christmas
message
much has changed
in those decades on wilton indeed much
had changed in britain
but with one constant
a sovereign who over seven decades
demonstrated the values of duty and
public service
a remarkable woman who was an amazing
mother grandmother and great-grandmother
and as we've heard from others a trusted
counselor guide and friend
it was her christianity that formed the
guarding principles of her life and the
example that she set
import into paul's letter to the
galatians he describes the fruits of the
spirit as love joy peace
patience kindness
goodness
gentleness faithfulness and self-control
these are the words by which we knew our
queen
she was a monarch like no other who gave
everything for our country and as she
said in her christmas message in 1957
i cannot lead you into battle i do not
give you laws or administer justice
but i can do something else
i can give you my heart and my devotion
to these old islands and to all the
peoples of our brotherhood of nations
that she did
she truly was elizabeth the great
god bless our late queen
may you rest in peace and god save the
king
said deputy speaker and in forming my
comments today i thought it'd be nine
possible really to articulate what late
manchester united queen meant
to me and to my constituents and to
members not right on the board of
members across these houses but as i've
sat here today it's been quite clear
that that actually i think her legacy
has inspired us to be able to articulate
exactly what she meant and
you know for
for my constituents in the black country
she was that continuity
now her late manchester visited the
three towns i represent at various
different times she visited oldbury in
1957 as part of the uh the black country
tour that my little friend from dudley
sounds referred to
and she visited wednesbury in 1962 and
there is the incredible image of
her late majesty waving to the crowds
from wentworth town hall
as they came to greet her there and she
visited tipton in 1994 as part of her
final tour of the black country where
she also included sites such as dudley
castle
and
for my constituents
she
embodied that continuity of time and
massive change you know during that
period of time mr debbie speaker we saw
slum clearances we saw industries
disappear but we also saw new people
welcomed into our community
we also saw our communities change for
the better we also welcome that
diversity that the black country is so
known for today and so communities live
side by side with one another embodying
the example that she set particularly
with her work within the commonwealth to
encourage communities and peoples to
come together to share what make to
share those things that bind us together
to share those things that unite us and
to live by that message and it was
embodied know much more so that during
the platinum jubilee
where i had the pleasure of joining so
many different communities
and street parties particularly in
tipton where uh people noticing their
member of parliament engaging some sort
of dodgy dancing that i can't quite
remember exactly how it went but
nonetheless embodied the passion that
those communities had my communities had
in what her manchester late majesty
meant
and as we move forward out of this
elizabethan age into a new carolina age
we need to ensure that the principles
that
he late managed to live by are embodied
further and as we look towards his
majesty the king we we look at the
legacy that he also has as he comes into
this role of progress and protects our
environment of looking forward a visit
of his focus on technology of bringing
in
new ways of working of new ways of
viewing the world and i am
and i mourn the loss of that elizabethan
age but that sadness
within that sadness there's also hope mr
deputy speaker as we look forward and i
know that my communities the great
communities of the black country who
have looked towards her late majesty
with that sense of continuity and that
sense of pride will embrace his majesty
now as he comes forward
what it leads me to say is thank you
ma'am for everything that you've done
and for the communities
that you
were so admired by
and to say god save the king
anthony higginbotham
yeah thank you mr deputy speaker it is
both a privilege under sadness to speak
today to pay tribute to her late majesty
the queen
personally
on behalf of my family and on behalf of
my constituents in burnley paddian
and all of the villages and parishes
that make up our borough
thursday was a day that in our minds
we knew would come
but in our hearts
we had hoped would not
the death of her late majesty the queen
was something that would happen one day
but never that day
but on thursday that day came
we will all have our own thoughts
feelings
emotions and memories of the queen
it didn't matter
if you had never met her
or you'd met her many times
you felt close to her
we all knew her personally
she was part of our lives
and we knew her because we knew her
ideals
her values her sense of duty and mostly
her irrevocable unwavering
devotion and love for our country and
for all of us
and this was always reciprocated
her incredible impact on our lives and
our country meant that often we were
able to forget
just how important she was to us
in the last few days we've remembered
the realization of just how much she did
to steer this great ship that is the
united kingdom and the commonwealth
that
and the impact she had on each of us
is what causes our grief and sorrow now
through her many addresses to our nation
she was our guiding light she asked us
to focus on what was important
when we needed focusing
she brought us cheer when we needed
cheering up
she gave us hope and wisdom when we felt
down
and she encouraged us to reflect when
life got too busy and we struggled to
see perspective
and for most of us
she was the only monarch we had ever
known
during her reign she made three trips to
my constituency
the first was in 1955
when she told the nation as our new
monarch
the second in 1968
when she traveled through padium to
visit saint peter's church in berlin
and the third and most recent
was in 2012 for the diamond jubilee
on each occasion everyone came out
it was one photo taken during the 1968
visit
captioned by the civic trust
that i want to read out
a sea of faces
and seemingly hundreds of waving union
jacks greeted the queen
the crowds were spilling onto the
roadway
turning in trafalgar street
and it was more than evident that
burnley was turning out in full force
there was only just sufficient road
for the royal motorcade to pass
mr speaker such was our affection and
admiration for her both as queen
and as duke of lancaster
as we pledge ourselves and our
unwavering loyalty
to his majesty the king
who we know will lead us just as ably
all it remains left for me to say
is mom thank you for all you did
may you rest in peace
god save the king
robbie moore
thank you mr deputy speaker and i rise
to speak on behalf of each and every one
of my constituents across keithley and
elkly to pay tribute to the late queen
elizabeth ii
someone who we all had so much affection
and love for and admired
with the rest of the nation
and i want to along with my constituents
share our deepest sorrow with that of
the nation and of course send our
deepest sympathy to our new sovereign
king charles and the remainder of the
royal family
queen elizabeth was a woman of great
kindness and faith an incredible
inspiration to us all
her dedication devotion and commitment
throughout her entire life to public
duty to our great nation and the
commonwealth was unparalleled
and of course her majesty provided us
all with great stability and reassurance
and carried out her reign with enormous
amounts of love coupled with incredible
humility
love which was there for us all
and the reality of it is
all of us have grown up knowing nothing
else but the queen being there at the
very heart of our nation at the soul of
our nation
we welcomed her into our homes every
christmas as we watched her give her
annual christmas address and we looked
towards her for leadership and
resilience through some of the darker
moments in our nation's history
and of course we celebrated her
and with her at national events and it
was only earlier this year when we all
came together as a country to celebrate
her marvelous
70-year platinum jubilee
street parties happened right across my
constituency church services school
children
sending posters of
that they'd designed and drawn um of her
majesty the sense of um
strength for her was huge
so it is no wonder that all of us
felt that we knew the queen and that we
had a personal relationship with the
queen and we had a personal
understanding of what she was all about
and what she stood for
decency
now i have never met the queen but as a
new member of parliament coming to this
place i will never forget leaving this
chamber for the state opening of
parliament and walking down to the other
place and
the hairs on the back of your neck
standing up and the goosebumps uh coming
before you because you could see the
glimpse of her majesty sitting on the
throne a moment that i will always
cherish
the sense of loss has been strong
and we have seen that through the
presence of those standing outside
buckingham palace
for decades
her majesty has been a cool-headed
constant steward of our great nation she
has been our nation's soul
so your majesty may i simply say on
behalf of each and every one of my
constituents across keithley and ilkley
thank you
thank you for your service
may you rest in peace
and rise in glory
god save the king
mark fletcher
thank you mr deputy speaker it is with
some humility that i speak today on
behalf of the people and communities
across the bolzova constituency in which
i place on record our thanks to her late
majesty for all that she did for our
nation and our sincerest condolences to
the royal family you are very much in
our thoughts and prayers at this moment
in time
grief is the price we pay for love has
been
often quoted over the last two days and
boy did we love her we saw how much we
loved her in the platinum jubilee
celebrations earlier this year it was
the greatest weekend of my life it was
the greatest honor to tour a
constituency i grew up with a father who
told me of his stories of playing in
1977 playing with his band at the silver
jubilee celebrations and although his uh
rock star status has uh has a lot has
gone and he is now a financial advisor
those stories
have stayed with me and i saw
the unity that her majesty can bring in
a world in which we are deeply cynical
and we are encouraged to find our
differences with each other that weekend
managed to bring us together
and perhaps it will be the final time
the nation will feel so together
thursday
is a day that i think few of us will
forget i think it is one of those
moments where we will all know where we
were at that time and
many of us gathered in strangers
downstairs there were members of all
parties there were house staff there and
we we waited with tremendous
uh anticipation and sadness we were all
very emotional even some of the
journalists that were present seemed to
have emotions at that time
and as the news
came out of the the television
tears
were were everywhere and the image that
stays with me
is of the doorkeepers their tear-stained
eyes many of whom represented
our country in our armed forces they
represented her majesty and i saw the
sadness that was reflected within them
and i have to say i thank all of the
house staff for all they've done to make
sure that we are able to sit today and
everything that is going on at this
moment is incredibly important to
remember what they have done
but
that moment will live with us
for the rest of time and it has been
suggested
by the chair and by others uh in this
debate that perhaps we have um
often repeated what has been said one or
two members may have made similar points
but i think if there were to be a word
cloud of what has been spoken of today
perhaps the most important thing we
speak of is duty
we are public servants in this house we
swear an oath as the very first official
thing we do to the sovereign we are
servants to the people that we represent
in our constituency but we pale in
comparison to the duty that her majesty
provided this land
her duty helped to unify us it helped to
humble us it helped to remind us of
greater times when things were difficult
it helped to encourage us
her majesty
will never be replaced in a way in our
hearts
but she will
live on forever
god save the king
it goes
thank you mr deputy mr speaker uh
it is an honor to rise on behalf of the
people of stockton south to offer our
deepest condolences to the royal family
and pay tribute to our longest-serving
and greatest moniker since 1952 our
nation has changed beyond all
recognition the people of 1952 would
recognize very little of modern society
with the exception of one thing her
majesty queen elizabeth ii
for 70 years our gracious sovereign lady
has provided stability continuity and a
sense of reassurance
to millions across this nation and to
billions across the world
the queen has a special place in the
hearts of people of stockton
and during the jubilee weekend we saw
communities come together with huge
celebrations in my part of the world
many sharing their stories of the
queen's visits to stockton in 1956
in 1977 and most recently in 2012 when
she opened our our white watercourse
a lady of saw small stature but with
huge personality and presence
she was someone every world leader
wanted to be seen with
15 prime ministers 14 presidents of the
united states and many other leaders
the queen saw them come
and she saw them go
while they were able to step down
walk away and retire her majesty never
had such a luxury the vow she made in
1947 to dedicate her whole life to
service was as true then as it was at
the end
her majesty showed that age is but a
number
for me the queen was basically britannia
a titan in her own right a proud
defender of the united kingdom and the
commonwealth and our true strength and
stare
not only
has she seen her nation engage in combat
over the seven decades of her reign
she herself saw active service in world
war ii
that image of her majesty behind the
wheel of a wagon in her uniform is one
that can only make you proud proud of
her
and proud to be british
today in every city every town every
village and in every street of our
nation we all mourn the loss of our
queen of our guiding light of our
nation's rock the best of britain
we must never forget the incredible
uh the incredible example her majesty
has set
on behalf of the people of stockton
south i offer her our thanks for our
incredible life of service
god bless her majesty may you rest in
peace and rise in glory god save the
king
robert
thank you mr speaker
when i was 20 years old
my grandma suddenly and very seriously
fell ill
she was undergoing emergency surgery and
we all knew that the chances of survival
were very slim
i vividly remember that long day waiting
for the bad news
on thursday
as the country collectively held its
breath
waiting for word from balmoral
i found myself
thinking of my grandma and that long day
those years ago
and that's because
for many many reasons her majesty
was a grandmother to the entire nation a
constant in all of our lives
that familiar
smiling reassuring and comforting
presence
i've never had an audience
with the queen
i don't have any
moving or amusing anecdotes to share
many other members who are far more
eloquent than i have already set out in
great length
her many remarkable qualities and i will
not repeat them again to the house now
i will simply say
we are all diminished by her loss
yet her memory is our blessing
mr speaker
on behalf of the people of high peak
i want to set on record
our deep felt gratitude and love to our
late sovereign and to express our
heartfelt condolences
to his majesty king charles iii
and to affirm that we remain his most
loyal subjects
may her majesty rest in peace and rise
in glory
god save the king yeah yeah i love firth
thank you mr speaker the city of south
end and leon c also wished to pay
tribute to her majesty the late queen
elizabeth ii quite simply one of the
most exceptional women the world has
ever known as one constituent put it to
me the best sequel we could ever have
hoped for
like many i never had the opportunity to
meet her majesty but my father-in-law
shared with me a lovely story
he was part of the battle management
group for the first gulf war and was
hosting the queen in high wycombe where
they were in constant communication with
the front line
walking down the desks the queen stopped
to look over the
shoulder of one of the operators to ask
what he was doing and was amused to see
written on the screen mr speaker sorry
jim
got to go queen just arrived
now just imagine his horror when the
next message that appeared on his screen
was p
dot dot dot
off for stop pull the other one
the queen did not miss a beat
chuckling away
she said tell your friend jim
i am here
and i wish him the very best of luck
and doesn't that sum up uh the queen for
us they're with our troops even at a
distance at the in their hour of need
always seeing the fun
and always seeing the best in everyone
and everybody she saw instantly that at
the other end of the line was someone
who nobody knew but who was putting
their life at risk for the rest of us
and her priority was to say thank you
and wish him luck
but as well as 15 prime ministers 14 u.s
presidents and seven popes
the queen also saw four members of
parliament for south end west
when she ascended the throne chips
shannon was our local mp and described
her as regal and quite perfect
my predecessor sir david was knighted by
the queen at windsor castle he described
it as the best day of his life
in 1999 in carnival red the queen lit up
our seafront delighting thousands by
walking the entire golden mile with
philip beside her
but with characteristic interest in
sound finances she also insisted on
visiting our local customs and excise
office and of course earlier this year
she granted
south end city status for which we are
eternally grateful but it is her values
that i most want to give thanks for
tonight and they are perfectly summed up
by the words she chose to speak
at the end of her coronation day the
penultimate devotional prayer it's very
short
lord
thou has filled my cup
with thy goodness to overflowing
with a humble spirit
and a thankful heart
i commit myself to thy care
and will lay me down in peace and take
my rest
on behalf of everyone in south end
rest now your majesty in eternal peace
god save the king
robin miller
thank you mr speaker it is
my sad duty to convey on behalf of the
constituents of abercromwy our deepest
constant condolences to his majesty and
to the royal family in their loss
but also a privilege to express our
gratitude for the life of her late
majesty
to king charles to the new prince and
princess of wales and their families we
offer every prayer and good wish
for them and the important roles they
will play in the days and years ahead
i will not restate again the many
tributes played in this place to her
late majesty
of her character
the impact of her service
and the affection for her in all parts
of her realm
abba conway is no exception she visited
on many occasions including the
nationalist edward in 1963
on her silver jubilee tour and notably
for this engineer to open the conway
tunnel in 1991
it will be no surprise that a recent
class platinum jubilee was marked across
abba conway with enthusiasm many events
street parties and much good cheer the
sun shone the rain fell
but whether it was dog shows and damn
bunting or coffee cake and coronation
chicken sandwiches
communities were united
they were open armed in celebration and
appreciation of her second seven decades
of service
but today those communities are united
in mourning
and it is books of condolence that are
open across the constituency
yesterday in one village driving to the
station i saw a simple bouquet of fresh
flowers had been laid out a quiet
personal gesture of grief
no doubt repeated countless times and
ways across the land
mr speaker i did not have the honor of
welcoming her late majesty to
abercrombie
i do not have a story to share
like so many mine has been the simple
privilege of being her loyal subject
a beneficiary of her lifetime of public
service
we have this in common however
we have both professed a christian faith
and when the christians course is run
our fond hope
our great expectation
is to be welcomed by our heavenly father
with the words well done
good and faithful servant
i cannot think of a higher tribute
or a greater reward
for her majesty
may she rest in peace
and may god save the king yeah they're
in heaven
thank you mr speaker i'd like to echo
the sentiments of many of my colleagues
here today
it's always a special moment in this
chamber when all parties unite together
and speak with one voice
unifying those divided is just one of
the countless qualities that made our
queen
the ruler that she was
my thoughts and the thoughts of my
constituents in broxto are with the
royal family at this time
the queen was loved and admired not only
throughout great britain but across the
commonwealth and i know that a sense of
loss and mourning will be felt through
all corners of the world
on a personal note
on more than one occasion in my life i
swore true allegiance to her majesty the
queen
the first was in 1987 at the age of 18
whilst joining the armed forces
and of course more recently in 2019
whilst being sworn in as a member of
this house
on those occasions i felt incredibly
proud to be able to serve my country and
most importantly the queen
i was honoured to be invited to meet her
majesty while serving in the royal air
force the queen smiled and shook my hand
it was one of the privileges of my life
and a memory i always will hold dear her
smile no matter who you were put you
instantly at ease the rarest and most
wonderful quality for anyone to hold
as has been mentioned by some of my
honorable and right honourable
colleagues
in 1947 the queen stated
i declare before you all
that my whole life whether it be long or
short
shall be devoted to your service and the
service of our great imperial family to
which we all belong
she came to embody those words
throughout her 70 years of service and
displayed a sense of duty to the united
kingdom and the commonwealth unlike any
scene before
over the last 70 years at times of
struggle and loss
we as a nation always looked to the
queen
she has given comfort in times of sorrow
continuity in times of uncertainty and
hope
in our times of doubt
during the pandemic when many of us were
separated from our loved ones she
reminded our nation that we will meet
again
she embodied the strength that we needed
and inspired us all to carry on
i'd like to end by offering wishes of
success and prosperity
to our new king charles iii
the country and the commonwealth are
behind you and with you
on behalf of myself and my constituents
in brockton may the queen rest in peace
and god save the king
james
mr speaker i rise with profound
reverence to pay tribute to her majesty
the queen
ours is not the reason why but this is
the moment that we feared would happen
as the bedrock in our lives of so long
the loss of this most adored global icon
is deep palpable and impossible to put
into words
we have heard many superlatives perhaps
uniquely all of these are perfect as she
was magnificent steadfast inspirational
a devoted mother and simply the best
but the two words that i want to focus
on are service and love
when her majesty went up a princess
and came down a queen at treetops in
1952
she was aware of the service that lay
ahead not only as a head of state in the
commonwealth but also as head of the
armed forces
having already become colonel in chief
of the grenadier guards at the age of 16
the royal navy and the rural air force
would soon bear her standard
it's impossible too not to mention the
household division they're all engineers
and so many of the other army units for
whom she was also one of their own
and i can't think of a single person for
whom that famous mantra of serve to lead
could be more perfectly applied
her soldiers as sailors and aviators
truly loved her and rightly so
having led soldiers myself on several
operational tours i can tell you from
experience that servicemen and women do
not proudly serve their country or even
pay the ultimate sacrifice because the
prevailing government asks it of them
nor do they do it to follow orders out
of camaraderie or even a sense of glory
but because of service to the crown
the glue that actually binds military
service at sea land and air is the
democracy the freedom and the
sovereignty of this great nation and the
monarch who presides over it
in my own constituency of bracknell the
royal military academy at sandhurst
proudly occupies its leafy corner of
berkshire
three times a year the queen or her
representative would come to her
sovereigns parade where officer cadet's
commission into the army i can recall my
own commissioning in 1992
as if it was yesterday and the queen was
always a regular feature smiling in the
achievements of others
and who could forget that fine day in
2006 when she attended prince william's
commissioning parade alongside her
beloved prince philip
king charles the queen consort and of
course cadet prince harry wales
the famous painting from that day still
hangs imposingly above the famous steps
at old college
and beyond sandhurst her majesty has a
wider association with the people of
bracknell
most recently she opened the lexicon
shopping centre in 2018
visited wellington college in 2009 the
transport research laboratory in 1995
the victoria's school in 1994 and the
lookout center in 1991
in fact she formally visited my
constituency from neighboring windsor on
at least 20 other occasions during her
life
to be in no doubt queen elizabeth ii
loved her country
she loved the commonwealth her family
her people and all those who came into
contact with her
she was also loved by them
and the people of bratman will always be
proud to have known her
lastly if i may i visited the lexicon in
blackball yesterday to sign the book of
condolence near to where she'd opened it
four years earlier
i spoke to constituents who were
saddened by her passing
and some i met were visibly overcome by
grief and loss
uncertain for their own future
and mr speaker you know what it's okay
not to feel okay at this profound time
it's okay to mourn her passing as well
as celebrate her life
it's okay to feel a sense of foreboding
and it's okay to feel wretched as the
queen was very special
so i want to finish by saying one thing
above all else on behalf of the good
people of bracknell crow thorne vince
hampstead sandhurst working and without
and beyond your majesty thank you
god save the
thank you mr queen
and it is indeed a great honour but also
with great sorrow that i stand in this
place today on behalf of the people of
hartlepool to express our profound
sadness for the passing of our most
gracious sovereign lady queen elizabeth
ii
the queen was many things a head of
state a leader a mother of realms and of
hers a daughter of history and humanity
she was also a warm humorous and
understanding country woman a lover of
horses and dogs passions and interests i
share with her late majesty
in the equestrian and dog loving
community when the sad but inevitable
time comes when we must say goodbye to a
much-loved four-legged companion
we always want that to be a time of
their choosing
at the end of a good summer
in their favorite meadow or basket by
the fire it is also a passing we wish
for ourselves
in my sadness at hearing of the news of
the queen's passing i also felt solace
in knowing that she left this earthly
dominion at the end of a glorious summer
before the cold of winter starts to bite
in a favorite place of her own a castle
of happy memories
no one will forget that last taken
public image of her fulfilling her final
duty
smiling in her kilt and cardigan trusty
handbag perhaps containing a marmalade
sandwich
over her heart hover of her arm a
country woman by her fire
throughout history we have heard of the
great moments of monarchy being
accompanied by celestial events
such as edward iv sun in splendor
the appearance of three sons rising in
the sky before the battle of mortimer's
cross
he was father to elizabeth of york
grandmother of elizabeth the first
the rainbow queen who presided over a
golden age
how fitting that the announcement of the
passing of our great and noble queen
elizabeth ii daughter of another
elizabeth of york
rainbows appeared in the sky over her
palaces
the two elizabethan ages entwined
through time proclaiming the new dawn of
the reign of king charles iii
as he pledged to continue the same duty
as his mother before him
so shall we all in this place swear a
new oath of allegiance to him
may elizabeth of blessed memory rest in
peace
god save the king
rob roberts
thank you mr speaker i rise with both
immense sadness and immense gratitude
for being able to contribute to this
series of tributes to her late majesty
queen elizabeth ii both on my own behalf
and on behalf of the people of delhi
who've been delighted to welcome her on
visits to the constituency many times
over the years
it is an honor to be able to follow such
outstanding speeches that we've heard
over the last two days
mr speaker nothing can measure the
impact of a person than the way we feel
about them when they pass away
we feel an imaginable grief at the
passing of a parent a close family
member or a lifelong friend and it's
astonishing to think that people feel
those same feelings that the passing of
someone
that like me they probably never met
such was the impact of her late majesty
she was the epitome of discretion
humility and grace
and whilst we were honored to have her
as our head of state for so long in
truth i believe that she felt that the
honor was hers
in being afforded the privilege of being
our queen for hers was a life of duty of
sacrifice and of diligent responsibility
to be that beacon that we all look
towards in the most challenging times
she never took that duty lightly or
casually
the omnipresent figure that bound us all
together
providing a link to times gone by
and to those people we've sadly lost
along the way
people have said many times we will
never see her like again mr speaker i
hope we do i really hope we do because
we all need that figurehead
the shining light the ubiquitous
inspiration to do all we can
in the service of others
one of my old teachers told me a while a
while ago if someone's already said it
perfectly don't be so arrogant to assume
you can do it better
so in the words
of the poet david harkness
you can shed tears that she's gone or
you can smile that she lived you can
close your eyes and pray that she'll
come back
or you can open your eyes and see all
that she has left
your heart can be empty because you
can't see her or you can be full of the
love that you've shared
you can turn your back on tomorrow and
live yesterday
or you can be happy for tomorrow because
of yesterday
you can remember her and only that she
is gone
or you can cherish her memory and let it
live on you can cry and close your mind
be empty and turn your back
or you can do what she would want
smile open your eyes love
and go on
mr speaker our grief is palpable the
void in our lives both unexpected and
painful and we mourn her loss
may she rest well reunited with her
beloved husband
god save the new prince and princess of
wales
and god save the king
bradley
yeah thank you mr speaker many
colleagues in the course of this debate
have said that they will always remember
where they were at the time when the
news broke about her late majesty's
death but i certainly will i was stood
by a football pitch watching the under
sixes uh in my uh in nottinghamshire and
i've been let off the day for the tour
of britain passing through my
constituency and as the deluge clear and
it was a deluge and the news of her
majesty's passing rippled around the
parents stood on the side of the pitch
as my honourable friend mighty paul said
a rainbow appeared in the sky it really
was an incredible moment as that emotion
rippled
around those parents who were assembled
there just as i subsequently watched it
ripple round this chamber on the
television
i'm not sure what more i can really say
mr speaker coming right at the two end
of two days of tributes to her late
majesty queen elizabeth ii with so many
wonderful contributions particularly
from those senior colleagues and privy
councillors who might claim to have
known her and spent time with her and
having heard those uh personal stories
and anecdotes that spoke to her charm
her character to her humor and of course
in the right hand remember for
maidenhead her firm commitment to the
three-second rule
despite the fact that so much has been
said already mr speaker i felt duty
bound to speak on the half of my
constituents in mansfield and to lay a
floral tribute at the palace on their
behalf
and of course in my role at
nottinghamshire county council i also
have a civic role in a number of events
this week there are many and i think mr
speaker these events the proclamation
tomorrow at memorial events throughout
the week and next weekend are an
important chants for the public who are
mourning her losses if it were part of
their own family
to do what we are doing now to come
together to share stories and memories
and to be part of this transition from
one era to the next
we've been looking enough to host her
majesty in mansfield though admittedly
in the 1970s so i must admit i didn't
quite manage to get there myself but the
town still celebrates and remembers when
she came to open mansfield library all
those years ago
she opened the queen's medical center of
course i think made at least six visits
to nottingham two throughout her reign
most recently for the diamond jubilee
and everyone who saw her on those visits
and who met her will remember the
occasion among their most treasured
memories
in many ways the one constant in our
lives see so much change and chaos the
manchester queen elizabeth has played a
huge role in all of our lives i
personally have been struck by her love
for her family not least the way she
wrapped her arms around her
grandchildren in 1997 after the death of
princess diana and how she shouldered
that grief and those burdens whilst
protecting them even in what was perhaps
the most difficult time for our monarchy
during her reign
mr speaker the end of one era is also
the start of another and king charles
iii now shoulders that responsibility my
heart goes out to him and his family as
they seek to provide stability and
continuity whilst also dealing with
their private creek in the eye of so
much public interest
i hope that the heartfelt sadness and
outpouring of affection from the public
here and around the globe gives him
heart and gives him strength
i was lucky enough to meet the king then
the prince of wales earlier this year we
discussed some of his charity work how
good housing can help to tackle
inequalities and he was warm energetic
and incredibly knowledgeable
just as we've heard in our recollections
of the queen i know and trust that he'll
continue with the same sense of duty and
public service that he's learned from
her late majesty over so many years i
hope that she's reunited with philip and
that she may rest in peace god save the
king
thank you mr speaker i rise with a heavy
heart to contribute tonight and pay
tribute to her late majesty the queen i
want to start by expressing my deepest
sympathies for his majesty the king and
the entire royal family from my family
and the loyal constituents of wilden
a late queen her
her majesty queen elizabeth ii was loved
and respected from the north of my
constituency the villages of wisdom and
aries down south to the towns of helsham
she was adored for her duty
loyalty and leadership here in the uk
and the commonwealth and across the
world i want to share the words of a
particular constituent who lives in
fletching
libby buchanan
libby is 99 years old
she has lived in the reigns of five
monarchs from george v to king charles
iii
she said to me how deeply blessed she
felt to have lived through the reign of
queen elizabeth
sometimes libby told me the changes
experienced in the world over the
queen's reign were bewildering yet the
queen never changed
she was always there
a constant gentle and ever-present light
a light which has now gone out
but as libby said to me
the flame has been re-lit and is held in
the safest possible hands of king
charles iii
long live the king
yeah
afraid
thank you mr speaker
her majesty the queen was the heart of
windsor and it's in some ways fitting
that perhaps my words will be the last
in the tributes to her majesty
and i wish to pass on my condolences not
just from myself but from my many
constituents
to the royal family
she was an exceptional monarch through
an extraordinary era
even before her coronation the young
queen elizabeth made a vow to devote her
life to serving her country she kept her
promise
and she surpassed our expectations she
has been the constant in an
ever-changing world
not just for windsor but for the country
the commonwealth and in the hearts and
minds of all those around the world
she has been the embodiment of the
united kingdom she has been projecting
all that is good about our nation across
the globe for more than 70 years
her image
is our image to the world
and she was the omnipresent queen i've
been listening to this distributes in
this debate it seems that the queen has
been to every part of our united kingdom
everybody has a story to tell everyone
in this chamber has a story to tell and
i can tell you as the prime minister's
trade envoy to parts of west africa
everybody there had a story to tell
everyone has a story to tell about our
omnipresent queen
so nationally and internationally she is
recognized
yet amidst all her duties
responsibilities and commitments
she remained ever present in the windsor
constituency one of her favorite homes
you felt her presence everywhere across
the constituency absolutely everywhere
and as mpi the privilege of greeting
heads of state as they arrived in
windsor
albeit in the shadows of her majesty and
i could witness first hand her incisive
wit
her call and calm humor
which set guess that there is
and aside from royal ascot the savile
gardens seeing her at the cumbermere
barracks and the victoria barracks and
on military near military parades
virtually every constituent will have
seen or met the queen or knew somebody
very close who had and if you lived in
windsor there was no escape none
whatsoever if your australian winds a
great park you would inevitably bump
into the queen walking or driving or in
the past on the horse
your children would like to see her at
school or at college
and anyone
working for our many charities and good
causes it was inevitable they received
visits and great patronage from the
queen and when it comes to our
businesses
um if you um if the foundation stone of
their building was not laid by the queen
then the plaque was placed with the
queen's name or they received a letter
or an invite to the castle
and whether you knew it or not even when
you were shopping in the king edwards
7th center in central windsor it was
inevitable you're bumping you'd bump
into her majesty on occasion she was
everywhere she was truly omnipresent so
i'm not surprised i'm not surprised
that her last official engagement was at
the thames valley hospice
in our local area it makes sense in so
many ways
so in closing mr speaker
it is difficult for me to express just
how much she will be missed in windsor
and how thankful we are to have known
her she was our omnipresent queen the
queen of constance her image is our
image to the world in future in this
place and across the country we must
strive to live up to her image of us in
winds of the queen will live on in our
parks our lakes and our buildings and in
our memories and she will live on in her
eldest son and i say without hesitation
long live king charles iii
we now come to thank
the shadow leader of the house thank you
thank you mr speaker and and first of
all i say it must it is a great pleasure
to follow the honourable member for
windsor i had a feeling he'd have more
anecdotes than i did
it is also mr speaker it is truly an
honour to close these two days of
tributes to her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii i have heard almost all of
them either from in here or from my
office and truly every speech has been
superb
i'm so proud of us
how we her parliament have come together
to pay tribute
and i really think we have done her
proud
colleagues have sent condolences to the
royal family and on behalf of their
constituents and on behalf of the people
of bristol west and my own family i do
so too
from the opening speeches from the prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition followed by the father and
mother of the house to those here now
and i think the hundreds in between i'm
grateful to each and every colleague and
also of course to the clerks and the
doorkeepers and the staff who've enabled
this to happen i thank you truly thank
everyone it is impossible to do the
normal round-up closing speech and so
i'm going to try and pick out themes
instead because we have explored so many
of service and of faith
we've had poetry and prose and quite a
lot of comedy
there's been perspectives from history
and of progress
and i'm aware i hope i've got my dates
right that her majesty's first prime
minister was born in 1874 until last in
1975. what a span of historic of
historical perspective
many spoke wittily of their own time
with her to illustrate character i've
got to say if i'm going to pick one out
who knew that a plate of cheese has
delivered with a rye raised eyebrow by
the former prime minister the right hold
member for maidenhead could evoke the
queen so well
we've heard many stories of mishaps on
footstools mr speaker
some of them her majesty saving people's
dignity but some of them just managing
to turn into a comedy moment
the mother of the house and many others
spoke of the significance of her as a
female leader and role model and indeed
in her christmas broadcast in 1966 the
queen said it has been women who have
breathed gentleness and care into the
harsh progress of mankind i've think
about that one a lot in the last couple
of days
some colleagues spoke eloquently of
their time with her in other countries
the greatest diplomat on the world stage
in our corner representing britain and
many have talked movingly of her close
bonds and relationships with our armed
forces and others in uniform
we've toured all the nations and every
region seems like every village town and
city and with this the sense of pride
that she had in all of it and all of us
in this country where she has shaken
more hands unveiled more plaques and
gifted more smiles than anywhere else
i've learned a great deal more in fact
about how a constitutional monarchy
operates from those who interacted with
her majesty in governmental office and
of a kindness to those whose
governmental career had ended
shortly
ardent monarchists and those with a
different view alike expressed huge
respect for her dedication to public
service her ability to transcend
politics and to represent the national
mood meant that she was a unifying
figure through which the public could
share our nation's joys and bring that
much needed comfort in our country's
darkest hours i have to say i feel that
today that we have transcended politics
and come together in that way
many mentioned the pitch perfect
television statement that she made in
the pandemic so movingly connected our
collective trauma in those fearful
months in 2020 with the anguish
instilled from the world war ii
generation she managed to evoke vera
lynn's wartime will meet again message
it gives me a lump actually in my throat
so poignantly but also said that the
attributes of self-discipline have quiet
good human resolve and a fellow feeling
still characterized this country this
pride in who we are is not a part of our
past it defines our presence and our
future
some spoke of how age just 21 the then
princess elizabeth declared that her
whole life whether it be long or short
should be devoted to our service and
that was a promise she fulfilled right
until the very end
grief as so many have said her late
majesty said is the price we pay for
love but who who would want to live
without love so we suffer that grief
willingly
whatever the age our loved ones leave us
whether their life was long or short we
always grieve for that lost presence the
years we are robbed of we yearn for just
one more week one more day just one more
hour with them and knowing how that
feels
knowing that the royal family must be
feeling that right now even in the midst
of all the formalities and the public
duties so therefore we keep them in that
in our hearts
i hope that in reflecting on the queen's
life together in these last few days we
can appreciate the concept of a life
well lived because
in closing mr speaker whether you're a
brownie or an mp whether you work in the
nhs or in education a key worker or in
the pandemic or a volunteer if you work
in hospitality or a factory simply
you're a mother a father a brother or
sister friend or neighbor each day
brings all of us a new opportunity to
live up to the ideals set by the late
queen's life well lived because perhaps
that's the biggest tribute we can pay mr
speaker to the ultimate public service
conscious as we go about our lives of
how we can help one another of how we
can contribute to the common good and
work towards an even better britain in
doing in the doing of duty and service
we sometimes think of sacrifice but
hearing the tributes here
we can all recognize that these in fact
make a good life
we mps who willingly chose our life of
duty and service we can renew our
commitment to them now as we celebrate
the one who through though that life had
been thrust upon her followed it
unstintingly for 70 years we must carry
forward this elizabethan legacy of
public service for generations to come
for this truly is patriotism
may her late majesty the queen rest in
peace the legacy of the great
elizabethan age continue may his majesty
king charles iii have a long and
successful reign long live the king okay
i know called leader of the house
mr speaker it is an honor to bring to a
close the tributes paid to her most
gracious majesty queen elizabeth ii
i speak today as leader of the commons
but also for the people of portsmous
a city she visited not just for fleet
reviews civic events homecomings or ship
commissionings
but also in transit
to board her beloved royal yacht
britannia
in all cases the people of my city
remember her connection and
understanding to the tools of uk sea
power our sailors
our civilians
their families
our dockyard and our warships
for a time
that was her life too she'd worn a
uniform
she was a naval wife
she understood service and sacrifice
and the burdens people carried
that empathy
was evident in all that she did
so it was no surprise
to see hear so many tributes from
honorable and right honourable members
full of examples of that personal
kindness
or her concern and care
for the staff
of this estate
including her desire for the vice
chamberlain's weekly notes to keep her
up to speed on the gossip
she was our polaris
but she was not a distant queen
she took an interest in us all
because she recognized the burden of
service
her reign began
with a very public grief
because she could not mourn her father
in private
she loved balmoral
not just for its beauty and peace
but because she got to sleep in the same
bed for a whole six weeks
of all the exceptional things she did
of all the people and places experienced
her rare night of normality
of freedom out with her sister to
celebrate victory in europe
was in her words
one of the most memorable
for me
the fact that she met her new prime
minister
in person
and
prepared to take a privy council
24 hours before her death
illustrates the depth
of her devotion to duty
she lived and died in the service of the
nation
as her father did
and his father before him
so in the final analysis this then is
the measure of all greatness
it is not weighed by gain
but in loss
sacrifice is the ultimate test of faith
and duty
all that is yours
must be laid down
for all that is us
all that is they
must be laid down
for all that is we
for only those that bear this cross
can wear the crown
because crowns are not made just of
jewels and precious metals
they are mostly made of love
speaking after 9 11 she comforted us and
the rest of the world by saying that
grief was the price of love
her words should comfort her still
we may now feel lost and uncertain
just like some
may have felt 70 years ago
when she vowed that her life would be
dedicated to us
if only they knew
what a life she would lead
what glories and hope and vision she
would bestow
they need not have worried
and nor should we now
like his mother's grief at her father's
death
his majesty's grief too
will not be a private one
he will lead us in mourning
he also carries the cross
across of sacrifice
and service
our great queen has entrusted us all
with a living legacy
of triumph over tribulation
of cheerfulness
over challenge
of dedication and determination
she has left us
her values remain
with us
her example compels us to continued
fidelity
to our king
and our country
god save the king
i call them leave the house to move the
motion for the address
i beg to move that a humble address be
presented to his majesty
to convey to his majesty the deep
sympathy felt by this house
for the great sorrow which he has
sustained by the death of the late queen
his majesty's mother
to extend to all the royal family the
deep sympathy of this house in their
grief
which is shared by all its members
to assure his majesty that her late
majesty's unstinting dedication
over a reign of over 70 years to the
service of our great country and its
people
and to the service of the countries and
peoples of the rest of the wider
commonwealth will always be held in
affectionate and grateful remembrance
to express to his majesty our loyalty to
him
and our conviction that he will strive
to uphold the liberties and to promote
the happiness of the people in all his
realms
now and in the years to come
the question is that humble address be
presented to his majesty as on the order
paper the question is as on the other
paper as many of that opinion say aye
the eyes have it the eyes have it order
order
we now come to the motion relating to
the presentation of the arrest just
agreed to by the house i called the
leader to move forward
the question is the address be presented
by the whole house the question is as on
the order paper as many of that opinion
say aye
the eyes of it the eyes have it we now
come to the motion in the name of the
leader of the house relating to the
adjournment of the house i call the
leader
i beg to move
the question is as on the order papers
many of their opinions say aye
the eyes of it the eyes have it
just before we come to the german just
want to remind members that tomorrow at
six o'clock saint margaret's will be
holding our own service i hope as many
members and staff members will be able
to join us at that event and can i just
say
this has been an amazing tribute
when as i said yesterday when the house
comes together it comes together in a
very special way and there's been none
more special than these last two days
138 contributions today making a total
of
321 contributions
in total and i've got and personally
i've been moved and amazed by the way
that everybody's contributed all being
able to lay their own looking part of
their life that have been played in her
majesty so it's moving for me as i must
be one of the few constituencies
the queen never visited but there we are
so what i would say
and thank you once again to all the
staff of this house all the scooting
everybody who's made it
it really is appreciated and thank you
and thank you to all so the question is
that this house do not adjourn as many
of that opinion say aye
the eyes of it the eyes of it order
an
order
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons
sound house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons
sound house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of com